MLB
>> WHAT STANDS OUT TO ME IS
TWITTY FOR TIME ALL-STAR.
IT'S TRULY AMAZING BUT WE DID A
FEATURE ON HIM WHICH WE CAN SEE
ON OUR YOUTUBE PAGE.
IT WAS PRETTY COOL TO SEE THAT
NOT ONLY WAS HE A BASEBALL
PLAYER.
HE WAS AN ENTERTAINER.
THE BASKET CATCHES, THE FLARE,
THE DYNAMIC OF BEING ABLE TO
STEAL BASES, TAKING EXTRA BASES.
I THOUGHT THERE WAS AN EXTRA
INTANGIBLE WILLIE MAYS BROUGHT
TO THE TABLE THAT HE WOULD SAY
HEY, I WENT TO A BASEBALL GAME
AND THIS GUY CAUGHT MY EYE.
IT WAS SOMETHING FOR THAT
GENERATION THAT YOU WILL NEVER
FORGET.
I HEAR THE STORIES MY DAD WOULD
TELL ME.
HE WAS BY FAR THE BEST PLAYER ON
THE FIELD.
I LOVE THOSE VIDEOS.
>> THOSE NEVER GET OLD.
THE FLAMBOYANCE OF IT ALONG WITH
THE TALENT, AMAZING TO SEE.
WE WILL TALK WITH THE BRAVES,
THE NATIONALS.
ESTATE OUT THE HIGHLIGHTS FROM
LAST NIGHT.
>> BASES LOADED TWO DOWN.
HE STRIKES THE FIRST ONE AND
WANTED TO RIGHT FIELD.
IT IS GONE.
A GRAND SLAM FOR IS UNA ON THE
FIRST PITCH.
>> CONTRAST, 3-0 COUNT.
HE HITS IT TO CENTER FIELD.
CONTRERAS TO THE DEEPEST PART OF
THE BALLPARK.
>> FIRST CAREER HOME RUN FOR
WILLIAM CONTRERAS.
>> THE CHICAGO CUBS IS OUR NOW
FOR THE BRAVES.
THIS IS THE STANDINGS.
IT MIGHT BE THE BEST DIVISION IN
BASEBALL.
YOU GOT 4-5 TEAMS UNDER 500.
MARLON'S ARE JUST TWO GAMES OUT
OF 500.
BRAVES AND NATIONALS ARE THE
TEAMS YOU ARE SEEING TODAY, JUST
1.5 GAMES BEHIND.
WE'VE ALWAYS KNOWN HE IS A GREAT
PLAYER.
WHAT IF YOU SEEN SPECIFICALLY
FROM IN THIS YEAR?
>> HE JUST PUTTING EVERYTHING
TOGETHER.
IT'S NOT JUST ONE THING.
HE HAS A COMBINATION OF POWER
AND SPEED.
AS WE SEE HERE, WE ARE GOING TO
SEE THE NUMBERS.
HE LEADS THE LEAGUE'S IN RUNS,
HOME RUNS, SLUGGING, OPS, AND BY
THE WAY, HE IS 23 YEARS OLD.
>> HE IS A BABY.
>> THE PROSPECT OF POWER, HE HAS
TONS OF POWER.
TO BE ABLE TO GET ON TOP OF THAT
AND STILL HIT IT HARD ENOUGH TO
LEFT FIELD IS PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
THIS IS A CHANGEUP BELOW THE
STRIKE ZONE, KIND OF OUT OF
THIRD.
TO HAVE THE DISCIPLINE TO STAY
ON IT AND TAKE IT OUT TO RIGHT
FIELD, NOT MANY GUYS HAD THAT
ABILITY.
HE BRINGS A LITTLE FLARE.
HE IS EXCITING.
HE CAN RUN THE BASES.
THIS IS A VERY UNDERRATED, I
GUESS, QUALITY HE HAS.
HE GOT A LITTLE BIT OF FLAK
BECAUSE OF THE HUSTLE IN THE
PLAYOFFS A COUPLE YEARS AGO LIKE
MAYBE HIS ROTATION WAS WANING IN
THAT SENSE, BUT HE IS PUTTING IT
ALTOGETHER.
HIS EXTRA BASES HIS EX ARE HIGH,
GO FROM FIRST-THIRD, HE MAY CUT
THE BALL, HE MAKES IT LOOK EASY.
THAT ABILITY TO STRETCH DOUBLES
INTO TRIPLES, SCORE ON BASE HITS
SECOND BASE, PRETTY GOOD CLUB TO
RIGHT FIELD.
YOU SEE THE GLOVE WORK, YOU SEE
IS A GREAT CANNON.
-- GREAT CANNON FOR AN ARM.
HE IS A TOTAL PACKAGE AND ONE OF
THE GUYS WERE YOU GET SPOILED BY
SEEN THE TROUTS AND THE HARPERS
AND THE ACUNA JUNIORS, IN THE
EARLY 20'S, TAKING THE LEAGUE BY
STORM.
WHAT I LIKE MOST ABOUT THIS GUY
ISN'T 2019, 41 HOME RUNS AND 19
STOLEN BASES, -- 20 10.
IT TELLS ME HE IS WALKING MORE,
HE UNDERSTANDS WHAT HE SHOULD BE
SWINGING AT AND UNDERSTANDS WHAT
HE SHOULD NOT BE SWINGING AT.
THE SLUGGING IS GOING UP.
THAT COMES LATER IN YOUR CAREER,
BUT A 23, I PICTURE MYSELF A 23,
I WAS IN DOUBLE-A.
HE IS TAKING THE LEAGUE BY
STORM.
IT IS A TALENT WELL BEYOND HIS
YEARS AND SEEMS LIKE THE SKIES
ARE THE LIMIT FOR HIM.
THOSE TWO GUYS CAN PUT THEIR
TEAM ON THE BACK FOR 7-10 DAYS
AT A TIME AND SAY JUMP ON, I
WILL WHEN YOU 4-5 GAMES.
REAL SPECIAL TALENT.
>> HE PICKED UP AFTER A SLOW
START.
THAT OFFENSE IS GOING TO SCORE.
THAT WILL BE KEY FOR HIM.
WHO WILL WIN TONIGHT?
BRAVES OR THE NATIONALS?
THE PITCHING MATCHUP IS DREW
SMYLY VERSUS JON LESTER.
SMILEY HAS STRUGGLED OUT OF THE
GATES WITH 19 INNINGS PITCHED
AND 805 E.R.A..
SEE JON LESTER.
FIVE INNINGS PITCHED AND ZERO
RUNS.
WHO WINS TODAY?
ATLANTA OR WASHINGTON?
WHEN WE COME BACK ON OUR PREGAME
SHOW, ONCE AGAIN, BUILDING UP TO
THE BRAVES AND NATIONAL, COMING
UP AT THE TOP OF THE HOUR.
A GOOD MATCH HERE.
A COUPL
♪
>> THIS ONE IS OUTTA HERE.
>> THERE IT GOES.
GAME-WINNER.
C.
YOU.
LATER.
>> OH MY GOODNESS.
>> HUNDRED 12 MILES PER HOUR.
FINALLY GOT ONE.
>> OUT TO RIGHT CENTER.
THAT BALL IS TO THE MOON.
TWO HOME RUNS ON THE SEASON AND
BOTH OF THEM HAVE BEEN
WALK-OFFS.
>> THAT'S WHY IS IN THE BIG
LEAGUES.
>> NOT WHAT THIS GUY.
ONE BALL TWO STRIKES, TOP OF THE
NINTH.
SCHERZER IS HEADED THE LINEUP.
THIS GAME IS IN THE BOOKS.
FOR MAX SCHERZER, NINTH
STRIKEOUT OF THE AFTERNOON.
IT IS A COMPLETE GAME.
VICTORY, 12TH OF HIS CAREER AND
THE NATIONALS OUT OF THE DUGOUT
TO CONGRATULATE MATCHERS OR.
-- MAX SCHERZER.
>>
YOU ARE WATCHING THE GAME OF
THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW PRESENTED
BY GLOBAL CITIZEN BACKS LIVE.
STREAMING ON YOUTUBE ONLY THIS
SATURDAY ON 8 P.M. EASTERN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE WAR LEADERS
TO START 2019, TREA TURNER IN
THE MIX.
HE IS AHEAD OF JAVIER BAEZ AND
FERNANDO TATIS JR..
WE BRING IN TREA TURNER OF THE
WASHINGTON NATIONALS.
EVERY TIME I WATCH YOU, YOU'VE
GOT TO BE THE MOST UNDERRATED
STAR OF THE GAME.
DO YOU FEEL THAT WAY ABOUT
YOURSELF?
>> I DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT
STUFF.
I DON'T FOR THE GUYS ON CLUB
OUTS IN THE FANS IN THE STADIUM.
I ENJOY PLAYING THE GAME AND
COMPETING AND SHOWING UP
EVERYDAY AND TRYING TO GET THOSE
WINS.
I'M HAVING A LOT OF FUN DOING
IT.
I WILL LET YOU DECIDE THAT STUFF
BUT I ENJOY PLAYING.
>> I KNOW IT WAS A SHORT AND
SEASON LAST YEAR, BUT A MONSTER
SEASON FOR YOU.
YOU LEAD THE LEAGUE IN HITS,
TRIPLES, YOU ARE OFF TO A GREAT
START THIS YEAR.
DO YOU FEEL YOU ARE COMING INTO
YOUR OWN IN EVERY ASPECT OF YOUR
GAME?
>> I ALWAYS STRIVE TO GET
BETTER.
DEFENSIVELY, OFFENSIVELY, AND
BASERUNNING.
I AM ALWAYS SEARCHING FOR TWEAKS
AND TRYING TO BECOME MORE
CONSISTENT I THINK LAST YEAR, I
TOOK A GOOD STEP FORWARD.
I THINK IT STARTED IN 2019, TOOK
ANOTHER FORWARD STEP LAST YEAR
AND HOPEFULLY I CAN MAKE MORE
PROGRESS THIS YEAR IN ALL
FACETS.
I AM HAVING FUN WITH THE
COACHING STAFF AND COMING IN
EVERY DAY AND FINDING THOSE
TWEAKS.
HOPEFULLY, MAKE SOME MORE
PROGRESS.
>> OUR COLLEAGUE WROTE A GREAT
PIECE ON YOU LAST YEAR.
YOUR MOM TALKED ABOUT ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF BEING A BATTING
CHAMPION.
WHO CARES ABOUT THE OPS
CHAMPION, A BATTING CHAMPION IS
PRETTY COOL.
TELL ME ABOUT MOM AND GOING
AFTER BATTING CHAMPIONS.
>> MY MOMS THE HARD ONE.
MY DAD IS EASY.
IF I GO 3-4, SHE WILL ASK ME WHY
I STRUCK OUT.
SHE HAS ALWAYS BEEN ON ME SINCE
DAY ONE AND EARLY ON IN MY
BASEBALL CAREER.
SHE INSTILLED THE
COMPETITIVENESS IN KNEE.
EVERY TIME I CAN WIN SOMETHING I
THINK SHE'S HAPPY, WHETHER IT IS
STOLEN BASES, ADDING TITLES,
MOST HITS.
SHE WANTS TO SEE ME AT THE TOP.
SHE IS A HUGE FAN OBVIOUSLY.
WHATEVER IT IS LAST YEAR, THE
AVERAGE IN THE HITS AND WHAT
NOT.
I GOT HER FULL SUPPORT WHICH IS
NICE.
>> TREY, SEVEN HOME RUNS, SEVEN
STOLEN BASES, THAT IS ON PACE
FOR 40/40.
ARE THERE NUMBERS YOU ARE TRYING
TO ATTAIN DURING THE SEASON IN
THE STARTS?
>> I DON'T LIKE TO DO THAT.
WHAT IS A GOOD YEAR?
YOU GOT PEOPLE YOU GET LAST
YEAR, I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT GOOD NUMBERS
ARE PER SE.
I JUST TRY TO NOT GET ANYTHING
ALONG THAT THAT WAY.
EVERY DAY, YOU CAN GO FOR-FIVE
OUT OF AT-BATS, THEY WILL BE
WHATEVER THEY WILL BE.
FOR ME IT'S JUST COMPETING.
LAST NIGHT FOR EXAMPLE, WASN'T
SO GOOD IN THE FIRST HALF BUT
THEN SNUCK A HOMER IN THERE.
THAT IS WHAT I WANT TO DO EACH
AND EVERY DAY.
NOT GIVE STUFF AWAY AND JUST TRY
TO COMPETE.
>> ONE OF THE COOLEST STORIES
FOR THE NATIONALS SO FAR,
MATCHERS OR DOESN'T JUST THROW A
COMPLETE GAME, HIS WIFE
DELIVERED A BABY.
AND THEN HE'S THERE FOR THE
BIRTH.
>> THOSE TWO ARE AMAZING.
HIM AND HIS WIFE ARE AMAZING.
SHE HAD TO GO THROUGH THE WHOLE
THING, PREP FOR A CHILD AND HE
DIDN'T SHOW UP UNTIL AN HOUR OR
TWO BEFORE THE KID WAS BORN SO,
I TIP MY CAP TO HER.
SHE PROBABLY HAD A ROUGH DAY AND
I'M HAPPY EVERYBODY IS HEALTHY
AND THE BABY WAS BORN BUT HE
WENT OUT THERE AND THREW NINE
INNINGS AND HOPEFULLY GETS SIX
SHUTOUT INNINGS AND GET OUT OF
THE INNING AND GO SEE YOUR KID.
BUT HE HAD TO GO THE WHOLE NINE
AND THEN HE HAD TO MEET HIS KID.
GREAT DAY FOR THE SCHERZER
FAMILY.
>> THEREFORE BIG-TIME SHORTSTOPS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE FREE
AGENTS.
YOU ARE A FREE AGENT NOT NEXT
YEAR BUT THE YEAR AFTER THAT, IS
IT HARD NOT TO SEE THE
CONTRACTS, YOUR NUMBERS ARE UP
THERE WITH THESE GUYS, IT'S HARD
-- IS IT HARD TO TO THAT OUT AND
SEE WAS ON THE HORIZON FOR YOU?
>> I DON'T WANT TO TUNE IT OUT
BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE THAT THE
GAME IS IN A HEALTHY PLACE.
I'VE SET A TIME AND TIME AGAIN,
IF PLAYERS ARE GETTING A LOT OF
MONEY, THAT MEANS FANS ARE
SHOWING UP, FANS ARE WATCHING
THE GAME, THE GAME IS IN A GOOD
PLACE FINANCIALLY.
I WANT EVERYBODY TO GET AS MUCH
MONEY AS POSSIBLE AND FOR
EVERYBODY TO BE HAPPY.
FOR ME, YOU FOCUS ON WHAT IS IN
FRONT OF YOU, THE REST WILL TAKE
CARE OF ITSELF.
YOU GOTTA ENJOY PLAYING THE GAME
AND WHEREVER THOSE DOLLARS AND
UP, THEY END UP.
FOR ME, I JUST FOCUS ON TRYING
TO COMPETE AND TRYING TO WANE.
>> A LOT OF DOLLARS WILL BE
COMING YOUR WAY AND YOUR
TEAMMATE WHO IS INCREDIBLE TO
WATCH.
WHAT IMPRESSES ME THE MOST IS
THE ABILITY TO BE SUCH A GOOD
HITTER AT SUCH A YOUNG AGE, SO
HE'S PATIENT, HE DOESN'T SWING
AT BAD PITCHES.
WHAT IMPRESSES YOU MOST ABOUT
SOTO?
>> IS THE PLATE DISCIPLINE, BUT
ALSO THE COMPETITIVENESS.
THE MIND.
THE WORK ETHIC.
IT'S MANY THINGS.
ANOTHER THING THAT STANDS OUT
FOR ME IS THE EIFFEL TOWER AND
WE CAN DRIVE IT TO THE BALL AT
ALL FIELDS, YOU WILL BE
DANGEROUS.
HE KNOWS EVERY PITCH IN EVERY
ZONE.
IT WILL BE A BRIGHT CAREER FOR
HIM AND A SPECIAL CAREER FOR
HIM.
HE'S JUST GOT TO KEEP GOING AND
DOING WHAT HE IS DOING AND HE IS
ON THE RIGHT PAST -- PATH.
>> HE IS ON THE MEND.
HOPEFULLY, WE WILL SEE HIM AND A
FULL DH ROLE.
YOU GOT STRASBURG COMING BACK
SOON.
YOU GUYS ARE 12-14.
I'M SURE NOBODY IS HAPPY ABOUT
THAT BUT EVERYBODY IS BEATING UP
EACH OTHER IN THE DIVISION.
YOU'RE JUST 1.5 GAMES OUT.
WE LUCKY THAT NOBODY IS PULLED
AWAY IN THIS DIVISION?
>> I WOULD SAY A LITTLE BIT.
WE COULD'VE PULLED AWAY FOR THE
MOST PART.
I KNOW WE HAVE BEEN BANGED UP
BUT WE HAD CHANCES TO WIN
BALLGAMES.
IT'S ALL ABOUT PERSPECTIVE.
I THINK WE ARE IN A GOOD SPOT
RIGHT NOW IN THE LAST FEW YEARS.
STARTING 19-31, WE ARE OFF TO A
BETTER START AS OF RIGHT NOW.
IT'S ABOUT PERSPECTIVE,
COMPETING EVERY DAY, THE GUYS IN
THE CLUBHOUSE WE ARE IN A GOOD
SPOT MENTALLY AND PHYSICALLY OR
GETTING THERE I SHOULD SAY WHEN
WE GET THOSE GUYS BACK, IT WILL
BE TIME TO MAKE A PUSH AND GET
OUT TO A LEAD THAT IS NOT EASY.
EVERYBODY IS COMPETING.
EVERYBODY HAS KIND OF STRUGGLED
BUT IT'S ANYBODY'S DIVISION AND
WHY NOT US?
HOPEFULLY, AND HE'S NEXT FEW
WEEKS WE WILL PLAY BETTER.
>> I KNOW YOU DON'T SET GOALS
FOR YOURSELF.
BUT WITH A NAME LIKE TREA
TURNER, I WOULD HOPE YOU LEAD
THE LEAGUE IN TRIPLES.
IT MAKES SENSE IN MY HEAD.
WITH YOUR TALENT, IT IS ALWAYS A
POSSIBILITY.
HAD THEY CONTINUED GREAT REST OF
THE SEASON.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
I APPRECIATE IT.
♪
>> TIME NOW FOR A CREATOR
SPOTLIGHT.
I LOVE THESE GUYS.
BENNY NO, A GIGANTIC DODGERS
FAN, LOVES TO PLAY VIDEO GAMES
ABOUT WITH HIS CRAZY SON.
FINDING OUT HE WAS A DAD DURING
ATTENDING OK -- OPENING DAY ON
APRIL FOOLS' DAY IN 2013.
LET'S BRING HIM IN RIGHT NOW AND
HIS SON LUMPY.
I LOOKED IT UP, I THOUGHT IT WAS
LEFTY, NO, IT IS LUMPY.
HOW DID YOUR SON GET THE NAME
LUMPY?
>> WELL HE GOT THE NAME LIKE 30
SECONDS AFTER HE WAS BORN.
WHAT HAPPENED WAS HIS HEAD WAS
SUPER BUMPY.
FIRST NAME THAT CAME TO MY MIND
WAS, I WILL CALL HIM LUMPY.
JUST LIKE THAT, IT HAS BEEN HIS
NAME EVER SINCE.
>> WHAT YOUR REACTION WHEN YOU
TELL YOUR FRIENDS, MY NAME IS
LUMPY HOW ARE YOU?
>> I DON'T USUALLY DO THAT.
I JUST CALL ME BENNY.
I JUST DON'T KNOW THEM BUT
SOMETIMES THEY GET IT.
>> AS LONG AS THEY KNOW
SOMETHING ABOUT YOU, THAT IS
GOOD NEWS.
I KNOW YOU GUYS ARE GIANT
BASEBALL FANS.
WE LOVE PLAYING MLB THE SHOW.
WHICH TEAMS YOU GUYS PLAY AS,
DAD?
>> WE BOTH LIKE PLAYING WITH OUR
CREATIVE TEAMS.
WITH THOSE TEAMS, NEW PLAY WITH
ALL PLAYERS, NEW PLAYERS, AND
CREATE YOUR OWN PLAYERS.
I LOVE FRENCH FRIES.
WE USUALLY PLAY WITH THOSE
TEAMS.
IT'S A LOT OF FUN LIKE I SAID,
AND YOU GET TO PLAY WITH ANY
PLAYER YOU CAN FIND.
THE CREATIVE PLAYERS ARE WHAT
MAKES IT COOL.
HE PLAYS AS AN 18-YEAR-OLD
VERSION OF HIMSELF.
HE IS GOT A REALLY LONG BEARD.
THE PLAYER FROM HE HAS A HUGE
STOMACH, BELT PROTRUDES OUT AND
IT'S LIKE SPILLING OUT.
>> ANY TIME YOU ARE UP AGAIN THE
REAL GAME IS WHAT IS POSSIBLE.
MAKE YOURSELF A LITTLE SLIMMER,
IT'S OK.
YOU GUYS BOTH LOVE THE DODGERS.
LUMPY, WHO IS YOUR FAVORITE
DAUGHTER?
>> MOOKIE BETTS.
>> WHAT HE LOVE ABOUT MOOKIE
BETTS?
>> HE MENDICK COOL CATCH IN THE
WORLD SERIES.
AND HE CAN KEEP THROWING.
>> FAVORITE CURRENT DART DODGER,
THEN HE?
>> NO DOUBT, CLAYTON KIT --
CLAYTON KIT YOUR -- CLAYTON
KERSHAW.
HE IS THE BEST PITCHER I'VE EVER
SEEN.
ACTION GOT TO MEET HIM AND SIGN
MIGHT NO-HITTER TICKET STUB
WHICH WAS AWESOME.
OF COURSE, WATCHING HIM RUN ON
THE FIELD TO CELEBRATE WITH HIS
TEAMMATES --
>> I WAS BORN IN 2013.
>> WILL GET INTO THAT IN THE
SECOND, LUMPY.
I AGREE WITH BENNY.
WHEN THE DODGERS ACTUALLY ONE, A
CAMERA SHOWING THEM RUNNING OUT
WAS MY FAVORITE MOMENT.
WHEN THEY WERE TELLING CLAY, I'M
SO HAPPY FOR YOU, I'M SO PROUD
OF YOU.
IT WAS A GREAT MOMENT IF YOU
LOVE BASEBALL.
>> WHAT WAS YOUR FAVORITE MOMENT
OF THE DODGERS PLAYOFF RUN?
WHAT WAS YOUR FAVORITE MOMENT
WATCHING WITH YOUR DAD?
>> MY FAVORITE MOMENT IS WHEN HE
WENT DOWN AND HE WAS EXCITED.
MY DAD WAS THERE AND MY -- AND
HIS FRIEND WAS THERE.
>> MY FAVORITE MOMENT IS WHEN
THEY PULLED BLAKE SNELL OUT OF
THE GAME.
[LAUGHTER]
THE ENERGY WAS SUCKED OUT OF THE
BUILDING.
I MEMBER LOOKING AT MY FRIEND
BOBBY WHO WAS THERE AND WE WERE
LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT, WE ARE GOING
TO WIN THIS.
IT WAS EPIC AND WHEN THEY PULLED
HIM OUT, I WAS LIKE --
WE ARE FRIENDED PLACE SOFTBALL
AND WE CALL THEM T-MOBILE
BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY IT WORKS.
>> BLAKE SNELL GETTING PULLED, A
FORGETTABLE MOMENT FOR THE RAYS,
UNFORGETTABLE FOR THE DODGERS.
BENNY, WHAT YOUR ALL-TIME
FAVORITE MOMENT?
YOU CAN SAY 1981, AND A CANADIAN
SPAN, DON'T MENTION THAT.
FAVORITE ALL-TIME DODGERS
MOMENT?
>> UNTIL RECENTLY, IT WAS
DECLARED GIBSON MOMENT.
I SAW THAT AS A KID ON TV BUT
DEFINITELY INNING THERE IN
PERSON AND THEM WHEN IN 2020
TAKES THE CAKE FOR SURE.
I CAN'T IMAGINE TOPPING THAT
UNLESS THEY WANTED THIS YEAR AT
DODGER STADIUM.
WE WERE THERE FOR THE FINAL OUT,
THIS WAS OUR REACTION AND YOU
CAN SEE IT MY FACE RIGHT HERE.
IT WAS JUST JOYOUS.
SO MANY EMOTIONS.
DISAPPOINTED FOR SO LONG AND FOR
THE BEING ABLE TO SEE THEM WHEN
WAS PHENOMENAL.
>> LUMPY, DO YOU APPRECIATE HOW
COOL THIS IS?
YOU GET TO SEE A DOG'S WORLD
SERIES CHAMPION AND CELEBRATE
WITH YOUR DAD.
THE APPRECIATE HOW GREAT THAT
IS?
>>, YEAH.
>> IT'S AMAZING AS YOU SEE THIS
ONCE AGAIN.
>> THE ONE I HATED IT GET ME TO
GO TO WAS WITHIN HAVE THAT MANY
TICKETS.
>> WE DIDN'T HAVE AN EXTRA
TICKET FOR HIM BUT DON'T BE TOO
MAD.
HE WAS A GAME ONE OF THE 2017
WORLD SERIES SO HE HAS BEEN TWO
WORLD SERIES GAMES BEFORE JUST
NOT THERE TO SEE THEM WHEN IT.
>> BEGGARS CAN'T BE CHOOSERS
HERE.
LAST ONE FOR YOU, YOU MENTIONED
AT THE TOP.
SOME OF THE STORY WHEN YOU KNEW
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE LUMPY ACT
APRIL FOOLS' DAY TO DODGERS
GAME.
WHAT?
>> HIPPEL FIRST, 2013, IT WAS
OUR FIRST OPENING DAY AND WE GO,
CLAYTON KERSHAW HAS A PHENOMENAL
DAY, PITCHED A SHUTOUT, HIT A
HOME RUN TO CENTER FIELD, THEN
THEY WON THE GAME.
WALKING BACK TO THE CAR MY WIFE
CALLS ME AND SHE'S LIKE YOU'RE
GOING TO BE A DAD.
I'M LIKE OK IT'S APRIL FOOLS'
DAY.
FOR REAL?
NO, YOU'RE GOING TO BE A DAD.
IT'S BEEN ALREADY AMAZING DAY.
A COUPLE DAYS LATER, I GOT A
COMMEMORATIVE BASEBALL THAT HAD
THE OPENING DAY LOGO ON IT.
AT AS A BASEBALL I HOLD NEAR AND
DEAR TO MY HEART.
I STILL HAVE IT AND IT WAS JUST
A PHENOMENAL DAY.
THE WAY EVERY THING PLAYED OUT,
APRIL FOOLS OF COURSE, YOU HAVE
TO GET SOMEONE LIKE THAT.
>> NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
NOTHING SWEETER THAN THAT.
WE APPRECIATE YOU GUYS AND
LOVING TO L.A. DODGERS.
I JUST LOVE THE NAME LUMPY.
WHO IS THIS SOMETHING GUY?
INSTEAD, IT'S LUMPY BECAUSE OF
HOW HE CAME OUT AT BIRTH.
READ STUFF, GUYS.
WE WILL GET MASON T-BAR WITH
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
>> THANK YOU GUYS.
>> GREAT STUFF THERE.
ACUNA JR. HAS BEEN SENSATIONAL
SO FAR FOR THE BRAVES.
HE IS THE M.V.P. OF THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE WHEN HE IS ON TV, IT IS
MUST-SEE TV.
UR
GAME OF THE WEEK.
>> THAT BALL IS WAY OUT OF HERE.
>> HIGH FLY OFF BALL.
HE PUTS THE BRAVES IN FRONT.
TAKE A SELFIE, MARCEL AND THE
GRAND TOUR.
HE WAS STRUGGLING WITH THE
BREAKING BALL, AND YOU TALK
ABOUT THE EXTRA WORK THEY PUT IN
BEFORE THE GAME, AND IT PAYS
OFF.
>> FLY BALL, HE IS BACK, HOW FAR
IS THAT GOING?
>> HIS FIRST HIT SINCE APRIL 17.
481 FEET FOR ACUNA.
THAT BALL IS HAMMERED.
♪
>> WELCOME BACK TO THE GAME OF
THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW.
LIVE STREAMING ON'S YOUTUBE THIS
SATURDAY AT 8 P.M. EASTERN.
IT'S TIME FOR PICKS TO CLICK.
WE GOT SOME GOOD ONES HERE.
FOR THIS GAME, FIRST AND
FOREMOST, TOTAL RUNS SCORED,
OVER-UNDER?
>> I'M GOING UNDER.
JON LESTER IS COMING OFF A GOOD
START.
DREW SMYLY HAS GOT A COME BACK
TO THE AVERAGE.
HE'S GOTTA KEEP THE BALL IN THE
PARK.
HOME RUNS OF REALLY HURT HIM.
I WENT A GO 7-8.
>> YOU GOT A JON LESTER STORY
FOR ME?
>> ONE THING ABOUT HIM, HE IS A
MUCH BIGGER HUMAN BEING THAN YOU
THINK.
HIS BIG TREETRUNK LEGS, FEARLESS
, GREAT STORY IN 2007 WHEN HE
CAME OVER FROM HIS CANCER SCARE
AND WAS ABLE TO BE SO IMPORTANT
FOR US.
TO HAVE THAT GUY, TO START IN
THE WORLD SERIES, WAS SOMETHING
TRULY SPECIAL.
HE ALSO THREW A NO-HITTER.
JUST A LITTLE MILESTONE, I THING
THE PINNACLE WAS HE SIGNED A BIG
DEAL WITH THE CUBS AND HE LIVES
UP TO ALL THE HYPE AND
EXPECTATIONS.
THEY WIN A WORLD SERIES.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE TEAMMATES.
JUST A GREAT GUY.
HE IS A VALUABLE ASSET TO THE
NATIONALS, ESPECIALLY WITH THE
NATIONALS, I HOPE HE COMES BACK
SOON.
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED HIM.
>> HE WILL EAT UP INNINGS AND HE
CAN COMPETE ON THAT ONE YEAR
DEAL.
UPDATE ON AND NL EAST TEAM.
PHILLIES ARE TAKING ON THE
BREWERS.
ALEC BOHM, THAT TO THE BONE HERE
FOR THE PHILLIES.
THIS OFFENSE, THEY CAN HIT RUNS.
2-0, EIGHT K'S.
>> THE PHILLIES HAVE BEEN
TURNING ON THE JEWS LATELY AND I
THINK THAT'S A GOOD SIGN.
GOT A SLOW START.
MONSTER POP UP GOING THE OTHER
WAY.
GREAT PITCHING.
11 STRIKEOUTS AND THE END UP
WINNING THE GAMES.
AS A SET OF TOP, THIS MIGHT BE
THE BEST DIVISION IN BASEBALL.
INSTEAD, A LOT OF MEDIOCRITY
RIGHT NOW.
WHO YOU THINK WILL SEPARATE
THEMSELVES IN THE PACK?
>> I THINK ALL THOSE TEAMS HAVE
UNDERPERFORMED.
THE MARLINS ARE LAST-PLACE AND
TWO GAMES OUT.
ANYONE IS IN A RIGHT PLACE.
I STILL LIKE THE BRAVES.
HE CAME BACK YESTERDAY.
MIKE SOROKA, HOPEFULLY COMING
BACK LATER IN THE YEAR.
I THINK THE OFFENSE HAS LIVE
THINK IS THE M.V.P. SO FAR IN
ACUNA JR..
FREDDIE FREEMAN, A NICE MIX.
I THINK THEY WILL START TO TURN
IT ON AND BE ABLE TO SEPARATE
THEMSELVES.
>> I LIKE THE BRAVES AT THE
START OF THE SEASON.
AT THAT OFFENSE PICKS IT UP, WE
WILL SEE.
HOW ABOUT AN UNDERDOG PICK FOR
M.V.P. ECHO YOU MENTIONED ACUNA,
BUT IS THERE ANOTHER PLAYER THAT
YOU THINK IS UNDER THE RADAR?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF MY PICK IS
UNDER THE RADAR, BUT HE IS
BECAUSE IS A PICTURE, I'M GOING
WITH JACOB DEGROM.
FIVE STARTS, .5 E.R.A..
HE IS AVERAGING SUMMARY
STRIKEOUTS AND ONE WALK.
HE IS AVERAGING FIVE GUYS
GETTING ON BASE LET ALONE GIVING
UP RUNS.
IF FOR SOME REASON, HE CAN KEEP
THIS UP FOR SIX MONTHS, I THINK
THE NUMBERS WILL BE SO
STAGGERING THAT HE'S GOTTA GET
SOME M.V.P. VOTES.
>> CAN A PICTURE GET A M.V.P.
?
>> IF NO ONE ELSE STANDS OUT,
I'M OK WITH IT.
I AM NOT A HUGE FAN.
IF ACUNA JR. HITS 55, I THINK
GUYS LIKE THAT DESERVE IT.
THERE IS AN AWARD FOR PITCHERS.
>> I'M GOING MOOKIE BETTS.
PLUS, HE'S BEEN GREAT FOR THE
DAUGHTERS.
POLL RESULTS FOR OUR QUESTION
WAS WHO WILL WIN TODAY'S GAME?
BRAVES AT 70%.
NATIONALS AT 30%.
ACCORDING TO THE NUMBERS, IT'S
BEEN BRAVES WHO'S HAD THEIR
NUMBER.
THEY'VE WON 4-5 GAMES AGAINST
THE NATS.
ALL FIVE GAMES HAVE COME IN BC.
THE GAME IS COMING UP
MOMENTARILY.
SOME NEWS AND NOTES TO PASS
ALONG.
ALBERT WOULD PUJOLS TO BE AT THE
END OF A CAREER.
CARLOS CARRASCO'S THIS BONE THE
60 DAY I.L..
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO WILLIE MAYS.
CELEBRATING HIS 90TH BIRTHDAY.
OLDEST LIVING HALL OF FAMER.
COULD THIS BE THE LAST WE SEE OF
ALBERT PUJOLS?
>> HIS FIRST 10 YEARS WERE MIND
BLOWING.
I THINK HE AVERAGED 41 HOME RUNS
WITH OPS OVER 1000.
HE WAS 21, HOW WAS HE DOMINATING
THE LEAGUE?
KUDOS TO HIM.
INCREDIBLE CAREER.
IT WAS THE END, FIRST OUT HALL
OF FAMER.
IF NOT, SEMINAL PICK UP A GOOD
BATTER.
>> ONE OF THE GREATEST HITTERS
OF HIS ERA.
HIS FIRST TIME IN ST. LOUIS IS
WHY HE IS CALLED THE MACHINE.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR CHECKING US
OUT.
ENJOY THE GAME, EVERYBODY.
♪
>> DRIVES IT DEEP.
WHAT A PLAY!
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
OH, MY!
>> LATE AFTERNOON HARDBALL IN
D.C.
A MONUMENTAL ACCOMPLISHMENT TO
TAKE THIS DIVISION.
THEY GO AT IT ON A GLOBAL STAGE
TODAY.
THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE PRESENTED BY GLOBAL
CITIZENS BANK.
THE ATLANTA BRAVES HAVE ONE MORE
GO IN THIS SERIES.
AT NATIONALS PARK.
LET'S SAY HELLO TO THE GLOBAL
AUDIENCE WATCHING AND LISTENING,
WE ARE'S THRILLED TO BE WITH
YOU.
SCOTT BRAUN ALONG WITH THE
PERFECT PERSON TO CALL THIS GAME
-- MARK DEROSA HAS PLAYED FOR
THE WASHINGTON NATIONALS AND THE
ATLANTA BRAVES.
YOU KNOW THESE FRANCHISES VERY
WELL.
MARK: BOTH CLASSY ORGANIZATIONS.
BORN AND RAISED WITH THE ATLANTA
BRAVES BUT TOWARDS THE TWILIGHT
IN MY CAREER, GOT TO CATCH
LIGHTNING IN A BOTTLE WITH THE
NATIONALS IN 2012 WENT TO THESE
YOUNG PLAYERS WERE BURSTING ON
THE SCENE.
SCOTT: BREAKS FANS LIKE HIM,
NATS FANS LIKE HIM.
YOU KNOW WHO WE LIKE?
TWO OF THE MOST VIEWED PLAYERS
ON YOUTUBE, TREA TURNER AND
RONALD ACUNA JR.
LET'S START OFF WITH TREA
TURNER.
HE HAS BEEN ON FIRE LATELY.
WE KNOW HE CAN RUN BUT HE CAN
SLUG TOO.
MARK: THAT IS THE BIG THING.
TREA TURNER IS TAKING IT NEXT
LEVEL.
JUAN SOTO HAS BEEN OUT AND SINCE
2019, I THOUGHT HE WAS DAMAGED
GOODS IN THE POSTSEASON FOR THE
NATS.
WHAT HAS HE DONE IN THE PANDEMIC
SEASON?
HE WENT COMPLETELY OFF AND HE
HAS TICKED UP RIGHT WHERE 2020
LEFT OFF WITH THE POP.
TAKE A LOOK, LAST 15 GAMES, .356
BATTING AVERAGE BUT HE'S GOING
DEEP AND GOING DEEP WITH TWO
STRIKES ON HIM.
CONTINUES TO GET BETTER.
SINCE THE START OF THE 2020
SEASON HERE.
MARK: THESE A STUD.
DAVE MARTINEZ ALSO SAID HIS
DEFENSE HAS BEEN --
YOU WANT DEFENSE, SLUG, SPEED ON
THE BASIS?
RONALD ACUNA JR. IS YOUR MAN.
MARK: I WOULD ARGUE YOU TAKE
MIKE TROUT OUT, THIS IS THE MOST
EXCITING PLAYER IN THE ENTIRE
SPORT.
PROBABLY A GUY YOU WANT TO START
YOUR FRANCHISE WITH.
FIRST FOUR MAJOR LEAGUE SEASONS,
I DON'T KNOW, AVERAGING 43 BOMBS
PER 162 GAMES.
TALKING TO BRIAN SNITKER WHO HAS
BEEN WITH THE BRAVES
ORGANIZATION FOR MORE THAN 45
YEARS, EVERYONE FROM ANDRUW TO
CHIPPER JONES, BRIAN MCCANN, THE
LIST GOES ON AND ON.
HE SAYS NOBODY IS MORE TALENTED
THAN RONALD ACUNA JR. WHO WAS
EVER PUT ON AND ATLANTA BRAVES
UNIFORM.
YOU LOOK AT THE 2021 SEASON
BREAKDOWN.
AN EPIC START, 4-19 WITH SEVEN
BOMBS -- .419 WITH SEVEN BOMBS.
SINCE COMING BACK WITH THE
STRAIN, HE HAS STRUGGLED MORE OF
THE SAME WITH THE ENTIRE LINEUP.
MARK: ACKERMAN YESTERDAY, THAT
IS A
LINEUP SENT FIRST PAGE FROM THE
CAPITAL OF U.S.A..
IT IS FREE ON YOUTUBE.
TELL YOUR FRIENDS.
>> SWING AND A HIGH FLY BALL.
A TAPE MEASURE SHOT IN
CINCINNATI.
>> GET USED TO THAT, MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL.
>> SWING AND A DRIVE.
HE HAS DONE IT AGAIN.
>> HOMERS IN FIVE CONSECUTIVE
GAMES.
A HIGH FLY BALL DEEP TO LEFT
FIELD.
A GRAND SLAM FOR ACUNA!
>> FAIR BALL.
IT'S A WALKOFF.
>> HIT IN THE AIR TO DEEP RIGHT
FIELD.
AT THE WALL.
TIED UP AT 3-3.
>> YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT ONE OF
THOSE LET THE KIDS PLAY MOMENTS?
WE JUST SAW ONE.
HE LAYS OUT AND MAKES THE DIVING
CATCH!
>> THAT IS WAY OUT OF HERE.
ACUNA IS GOING TO TAG.
HE'S GOING TO MAKE IT!
A SAC FLY TO SECOND.
FLY BALL.
LONG HOME RUN.
HE'S HOTTER THAN THE GEORGIA
ASPHALT.
SCOTT: ALMOST GAME TIME AND
YOU'RE STARTING NINE FOR THE
VISITING ATLANTA BRAVES IS
PRESENTED BY GLOBAL CITIZEN VAX
LIVE.
WE HAVE SEEN TWO GRAND SLAMS
THIS SERIES.
WHAT ABOUT A THIRD?
THIS RUN FROM ACUNA.
HE'S LEADING BASEBALL TIED WITH
THE MOST HOMERS WITH 10.
SWITCHHITTING ALBIES HITTING
SECOND.
LET'S START WITH RONALD ACUNA
JR.
WE ARE UNDERWAY ON YOUTUBE WITH
A GLOBAL AUDIENCE.
SCOTT AND MARK DEROSA WITH YOU.
ATLANTA BRAVES, WASHINGTON
NATIONALS FINISHING UP A
THREE-GAME SET.
HERE'S THE GUY THAT CAN DO IT
ALL.
IN ON THE HANDS.
THAT'S EXACTLY THE KIND OF PITCH
H JON LESTER WANTS TO DO ALL
DAY LONG.
YOU KNOW THIS GUY.
I THINK I HAVE MET HIM A TIME OR
TWO.
37 YEARS OLD, COMING OFF HIS
FIRST START OF THE SEASON.
A LITTLE BIT OF A DELAY FOR A
VARIETY OF ISSUES, INCLUDING THE
COVERT INJURED LIST.
HE LOOKED GOOD IN START NUMBER
ONE.
70 PITCHES, FIVE INNINGS FOR THE
NATIONALS.
HE CAN GO AS LONG AS HE WANTS TO
GO, HE IS JON LESTER.
HE IS VERY DURABLE, AS HE MISSES
UPSTAIRS TO OZZIE ALBIES.
MARK: THIS IS THE GUY, NO ONE IS
MORE PREPARED.
HE KNOWS HE'S GETTING TO THE
TWILIGHT OF HIS CAREER.
HE KNOWS HE HAS TO DO THINGS A
LITTLE DIFFERENTLY TO GET READY
FOR A SEASON.
2020 WAS A WASH FOR A LOT OF
THESE VETERAN BALLPLAYERS.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PITCH IN A
ROTATION WITH MAX SCHERZER AND
STEPHEN STRASBURG.
CANNOT PASS UP THE OPPORTUNITY
TO POSSIBLY GET BACK INTO THE
POSTSEASON.
SCOTT: ALBIES SWINGS AND MISSES
ON A PITCH UP.
DAVE MARTINEZ HAS SAID TIME AND
TIME AGAIN, AS WE CHECK OUT THE
SPRAY CHART FOR ALBIES.
A SWITCH HITTER TOO, KEEP IN
MIND.
DAVE MARTINEZ SAID THE KEY FOR
JON, KEEP THE BALL DOWN.
ALBIES WITH A LAZY FLY BALL TO
CENTER.
THAT IS PUT AWAY BY ROBLES.
FOR A LITTLE MORE ON JON LESTER,
THE BREAKDOWN IS PRESENTED BY
GLOBAL CITIZEN VAX LIVE.
MARK: THE FIRST TWO A.B.'S, JAM
SANDWICHES FOR ALBIES AND ACUNA.
MOVE THE PLATE, HE WANTS YOU.
HE WANTS TO DRIVE THAT CUTTER IN
AND GET YOU THINKING SIX INCHES
OFF THE CENTER HALF IS A STRIKE.
OK, DRIVE DOWNHILL.
WE TALK TO DAVE MARTINEZ IN THE
PREGAME.
IN TODAY'S DAY AND AGE OF
DRIVING THE BALL NORTH AND
SOUTH, JON HAS TO WORK DOWN IN
THE ZONE WITH HIS CHANGEUP,
CUTTER, FOUR-SEAM COMBINATION.
SILENT MOTIVATION.
I HAVE KNOWN MR. LESTER A LONG
TIME.
THE $11 MILLION THEY HANDED TO
DREW SMYLY, I THINK JON WOULD
HAVE ENJOYED GOING TO ATLANTA.
THE $6 MILLION TO JAKE ARRIETA
IN CHICAGO, JON WOULD'VE LIKED
AN OPPORTUNITY.
HE IS PITCHING FOR THE NATS.
I KNOW HE'S HAPPY AND HEALTHY
BUT THERE IS SOME SILENT
MOTIVATION.
LITTLE CHIP ON THE
SHOULDER OF THE VETERAN SOUTHPAW
WHO GETS THROUGH THE TOP THREE
IN THE ORDER FOR ATLANTA.
WE WILL INTRODUCE YOU TO THE
NATS LINEUP WHEN WE COME UP.
>> RONALD ACUNA SINGLED FIRMLY
TO LEFT FIELD.
THIS ONE STRUCK WELL TO CENTER
FIELD.
ROBLES.
A CLOSING CATCH.
DIVES ONTO THE WARNING TRACK.
WHAT A PLAY.
THAT BALL WAS ABSOLUTELY
ROASTED.
THE STANDING "O" FROM THE CROWD.
>> RONALD ACUNA JR.
AND THE FLY BALL HIT TOWARDS THE
SCOREBOARD AT RIGHT CENTER.
DID HE GET ENOUGH?
YES, HE DID.
RONALD ACUNA JR. BREAKS THE
SCORELESS TIE.
HE IS A DOUBLE DIGITS.
10TH HOMER OF THE YEAR AND THE
BRAVES STRIKE FIRST.
>> ATLANTA HAS THEM LOADED WITH
TWO OUTS.
A HIGH FLY BALL CENTER.
THAT BALL IS GOING TO GO.
IT IS A GRAND SLAM!
>> THAT WAS A NO DOUBTER.
>> HE KNEW IT.
LOOK AT THE SMILE ON HIS FACE.
>> MISSED THE LAST EIGHT GAMES
WITH LEFT SHOULDER STRAIN.
>> WELCOME BACK, JUAN SOTO.
SCOTT: NATIONALS HALF OF THE
FIRST COMING UP ON YOUTUBE.
EASY TO FIND US.
IT IS FREE FOR EVERYONE WATCHING
WORLDWIDE.
JOIN THE NEARLY 3 MILLION OTHER
FANS IN SUBSCRIBING TO THE MLB
YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
YOU CAN RECEIVE NOTIFICATIONS
PRIOR TO UPCOMING GAMES.
IF YOU ARE YOUTUBE TV CUSTOMER,
YOU GET EVEN MORE HOOKED UP.
NOW YOUR NATIONAL STARTING
LINEUP PRESENTED BY GLOBAL
CITIZEN VAX LIVE.
TREA TURNER, CRUSHING AVERAGE
THIS SEASON.
YADIEL HERNANDEZ IN FOR JUAN
SOTO WHOSE AVAILABLE OFF THE
BENCH.
AT THE TOP OF THE ORDER FOR THE
NATIONALS.
A STRIKE DELIVERED BY DREW SMYLY
ON THE MOUND, MAKING HIS FIFTH
START OF THE SEASON.
GAVE UP THREE HOME RUNS, FIVE
RUNS IN FIVE INNINGS AGAINST THE
TORONTO BLUE JAYS IN A LITTLE
BALLPARK IN FLORIDA LAST TIME
OUT.
MARK: I WANT YOU TO TAKE A LOOK
AT TREA TURNER.
HE DOES SOME THINGS I HAVE SEEN
VETERAN BALLPLAYERS DO.
0-1, YOU WILL SEE HIM GIVE THIS
MODIFIED LEG KICK.
WITH TWO STRIKES, 0-2, HE SETS
HIS FRONT FOOT DOWN, TAKES ALL
THE MOVEMENT OUT OF HIS SWING
AND PLAYS PEPPER.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE WITH THE
TREA TURNER THIS YEAR, HE IS
PLAYING PEPPER AND GOING DEEP.
SCOTT: HE SAID THAT POP.
UNLEASHED EVEN MORE SO THIS
YEAR.
SEVEN HOME RUNS ALREADY THIS
SEASON.
.414 AVERAGE IN HIS LAST 10
DAYS.
BEST IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE
DURING THAT TIME PERIOD.
NUMBER TWO IS AUSTIN RILEY,
PLAYING FIRST BASE TODAY.
FREDDIE FREEMAN GETTING THE DAY
OFF, ALTHOUGH AVAILABLE OFF THE
BENCH.
WE COULD HAVE FREEMAN AND SOTO
OFF THE BENCH LATER.
TURNER SWINGS THROUGH.
GOOD START FOR DREW SMYLY.
MARK: IT IS TOUGH AS A MANAGER.
YOU GIVE THE SUPERSTARS DAYS
OFF.
SEE RIGHT HERE, THE NICE FEEL
FOR A BREAKING BALL.
HE HAS BEEN THROWING THAT
PITCHED A TON THIS YEAR IN THE
EARLY GOING.
AT NO POINT UNLESS HE HAS A
CHANCE TO TRULY THE BASEBALL
GAME DOES BRIAN SNITKER WANT TO
LOOK DOWN TO FREDDIE AND TELL
HIM TO GET IT GOING.
HE WAS TO GIVE HIM THE FULL
MENTAL DAY OFF TO RELAX.
SCOTT: SMYLY HAS BEEN HIT HARD
SO FAR THIS YEAR.
E.R.A. NORTH OF 5.00.
YOU KNOW YOU WILL BE TEMPTED IF
IT IS CLOSE.
YESTERDAY WAS REALLY CLOSE LATE
IN THE GAME.
MARK: YES.
SCOTT: I KNOW DAVE MARTINEZ
THOUGHT ABOUT JUAN SOTO IN PLACE
OF VICTOR ROBLES AND A HUGE SPOT
IN THE EIGHTH INNING, BUT
WOULDN'T PULL THE TRIGGER.
SOTO PINCH HIT IN THE NEXT
INNING.
MARK: I TOTALLY UNDERSTOOD THAT
MOVE.
YOU ARE NOT PINCHHITTING FOR A
STARTER OF VICTOR ROBLES' ILK IN
THAT SITUATION.
THAT COULD DO MORE DAMAGE TO
VICTOR MENTALLY THAN GET THE
BOYS GOING IF JUAN COMES UP.
SCOTT: THEY ALSO DIDN'T HAVE ANY
OUTFIELDERS AVAILABLE AFTER
THAT.
IT WOULD BE JOSH BELL IN THE
OUTFIELD FOR THE NATIONALS.
MARK: WHICH I AM SURE HE CAN DO.
SCOTT: LET'S BREAKDOWN MR. DREW
SMYLY.
MARK: I HAVE BEEN A CHANCE TO BE
IN THE BOX WITH THIS LEFT-HANDER
EIGHT YEARS AGO.
LATE LIFE.
YOU WILL SEE THE FOUR-SEAM
FASTBALL AND YOU WILL WONDER
WHY.
HIS BAL PRESENTS ITSELF 92
COMING OUT BUT IT HAS GOT SOME
NICE RUN THROUGH THE ZONE.
ELEVATE.
WE TALKED ABOUT MR. LESTER
WORKING DOWN IN THE ZONE, YOU
WILL SEE A HIGH HEATER AND THEN
YOU WILL SEE HIM TUNNEL THE
BREAKING BALL OFF OF THAT.
AND SWING MODE.
THE REASON I WRITE THAT, WHEN
YOU ARE FACING DREW SMYLY, WHEN
HE'S AROUND THE DISH, EVERYTHING
MORPHS INTO ONE PITCH AND HE GET
YOU THINKING THAT EVERYTHING'S A
STRIKE AND YOU START PULLING THE
TRIGGER AND YOU GET SITUATIONS
WHERE YADIEL HERNANDEZ DOES NOT
KNOW IF HE SHOULD PULL THE
TRIGGER OR TAKE IT.
SCOTT: TWO QUICK STRIKEOUTS FOR
SMYLY.
THE SCOUTING REPORT PRESENTED BY
GLOBAL CITIZENS VAX LIVE.
DREW WAS A REVELATION LAST YEAR.
STRIKE OUT STUFF AND LIMITED
WORK.
THAT IS WHY THEY SIGNED HIM.
MARK: THE METRICS WERE IN LOVE
WITH MR. SMILEY LAST YEAR ALL I
CAN TAKE YOU THROUGH IS MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE IN THE BOX
WITH THIS GUY.
I LOVE FACING LEFT-HANDED
PITCHING.
I GET IN THE BOX AGAINST MR.
SMILEY, THAT HEATER IS MOVING
QUICKER THAN THEY GIVE HIM
CREDIT FOR.
SCOTT: SLIPPED A LITTLE BIT OVER
AT THE HOT CORNER.
AND JOSH HARRISON IS ABOARD.
TWO-OUT BASE RUNNER FOR THE
NATIONALS.
MARK: WHEN IT IS GOING YOUR WAY,
JOSH HARRISON GETS OFF TO A HOT
START, GET THE INFIELD KNOCKS.
TOOK A HOP ON MR. ADRIANZA RIGHT
THERE.
NOT ABLE TO MAKE THE PLAY.
SCOTT: HARRISON HAS REACHED BASE
SAFELY IN 17 OF 20 GAMES THIS
SEASON.
ADRIANZA CAN PLAY ALL OVER THE
FIELD.
TODAY AT THIRD SO THAT RILEY CAN
PLAY FIRST IN PLACE OF FREDDIE
FREE.
CLEANUP HITTER TODAY, STARLIN
CASTRO.
LOOK AT HIM DOING DAMAGE AGAINST
LEFT-HANDED ETCHING THIS SEASON
-- PITCHING THE SEASON.
BIG START.
RYAN ZIMMERMAN OFF THE BENCH.
HE CAN HIT LEFTY AS WELL.
MARK: NOT SHOCKED.
YOU SEE A LOT OF THESE VETERAN
HITTERS, THE STARLIN CASTROS,
RYAN ZIMMERMANS OF THE WORLD,
THEY WILL WEAR OUT TO LEFT
CENTER GAP AGAINST LEFT-HANDED
PITCHING.
GIVE THEM A CHANCE LINE TO LINE
TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
SCOTT: YESTERDAY, THIS LINEUP
HAD TROUBLE AGAINST MAX FRIED
FOR ATLANTA.
JUST MISSED FOR SMYLY.
1-1.
MARK: IF HE'S GOT THAT CURVEBALL
WORKING, A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
TROUBLE AGAINST HIM.
SCOTT: BRAVES FANS WERE HYPED TO
SEE THE MAX FRIED WHO LOOKED
MORE LIKE THE 2020 VERSION WHO
WAS FANTASTIC.
THIS IS THE GUY THEY WANT TO GET
GOING.
SMYLY'S 1-1.
AND IT'S 2-1.
HE STRUCK OUT 42 BATTERS LAST
YEAR IN 36.1 INNINGS FOR THE
GIANTS.
THE GIANTS KNOW HOW TO FIND
STARTING PITCHING.
MARK: THIS YEAR TOO.
SCOTT: ALEX WOOD.
MARK: DESCLAFANI OUT THERE.
SCOTT: NINE HOME RUNS ALLOWED.
HIGHEST HOME RUN RATE IN
BASEBALL.
MARK: YOU SEE THAT HEATER RIGHT
THERE, 93.
IT PLAYS HOTTER.
STARLIN, NOW YOU WILL SEE HIM
SHORTEN HIS SWING NOW.
HE WILL NOT PUNCH OUT ON A
SIMILAR FASTBALL IN THAT
SITUATION.
SCOTT: TWO STRIKEOUTS AND IN
INFIELD SINGLE.
HERE IT COMES.
JOSH HARRISON IS ON FIRST.
HE IS ALSO MIC'ED UP TODAY WHICH
IS AWESOME.
>> MIC CHECK, 1-2, 1-2.
WANT TO SAY SOMETHING TO THE
PEOPLE?
THEY WATCHING ON YOUTUBE.
HEY, THAT'S FOR MY BOY.
TWO DAYS, I DIDN'T DROP A COUPLE
POP-UPS.
BOGEY GOT ME RIGHT.
SCOTT: THAT'S AWESOME.
MARK: I HAVE HEARD TIM BOGAR'S
NAME A LOT.
TREA TURNER DEFENSIVELY, HELPING
JOSH HARRISON.
SCOTT: THERE IS THE BAG FOR
STARLIN CASTRO.
MAKE THAT HARRISON, SORRY.
CASTRO AT THE PLATE.
HARRISON TAKING THE BAG.
I WONDER WHAT HE SAYING.
IF HE SAYS ANYTHING GOOD, WE
WILL HAVE THAT FOR YOU.
AUSTIN RILEY ALSO MIC'ED UP.
HE'S ALWAYS TALKING, HARRISON.
HE'S FINE, HE CONDENSED.
ENTERTAINING.
BALL FOUR TO CASTRO.
SCRATCH THAT.
NO MIC FOR RILEY.
IT IS ALL JOSH HARRISON PUTTING
ON A SHOW TODAY.
HE WILL PROVIDE PLENTY OF
COMMENTARY FOR US.
I KNOW YOU SAW LAST WEEK WE HAD
SHANE BIEBER AND NELSON CRUZ.
YOU PLAYED IT THE OTHER DAY ON
YOUR SHOW.
SHANE BIEBER TALKING ABOUT
CHARCUTERIE.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK: YES.
SCOTT: ONE OF HIS TEAMMATES
PRONOUNCED IT "CHAR-SHOO
TER-REE".
GET OUT OF HERE.
SWITCHHITTING JOSH BELL.
TWO POWER BATS THAT THE NATS
PICKED UP IN THE OFF-SEASON.
OFF TO A SLOW START, BUT DAVE
MARTINEZ IS SAYING HE STARTING
TO SEE SOME BASEBALLS IN THE
AIR.
THEY ARE FEELING LIKE IT IS
COMING.
MARK: HE HAS TO HIT, BOTTOM
LINE.
THE NATIONALS ARE GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
JOSH BELLS, PATRICK CORBIN --
THEY HAVE TO REDEFINE WITH THE
BACK OF THE BASEBALL CARD HAS
ALWAYS BEEN.
SCOTT: ALBIES HAS PLENTY OF TIME
TO PUT HIM AWAY.
NATIONALS.
NOTHING TO SHOW FOR IT.
SCORELESS AFTER ONE IN D.C.
>> NOW FREDDIE FREEMAN GOING
RIGHTY RIGHTY WITH OZUNA.
HE SWINGS THE FIRST ONE AND
LAUNCHES INTO RIGHT FIELD.
HARRISON BACK, TURNS.
IT IS GONE!
A GRAND SLAM FOR OZUNA ON THE
FIRST PITCH.
>> SPARKING THE BIG RALLY IN THE
THIRD INNING.
>> HE LIFTS ONE TO CENTER
FIELD.
TO THE DEEPEST PART OF THE
BALLPARK.
>> FIRST CAREER HOME RUN FOR
WILLIAM CONTRERAS.
>> LEFT FIELD.
YAN GOMES HAS HIS SECOND HOME
RUN.
THIS GUY IS HEATING UP.
>> HIS 13TH APPEARANCE.
>> STRIKE THREE CALLED.
AN IMMACULATE INNING FOR KYLE
FINNEGAN.
NINE PITCHES, THREE K'S.
>> KYLE FINNEGAN STRIKES OUT THE
SIDE ON NINE PITCHES.
AN IMMACULATE INNING.
>> SWING AND A LONG DRIVE TO
LEFT FIELD.
GONE, GOODBYE.
IT'S A TWO RUN HOMER FOR TREA
TURNER.
>> BASES FULL FOR VICTOR ROBLES.
>> THE PITCHES HIT HIGH IN THE
AIR TO LEFT.
ON THE FIRST PITCH, BRAVES GET
OUT OF IT.
>> NATS GET TWO FOR DON'T GET
THE LEAD -- BUT THEY DON'T GET
THE LEAD.
>> EXCITED TO JOIN YOU LIVE FROM
NATIONALS PARK.
THIS GAME HAS ALL THE MAKINGS TO
BE SO EXCITING.
JUAN SOTO AVAILABLE OFF THE
BENCH.
RONALD ACUNA JR.
TWO YOUNG GUYS IN THIS LEAGUE
THAT ARE FUN AND EXCITING TO
WATCH.
I BLESS YOU GUYS BACK ON THE
STUDIO AND ON YOUTUBE, IF YOU
ARE BUILDING A FRANCHISE OR TEAM
RIGHT NOW, WHO WOULD YOU BUILD
ONE AROUND?
WE HAVE A FEW OPTIONS.
JUAN SOTO, RONALD ACUNA JR.,
FERNANDO TATIS JR., AND BLACK.
AND VLAD GUERRERO JR.
SCOTT: REALLY PUTTING THE
PRESSURE ON.
YOU CAN'T GO WRONG, CAN YOU?
WE WILL LOOK 10 YEARS AGO, THAT
GUY WAS THE CHOICE.
MARK: YES AND NO.
I THINK YOU'VE GOT THREE
POTENTIAL GUYS DESTINED FOR
COOPERSTOWN IF HEALTH -- LISTEN,
JUAN SOTO IS TED WILLIAMS,
RIGHT?
WHAT DID YOU WANT?
THE GUARANTEED OFFENSE OF
PLAYER, DO YOU WANT MORE SWAG
AND FLASH?
SCOTT: MORE TOOLS.
MARK: I LEAN TOWARDS WHAT I WAS
BORN AND RAISED TO DO AND THAT
IS PLAY A PREMIUM DEFENSIVE
POSITION UP THE MIDDLE.
CONTROL THE GAME ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE BALL.
FERNANDO TATIS JR. FOR ME,
PLAYING SHORTSTOP EVEN THOUGH HE
STRUGGLED DEFENSIVELY, WHAT HE
BRINGS WITH THE ENTIRE SKILL
SET.
SCOTT: OUT IN RIGHT.
MARK: I WOULD GLADLY TAKE JUAN
SOTO.
SCOTT: SODA WOULD BE OUT IN
RIGHT.
HERNANDEZ REPLACING HIM TODAY.
HE WILL HOPEFULLY PINCH-HIT
LATER ON AND DH THIS WEEKEND
AGAINST THE YANKEES.
BY NEXT WEEK, BACK ON THE FIELD
COMING OFF A SHOULDER ISSUE.
REHABBING WILEY'S UP ON THE
BIG-LEAGUE TEAM.
HE'S OK TO HIT BUT NOT READY TO
PLAY IN RIGHT FIELD.
RILEY FLIES OUT AND NOW IT IS
SWANSON.
POLL RESULTS LATER, BY THE WAY.
BRAVES AND NATS FANS PROBABLY
DOMINATING THE SECTION RIGHT
NOW.
MARK: I AM SURE THEY ARE.
I WOULD GLADLY PICK THIRD TOO.
SCOTT: IN THAT FANTASY DRAFT?
MARK: I WOULD GLADLY TAKE THEM.
SCOTT: FROM OUR YOUTUBE CREATORS
IN THE LIVE CHAT RIGHT NOW.
ANTONELLI BASEBALL SAID ACUNA
FOR ME, BUT I WILL TAKE ANY OF
THEM.
MARK: 87, THAT IS A GOOD TAKE BY
DANSBY SWANSON.
JON TRIED TO PRESENT THAT MIDDLE
IN HEATER AND GOT A JAM SANDWICH
AND DANSBY SWUNG AT THAT PITCH.
DANSBY IS FIGHTING A BATTLE
RIGHT NOW.
SO I SIT FASTBALL IN OR CHANGEUP
OUT OVER?
SCOTT: HITTER'S COUNT.
ONE HOMER AGAINST LESTER IN HIS
CAREER.
THERE IS A STRIKE.
WORKING THE OTHER END OF THE
PLATE.
MARK: TALKED ABOUT MOVES IN THE
DANSBY THOUGHT THE PLATE MOVED
A LITTLE BIT IN.
JUST THINKING THAT PITCH RIGHT
OUT OF THE HAND.
PROBABLY WAS A BALL OUTSIDE, BUT
MR. LESTER HAS BEEN DOING IT A
LONG TIME.
THE LITTLE CUTTER.
SCOTT: THAT ONE MISSED.
EXTRA FEW INCHES OFF THE PLATE.
SWANSON RECEIVES THE BASE A
PITCH LATER.
DANSBY 0-8 IN HIS FIRST TWO
GAMES IN THIS SERIES.
TWO FOR HIS LAST 18 BUT HE'S ON
BOARD WITH ONE DOWN IN THE TOP
OF THE SECOND.
THAT BRINGS US TO ADRIANZA.
ONE FOR HIS LAST 11.
THE STORY CONNECTED TO HIM, WHY
HE IS PLAYING TODAY.
RILEY TO FIRST.
FREDDIE FREEMAN RECEIVING A DAY
OFF, A MENTAL BREAK.
THE FIRST DAY OFF OF THE SEASON
FOR THE REIGNING N.L. M.V.P. --
HIS SWING LOOKS A LITTLE OFF FOR
ME.
MARK: IT IS FUNNY.
FREDDIE IS NOT A GUY THAT I SIT
HERE AND TRY TO BREAK DOWN ALL
THESE SWINGS.
I DIDN'T LEARN TO BE COMFORTABLE
IN THE BOX UNTIL I WAS ALMOST 30
YEARS OLD.
THAT IS WHY I GRIND SO HARD ON
IT, TRYING TO STUDY IT.
ASK ALL THE VETERANS AND THE
CURRENT PLAYERS, THE YOUNGER
GUYS WHAT THEY DO AT THE PLATE.
FREDDIE IS NOT A GUY THAT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY BASED.
HE IS AN OCTOPUS AT THE PLATE.
THE REASON I SAY THAT, I FEEL
LIKE HE CAN COVER EVERYTHING.
HE IS JUST TRYING TO PITCH
SHORTSTOP, LINE DRIVE OVER THE
SHORTSTOP'S HEAD.
IT FEELS LIKE WHEN YOU TALK TO
HIM, HE DOES NOT HUNT FASTBALL.
HE KIND OF HUNTS STRIKE ZONE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT FEELING, IS
WHAT I AM SAYING.
SCOTT: NOT MANY DO.
I LIKE THE OCTOPUS REFERENCE.
RIGHTY, LEFTY, ANY PITCH,
RUNNERS ON.
ESPECIALLY WITH RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION, HE HAS BEEN
ONE OF THE BEST IN THE PAST
DECADE.
RELIEVERS, STARTERS.
MARK: IF YOU LOCK-IN ON A BRAVES
GAME START TO FINISH, FREDDIE IS
NEVER NOT IN THE DUGOUT.
HE'S NOT IN THE VIDEO ROOM.
HE DOES NOT GO AND WATCH HIS
AT-BATS.
HE SITS IN THE EXACT SAME SPOT
IN THE DUGOUT FOR 162.
THAT IS PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
NOT MANY GUYS DO THAT.
SCOTT: HE IS THERE CHIPPER
JONES.
LEADER OF THE CLUBHOUSE.
THE LAST M.V.P. BEFORE FREDDIE
WAS CHIPPER IN 1999.
MARK: THAT'S RIGHT.
SCOTT: WHERE WERE YOU IN 1999?
MARK: I GOT CALLED UP IN JUNE TO
THE BRAVES.
CHIPPER SHOWED UP TO SPRING
TRAINING AND YOU KNEW IT WAS ON.
SCOTT: HE WAS FEELING IT.
MARK: HE DESTROYED THE METS
CONSISTENTLY.
I THINK THE YANKEES CAME IN, HAD
A SERIES WHERE HE WENT BONKERS.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THIS, 2020
MLB RANKS.
HE'S BEEN THE BEST HITTER IN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE.
DEFENDER.
LEGACY TYPE PLAYER.
I KNOW ALEX ANTHOPOULOS IS
WATCHING THIS.
YOU'VE GOT TO THINK THEY ARE
GOING TO SIGN HIM TO AN
EXTENSION.
SCOTT: FREE AGENT AFTER THE YEAR
IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
MARK: YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF YOUNG
SUPERSTARS ON THE RISE.
I KNOW ALBIES, ACUNA ALREADY
SIGNED BUT THE YOUNG PLAYERS
WATCH THE WAY THESE VETERANS ARE
TREATED COME CONTRACT TIME.
I THINK IT WOULD BEHOOVE THE
ATLANTA BRAVES TO DO THE RIGHT
THING.
SCOTT: RUNNER ON THE MOVE AND
SWANSON IS OUT.
SWANSON WANTS THEM TO CHECK IT.
ADRIANZA DOWN ON STRIKES.
YAN GOMES HAS A CANNON.
ARE YOU EVER GOING TO SAY DON'T
CHECK IT?
MARK: I'VE NEVER HAD THE STEAL
SIGNS, I DON'T KNOW.
SCOTT: HERE IT IS AGAIN.
HARRISON LAYS ON THE TAG.
BIG TURNAROUND FO
STRIKE THEM OUT, THROW THEM OUT
OR GET THE REPLAY.
>> HERE IS.
SWUNG ON, DEEP TO RIGHT FI
ELD.
UP THERE, GONE!
HOME RUN, FREDDIE FREEMAN.
>> HE SAID MY ELBOW FEELS FINE.
I AM GOOD TO GO.
HE SHOWED YOU THAT WITH THE
FIRST INNING SINGLE.
GOLFED INTO RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
MARISNICK GETTING IT DOWN FOR A
BASE HIT.
GOING TO GET THE GREEN LIGHT.
THE CUBS MISSED THE CUTOFF MAN.
THE THROW TO THE PLATE IS NOT IN
TIME.
>> THAT WILL DROP IN FOR A BASE
HIT.
>> HANGER AND A HIGH FLY BALL
DEEP RIGHT FIELD.
SEVEN HOMERS FOR FREDDIE.
>> 5-0, ATLANTA.
RIGHT BACK WHERE IT CAME FROM,
OFF THE PITCHER'S BACK HIP.
GUERRERO CANNOT MAKE THE PLAY.
ADRIANZA WILL COME HOME AND
SCORE.
MAKE IT 12-3.
>> THAT CAME BACK A LOT FASTER
THAN IT DID TO THE PLATE.
SCOTT: NO SCORE IN D.C.
ANOTHER UNIQUE ASPECT OF
WATCHING GAMES ON YOUTUBE, WE
JUST UNVEILED THE FIRST
INTERACTIVE PULL OF THE DAY
WHICH ALLOWS YOU TO ANSWER
MULTIPLE-CHOICE PAUL.
RESULTS WILL BE DISCUSSED LATER
IN THE BROADCAST.
WE START WITH WHO ARE YOU
STARTING YOUR TEAM WITH?
ALSO IN THE LIVE CHAT SECTION,
LOOKING FOR QUESTIONS FROM YOU
RIGHT NOW.
IAN ANDERSON ABOUT TO JOIN US ON
YOUTUBE AS DREW SMYLY GETS READY
FOR THE BOTTOM OF THE SECOND
INNING AGAINST YAN GOMES.
HERE WE GO.
IAN ANDERSON JOINING US IN THE
DUGOUT.
IT'S SCOTT BRAUN AND MARK
DEROSA.
HOW ARE YOU DOING TODAY?
>> GOOD, GUYS, HOW IS IT GOING?
SCOTT: GOOD.
WE WILL GET SOME QUESTIONS FROM
THE YOUTUBE CREATORS BUT I WILL
START US OFF BECAUSE I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE HOW MUCH PRESSURE IS
ON THE PITCHING STAFF WITH THE
WAY SHOWING UP AT THE PLATE
SLUGGING .923 WITH A HOME RUN
AND A GRAND SLAM IN THE PAST
WEEK OF BASEBALL.
>> YEAH, THAT'S IMPRESSIVE.
HE'S BEEN ABLE TO DO SO FAR --
IT IS OVERSHADOWING WHAT HE'S
BEEN ABLE TO DO ON THE MOUND.
THAT IS PRETTY CRAZY BECAUSE
HE'S BEEN PRETTY GOOD ON THE
MOUND FOR US.
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF PRESSURE WITH
WHAT HE'S BEEN DOING.
SCOTT: WE ARE SHOWING IT.
APRIL 28.
THIS ONE OFF KYLE HENDRICKS.
LOOKS LIKE A PRO.
MY GOODNESS.
THE RESPONSES WERE INCREDIBLE
FROM THE DUGOUT.
TUESDAY IN THIS SERIES ON TYNER
RAINEY, THE GRAND SLAM TO CENTER
FIELD, WATCHING IT TOO.
LOOKS LIKE HE BELONGS.
FORGET THE DESIGNATED HITTER.
THAT ONE SKIED BY SCHWARBER
SHOULD BE PLAYABLE BY MARCELL
OZUNA.
TWO QUICK FLY OUTS.
HE LOOKS LIKE HE'S A DH THESE
DAYS, IAN.
>> YEAH, HE HITS THE BALL HARD.
HE'S GOT SIX HITS, ALL OVER 100.
MARK: I WANT TO ASK YOU, YOU ARE
A SAVIOR LAST YEAR FOR THIS
ROTATION.
THIS YEAR, YOU SHOW UP, SOROKA
IS DOWN, FRIED GOES DOWN.
I FEEL LIKE YOU HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO BE A ROOKIE.
YOU HAD TO CARRY THE BURDEN OF
THIS ROTATION.
HOW HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO KIND
OF PUT THAT ON YOUR SHOULDERS
AND STILL BE PRODUCTIVE?
>> NO, OBVIOUSLY, NOT HAVING
SOROKA HAS BEEN TOUGH.
I THINK THE WHOLE ORGANIZATION
HAS BEEN NEXT MAN UP MENTALITY.
THAT IS KIND OF THE MINDSET.
DON'T MISS THIS CHANCE TO GO OUT
AND SHOW THAT I BELONG AND SHOW
THAT I CAN STAY HERE.
THE TEAM'S HAD SOME SUCCESS SO
IT'S BEEN FUN.
SCOTT: IT MUST NOT FEEL LIKE YOU
ARE STILL A ROOKIE.
I COVERED YOU IN OCTOBER LAST
YEAR AND YOU LOGGED SOMETIME.
>> YEAH, THAT DEFINITELY HELPED.
THAT WAS SUCH A GOOD EXPERIENCE
FOR EVERYONE.
WE HAVE SUCH A YOUNG TEAM.
FOR US TO GO THROUGH THAT,
DIDN'T END HOW WE WANTED IT TO,
BUT WE HAVE TAKEN NUMEROUS
THINGS INTO THIS YEAR.
THE RESULTS MIGHT NOT BE THERE
YET, BUT WE ARE STAYING THE
COURSE AND WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT
THE TEAM WE HAVE MADE THE WAY WE
HAVE AN PLAYING, IT SHOWS THAT.
SCOTT: MIXING AND ONE FROM THE
LIVE CHAT.
DREW SMYLY FILLING UP THE ZONE
NOW.
MOVING GAMING TV, WHO IS THE
FUNNIEST PLAYER IN THE
CLUBHOUSE?
>> THAT'S GOT TO BE LUKE
JACKSON, ONE OF OUR RELIEVERS.
HE'S HILARIOUS.
HE'LL HAVE YOU BELLY LAUGHING AT
LEAST ONCE AGAIN.
ENDED UP TAKING THE GUYS ON A
BIKE TOUR THROUGH THE D.C.
MONUMENTS ON THE OFF DAY.
HE'S A BIT OF A CHARACTER.
I THINK EVERYBODY WOULD PROBABLY
AGREE.
SCOTT: THAT ONE IS SHOT TO DEEP
LEFT.
OFF THE BAT OF VICTOR ROBLES.
HEADING BACK TO THE TRACK IS
OZUNA.
HE IS THERE.
YOU HAVE A BETTER VIEW THAN WE
DO.
APPRECIATE THE TIME.
KEEP IT UP.
WE WILL TALK SOON.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
A 1-2-3 FRAME FOR DREW SMYLY.
NO SCORE AFTER TWO.
♪
>> BREAKING BALL HIT IN THE AIR
LEFT FIELD DEEP.
THIS MAY GO AND IT IS GONE,
GOODBYE.
BANG, ZOOM GOES TURNER.
>> SWING AND A HIGH DRIVE LEFT
CENTER FIELD.
DOES HE HAVE ANOTHER ONE?
GURRIEL TO THE TRACK, TO THE
WALL.
IT'S TREA TURNER 2, AND THE BLUE
JAYS 0.
>> TREA IS ON IT.
LACES THAT ONE INTO LEFT FIELD
FOR A LEADOFF SINGLE IN THE
FIRST.
>> TREA SMOKES ONE THROUGH THE
HOLE.
>> BASES-LOADED.
SLOW GROUNDER.
WHAT A PLAY.
WOW.
HUGE PLAY BY TREA TURNER.
TURNER PUTS IT IN PLAY TO CENTER
FIELD.
THIS ONE WILL DROP.
THE 2-1 TO TREA.
OUT TO RIGHT FIELD, WILL BACK UP
BIGGIO.
THAT IS OVER HIS HEAD.
THAT BALL KEPT TRAVELING AND
TREA TURNER HAS HIMSELF A 4-4
DAY.
>> DIVING STOP, TURNER ON THE
OUTFIELD GRASS.
GET HIM BY A STEP.
ANOTHER SPECIAL PLAY FOR TREA
TURNER.
TAKES A HIT AWAY FROM JESUS
AGUILAR.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY GLOBAL CITIZEN VAX
LIVE.
STREAM THE EXTENDED SHOW ONLY ON
YOUTUBE.
THIS SATURDAY 8:00 EASTERN, IT
IS A STACKED LINEUP.
HOSTED BY SELENA GOMEZ, TONS OF
PERFORMANCES FROM HUGE NAMES.
EDDIE VEDDER WILL PERFORM.
I WILL GET YOU OTHER ONES
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE POLL
RESULTS.
FOR STARTING THE TEAM TODAY, WHO
WOULD YOU BUILD AROUND?
IT LOOKS LIKE BRAVES FANS ARE
WATCHING ON YOUTUBE TODAY.
YOU CANNOT GO WRONG WITH ANY OF
THESE OPTIONS.
RONALD ACUNA JR. TAKING 57% OF
THE PIE AS JON LESTER GETS READY
TO FACE 7, 8 AND NINE.
GOBBLED UP AT THIRD BY CASTRO
AND THE THROW WAS ON THE MARK ON
TIME.
MARK: ABSOLUTELY AWESOME PLAY BY
STARLIN CASTRO.
HE'S GOT SUPER WHEELS GETTING
DOWN TO THE FIRST, EVEN WITH THE
BUNT.
A BACKHAND TO THE FEET.
GET READY.
SCOTT: JOSH BELL HANDLES.
THERE IS OUT NUMBER ONE.
MARK: NO HESITATION RIGHT HERE.
THE ONE THING THAT IS NICE, TO
HAVE MR. JOSH BELL AT FIRST
BASE.
HE'S GOT THAT CATCH RADIUS
PRETTY MUCH GET IT IN THE
VICINITY.
SCOTT: CASTRO WAS A SHORTSTOP
FOR THE CUBS.
PLAYING SOME SECOND BASE FOR THE
NATIONALS WHICH IS WHAT HE
PREFERS AT THIS POINT.
HANDLING THE HOT CORNER NICELY.
NEXT IS JEFF MATHIS.
38-YEAR-OLD VETERAN.
MARK: I THOUGHT IT WAS
INTERESTING TODAY IN THE ZOOM
CONFERENCE TALKING TO BRIAN
SNITKER WHY MATHIS WAS IN THERE.
HE WANTED TO TAKE A CRACK AND
GET DREW SMYLY GOING.
HE IS SUCH A VETERAN PRESENCE,
MAYBE HE WILL GET THE RIGHT
FINGERS DOWN.
SOMEBODY WILL UNLOCK DREW SMYLY
FOR THE BRAVES.
THIS CANNOT BE A SITUATION WHERE
HE STRUGGLES.
GAVE ONE YEAR, $18 MILLION TO
COLE HAMELS LAST YEAR BUT NEVER
SAW HIM.
GOT TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO PEACE
IT TOGETHER -- PIECE IT T
OGETHER.
SCOTT: BRIAN SNITKER IN HIS 45TH
SEASON WITH THE ATLANTA BRAVES
ORGANIZATION.
JOINED THE TEAM AS AN UNDRAFTED
FREE AGENT IN 1977.
2018 MANAGER OF THE YEAR.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD IDEA TO
GIVE JEFF MATHIS.
MATHIS WITH THE PRISTINE
REPUTATION HANDLING PITCHERS.
THAT ONE LOFTED OFF THE BAT OF
MATHIS.
BERMUDA TRIANGLE ACTION.
IT IS HERNANDEZ FOR OUT NUMBER
TWO.
ALL RIGHT.
PICK YOUR POISON.
RONALD ACUNA JR., THE 20 NL
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
JUAN SOTO, A LITTLE YOUNGER, 22.
HE'S A BATTING CHAMP AND WORLD
SERIES CHAMP IN 2019.
FERNANDO TATIS JR., ALL THE RAGE
THESE DAYS IN THE NL WEST.
THE SILVER SLUGGER LAST YEAR.
A GUY WHO BURST ON THE SCENE IN
2021, VLADDY JR.
MARK: THE THING ABOUT ACUNA IS
THE ABILITY TO DO EVERYTHING AND
THEN ALSO DO IT AT THE LEVEL OF
GIANCARLO STANTON EXIT VELOCITY
OR DISTANCE.
HE IS TAKING THE NUMBERS AND
MAKING THEM EYE-POPPING.
HE IS HITTING THE BALL NORTH OF
480 FEET.
NORTH OF A 95 MILE PER HOUR NEXT
VELOCITY.
THERE'S NOTHING HE CAN DO ON A
BASEBALL FIELD AND IT IS HARD TO
HAVE A GORGEOUS RIGHT-HANDED
BASEBALL.
YOU THINK OF THE GREAT, GORGEOUS
SWINGS.
HE'S UNHINGED.
IN THE WAY HE GOES ABOUT IT FROM
THE PLATE.
SCOTT: DREW SMYLY WOULD LOVE HIS
SWING.
NO CAREER HITS IN 27 A.B.'S.
MARK: MR. JUAN SOTO IN 2019 IN
THE WORLD SERIES SHOWED
EVERYBODY WHY YOU CAN ARGUE HE'S
THE BEST HITTER IN THE SPORT.
WHAT HE WAS ABLE TO DO IN THE
WORLD SERIES.
SCOTT: I LIKE TO PLAY THAT GAME.
YOU TALK ABOUT PLAYERS, THE
ALL-AROUND GAME.
WHAT ABOUT ONE AT THAT TO WIN
THE GAME?
MARK: I WANT JUAN SOTO OUT OF
THAT GROUP.
SCOTT: IF YOU THROW IN --  MARK:
IF YOU THROW IN FINANCIALS,
ACUNAST EFFECTIVE
DEAL.
SCOTT: 2400 CAREER STRIKEOUTS
FOR JON LESTER, CONGRATS.
HE HAS FACED THE MINIMUM THROUGH
THREE.
>> HIGH FLY BALL.
HE CRUSHED THAT BABY.
MARCELL OZUNA HAS BUT THE BRAVES
IN FRONT.
TAKE A SELFIE, MARCELL, AND THE
GRANT TOUR.
HIGH FLY BALL, DID HE?
HE'S HIT A HOMER.
HIS FIRST HOME RUN.
GOLFED INTO RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
MARISNICK WILL GET THERE.
THAT IS DOWN FOR A BASE HIT.
HE'S GOING TO GET THE RING LIGHT
-- GREEN LIGHT.
ACUNA IS COMING HOME.
NOT IN TIME!
HE SLID IN AHEAD OF THE TAG AND
THE BRAVES HAVE SCORED SIX IN
THE FIRST TWO INNINGS.
SWING AND A DRIVE TO DEEP LEFT.
WELCOME BACK, CRISTIAN PACHE.
A GRAND SLAM.
>> ABSOLUTELY CRUSHED IT.
>> FLY BALL.
HE'S BACK.
LONG HOME RUN.
HOW FAR FROM THE BLEACHERS THIS
ECHO.
>> 481 FEET FOR ACUNA.
>> THE BRAVES LEAD THE LEAGUE
WITH 44 HOME RUNS COMING IN
TODAY AND I LOVE IT WHEN GUYS
PUT THEIR BAT, STRUT AROUND THE
BASES.
SOMETIMES THEY ARE GETTING MORE
INTO IT LIKE OTHER ONES.
OUR SPOKE QUESTION COMES AND IT
IS WHAT IS THE BEST HOME RUN
CELEBRATION OF THE LAST FIVE
USE?
WE HAVE THE TWINS, THE NATIONALS
OF THE 2019 POSTSEASON DRIVING
THE BUS.
WHICH ONE IS YOUR FAVORITE?
SCOTT: I HAVE RECENCY BIAS SO I
WILL GO WITH THE UNIQUENESS
OF THE SHOPPING CART BY JASON
VARITEK AND COMPANY.
MARK: THE SELFIE FROM MARCELL
OZUNA.
HE KIND OF CHANGE TO THE WHOLE
DYNAMIC LAST YEAR WITH THE
BRAVES.
ALL THE YOUNG, LATIN AMERICAN
BORN BALLPLAYERS, THEY
GRAVITATED TO HIM.
ACUNA, ALBIES -- I WANT TO BE IN
A SELFIE WITH HIM.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: LAST YEAR IN THE
WILD-CARD ROUND AGAINST THE
CINCINNATI REDS, THE BRAVES
HAVING SOME FUN AND THEY MOVE ON
EVENTUALLY TO FACE THE DODGERS.
THEY WERE UP 3-1.
ONE WIN AWAY FROM THE WORLD
SERIES.
OZUNA REPLACED JOSH DONALDSON IN
THE BATTING ORDER PERFECTLY.
MARK: WE'VE BEEN TO DINNER 100
TIMES AND I HAVE TOLD JON LESTER
HE NEEDS TO HONOR HIS HITTING
MORE.
HE'S GOT POP AND A GORGEOUS
SWING.
HE'S STARTED HIS CAREER LIKE
0-60 OR SOMETHING.
SCOTT: HE CAN BUNT.
LOOK AT THAT HACK.
THERE YOU GO.
GOOD DAY FOR LESTER ON THE MOUND
SO FAR.
THREE SCORELESS.
HE HAS FACED THE MINIMUM NINE.
9, 1 AND 2 DUE UP FOR THE
NATIONALS IN THE HOME THIRD.
SCOTT BRAUN, MARK DEROSA.
YOU JUST HEARD FROM SAVANAH
MCCANN.
MARK: STARTED HIS CAREER 0-66,
MATT BAKER SAYS.
SCOTT: 0-66 WITH THAT SWING.
HE HAD TO DO SOME CLIMBING TO
GET OVER THE 100 MARK HE IS AT
NOW.
FOR EVERYTHING WE SAY ABOUT
OZUNA, HE'S THE ONLY ONE ON THE
LIST DEFENSIVELY WITH A GOLD
GLOVE.
SILVER SLUGGER AND GOLD GLOVE
WINNER.
HE'S HAD SOME SHOULDER TROUBLE
SINCE THEN.
COULDN'T BITE.
STRIKE THREE, HIS THIRD OF THE
DAY.
DREW SMYLY WITH THE SWING AND
MISS STUFF TODAY.
THE NICE COMMAND.
NEW TO THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
FOR THE 2021 SEASON, YOUTUBE
TO PLAYER OF THE GAME.
FANS WATCHING FOR MOBILE DEVICES
CAN VOTE FOR WHO RECEIVES THE
TROPHY.
STAY TUNED FOR THE PLAYER OF THE
GAME PULLING OPTIONS.
YOU CAN TAKE HIS ADVICE OR LEAVE
IT.
DREW SMYLY MAKING A STRONG CASE
SO FAR.
THIS IS WHAT BRAVES FANS WERE
HOPING FOR IN THE OFF-SEASON
WHEN THEY SPENT $11 MILLION ON A
ONE YEAR CONTRACT FOR SMYLY,
COMING OFF A BIG YEAR WITH THE
GIANTS.
OF COURSE, LAST YEAR -- AN
ABBREVIATED SEASON, BUT WHEN HE
WAS ON THE MOUND, THE BRAVES
STOP THEY SAW SOMETHING THAT
COULD BLOSSOM EVEN FURTHER.
MARK: OBVIOUSLY, IT TOOK
EVERYONE BY SURPRISE.
HE SIGNED & EARLY, IT WAS ONE
YEAR, $11 MILLION.
IT WAS NOT $7 MILLION OR $6
MILLION WHERE PEOPLE ARE LIKE
THIS IS A NICE DEPTH MOVE.
NO, IT IS KIND OF LIKE WHAT THE
YANKEES DID WITH COREY KLUBER,
ASKING KLUBER TO SLIDE INTO
THERE TO SPOT WITH GERRIT COLE.
SCOTT: THAT IS A NICE STOP AT
THIRD.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE QUICK ON
TURNER.
ADRIANZA MAKES A BRILLIANT PLAY
AT THIRD BASE.
MARK: SEE HIM LEANING TOWARDS
THE LIGHT A LITTLE BIT.
ADRIANZA, BORN AND RAISED WITH
THE SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS.
HE WAS JUST A YOUNG BLOOD
PLAYING SHORTSTOP.
HE WAS ALL GLOVE, NO BAT IN WHAT
HAS BEEN A STEADY ASCENT THROUGH
THE MINOR LEAGUES.
SCOTT: SPRING TRAINING WAS SO
GOOD FOR HIM THAT BRIAN SNITKER
SAID THEY HAVE TO PUT HIM ON THE
ROSTER EVEN THOUGH HE WAS NOT
NECESSARILY IN THE PLANS FOR
2021.
FOULED OFF FOR HERNANDEZ.
THINK ABOUT WHAT IS GOING
THROUGH YOUR MIND.
TREA TURNER IS THE FASTEST
PLAYER IN THE SPORT, ACCORDING
TO SPRING SPEED FROM STATCAST.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE QUICK WITH IT.
MARK: THAT IS THE BEAUTY OF
PLAYING THIRD BASE, ESPECIALLY
FOR SOMEBODY AS GOOD AS THE
GLOVE.
THAT IS A DAY OFFER HIM AT THIRD
BASE -- OFF FOR HIM AT THIRD
BASE.
SCOTT: I LIKE THAT.
NICE GUY TO HAVE TO FILL IN AT
THIRD BASE AT THIRD BASE TODAY.
TREA IS 0-2.
HERNANDEZ STRUCK OUT AGAINST
SMYLY THE FIRST TIME AROUND.
THIS IS A GREAT STORY TOO.
HERNANDEZ WAS A STAR IN CUBA.
TOOK A LONG TIME FOR HIM TO FIND
THE MAJOR LEAGUES.
HE HAS HIT WELL SO FAR AND
LIMITED TIME -- IN LIMITED TIME.
DEBUTED LAST SEASON AT AGE 32.
10-25 IN HIS LAST EIGHT FILLING
IN FOR SODA.
SIX SEASONS IN CUBA.
THREE IN WASHINGTON'S MINOR
LEAGUE SYSTEM.
DAVE MARTINEZ TOLD US BEFORE THE
GAME, HE IS FUN.
WE LOVE HAVING HIM AROUND.
SOTO WILL COME BACK, HERNANDEZ
WILL BE A BENCH PLAYER GET BUT
YOU THINK ABOUT 2019 AND PARRA.
YOU WANT SOME PERSONALITY AND
SOME FUN, MAYBE HERNANDEZ MAKES
THAT IS WALK UP SONG.
TOUGH PLAY FOR SWANSON.
IT IS OFF THE GLOVE AND AN
INFIELD KNOCK FOR YADIEL
HERNANDEZ.
HERE COMES THE MAN WITH THE MIC
TODAY AND IT IS JOSH HARRISON.
>> SOMETIMES IT IS BETTER TO BE
LUCKY THAN GOOD.
I SAW HIM GOING BACKHAND.
THAT WAS DIRTY, HUH?
SCOTT: THAT IS A GUY WHO HAS
BEEN IN THE LEAGUE FOR A WHILE,
KNOWS A LOT OF PLAYERS AROUND
THE GAME AND IS COMFORTABLE WITH
WHO HE IS.
I WANT YOU EVERY MORNING, AND
ONE THING I DO REMEMBER AS JOSH
HARRISON GOES AFTER THE FIRST
PITCH -- FLY BALL -- YOU SAID
YOU WISHED YOU HAD MORE FUN.
JOSH HARRISON IS DOING THAT.
ANOTHER GOOD INNING FOR DREW
SMYLY WHO LEAVES ONE STRANDED.
STILL NO SCORE.
THREE IN THE BOOKS IN D.C.
♪
>> SWING AND A GROUND BALL LEFT
SIDE.
CASTRO POPS UP, THROWS TO
SECOND.
GETS THE OUT TO RETIRE THE SIDE.
A SPARKLING DEFENSIVE PLAY BY
CASTRO AND LESTER HAVING TROUBLE
IN THE THIRD INNING.
A DIVING STOP, TURNER ON THE
OUTFIELD GRASS GETS UP AND GETS
HIM BY A STEP.
TAKE THE HIT AWAY FROM JESUS
AGUILAR.
A BREAKING BALL TO LEFT FIELD.
>> THIS MAY GO AND IT IS GONE,
GOODBYE.
BANG ZOOM GOES TURNER.
GURRIEL SO THE TRACK, TO THE
WALL.
IT IS TREA TURNER 2 AND THE BLUE
JAYS NOTHING.
>> SWING AND A MISS.
MAX SCHERZER PUTS THE FINISHING
TOUCHES.
A 96 MILE-PER-HOUR FASTBALL FOR
HIS NINTH STRIKE OUT OF THE
BALLGAME.
>> LONG DRIVE RIGHT.
BACK ON THIS ONE IS HARRISON.
THIS ONE IS GONE INTO THE SECOND
DECK.
IT IS A LEADOFF, WALKOFF TWO RUN
HOMER FOR QUIET SCHWARBER -- FOR
KYLE SCHWARBER, AND HE SENDS
THEM HOME HAPPY.
SCOTT: EACH WEEK THIS SEASON ON
OUR BROADCAST, WE WILL FOCUS ON
A YOUTUBE CONTENT CREATOR
FEATURED IN OUR LIVE GAME
COMMENTARY SECTION.
TODAY OUR SPOTLIGHT IS ON BENNY
NO.
YOU CAN WATCH THIS DODGERS FAN
PLAY VIDEO GAMES WITH HIS SON
AND VLOG ABOUT THEIR LIFE AROUND
BASEBALL.
55 MILLION VIEWS.
THEY LOVE THE DODGERS.
I BELIEVE HE HAS TWO KIDS NOW.
IT IS "BENNY NO."
SOME TROUBLE FROM THE CHILDREN
IN THE HOUSE.
WATCH OUT FOR THAT VASE, THAT
TROPHY.
MARK: I'M PAST IT.
I'M IN THE GOOD YEARS NOW.
SCOTT: WHAT ARE THE AGES?
MARK: 17 AND 11.
SCOTT: GOOD CUT BY ACUNA TO
START THE INNING FOR ATLANTA.
MARK: I THINK THE BRAVES HAVE TO
RETHINK THEIR COLORS.
RONALD IS MAKING A DEAD PUSH TO
GET GOLD AS A PART OF THE
ATLANTA BRAVES COLORS.
KIND OF HONORING HIS VENEZUELAN
HERITAGE WITH A LITTLE IRON MAN
IN THERE.
I'M ALL IN.
LOOK AT IT.
SCOTT: IT SHINES.
MARK: HE HAS REALLY TAKEN
ATLANTA BY STORM.
WASHINGTON, D.C., I MEAN.
YOU HAVE NOT SEEN A PLAYER,
COME AS ATHLETIC AS ANDRUW
JONES.
SCOTT: NL PLAYER OF THE MONTH
FOR APRIL.
HE'S COOL.
HE RUNS, SLUGS.
HE SENDS ONE TO LEFT AND WE WILL
WATCH HIM RUN THE BASIS.
RONALD ACUNA JR. STARTS OFF THE
FOURTH WITH A BASE HIT.
MARK: YOU CAN SEE RIGHT HERE,
JUST A CUTTER IN.
BACK IN THE DAY WHEN JON LESTER
WAS LIVING AT 92, 93 MILES PER
HOUR, HE COULD BURY THAT PITCH
IN.
PITCH AT 88, 89 AGAINST RONALD
ACUNA, HE IS LUCKY TO GET THAT
BALL BACK.
GET IN LINE.
SCOTT: 111 MILES PER HOUR OFF
THE BAT FOR THAT SINGLE.
HE HAD THREE STOLEN BASES IN HIS
FIRST 10 GAMES AND NONE IN HIS
NEXT 18.
BRAVES ARE SAYING YOU CAN GO.
JUST WATCH IT ON SOME OF THE
DIVES.
WE SAW HIM DIVE BACK TO THE BAG
AND SUFFER A MILD ABDOMINAL
STRAIN ON APRIL 18.
ONE MORE SWIPE THIS SERIES, SO
FOUR ON THE SEASON.
THIS IS ALWAYS A FUN BATTLE
BECAUSE JON LESTER DOES NOT LOVE
GOING OVER TO FIRST BASE IF YOU
FOLLOWED HIM IN HIS CAREER.
IT IS ABOUT THE PAUSING, THE
CHANGING UP YOUR TIMING COMING
TO HOME PLATE.
OTHERWISE, I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
HIM THROW BUT IT JUST DOESN'T
HAPPEN.
MARK: I DO BELIEVE RONALD COULD
GO FROM FIRST AND THERE'S
NOTHING JON CAN DO TO DEFEND IT.
SCOTT: THERE HE GOES.
THE THROW SKIPS AWAY INTO CENTER
AND ACUNA IS OFF TO THIRD.
JUST LIKE THAT, ONE OF THE
FLASHIEST PLAYERS IN THE GAME IS
90 FEET AWAY FROM SCORING THE
GAME'S FIRST RUN.
MARK: I DON'T THINK YOU HESITATE
A GUY WHO DOES NOT LIKE TO THROW
OVER TO THIRD BASE.
A GUY LIKE RONALD ACUNA WHO HAS
WHEELS FOR DAYS.
EVEN IF HE DOES THROW THAT TO
JOSH BELL, I STILL THINK HE
BEATS THE TRANSFER TO SECOND.
HE'S PLAYING YOUTH BALL.
LET ME GO TO THIRD BASE ONCE HE
SEES JOSH HARRISON MISSES.
SCOTT: BRIAN SNITKER US THIS
MORNING, THE BALLFIELD IS HIS
PLAYGROUND.
MARK: THAT IS A GREAT LINE.
SCOTT: SINCE 2019, ONE OF THE
FASTEST, I WOULD SAY, ALSO
WISELY AGGRESSIVE AT THE PLATE
AS HE CONTINUES TO IMPROVE
CONTACT RATE AND DECREASE HIS
CHASE PERCENTAGE.
THAT IS SCARY.
MARK: HE'S ONLY GOING TO GET
BETTER.
WHEN HE KNOWS HOW THESE GUYS ARE
GOING TO ATTACK HIM -- PLAYING
WITH CHIPPER JONES ALL THOSE
YEARS, HIS ATTENTION TO DETAIL
BEFORE THE GAME.
COMING UP WITH A GAME PLAN,
KNOWING HOW GUYS WILL ATTACK
HIM, WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO
THROW WITH RUNNERS IN SCORING
POSITION.
HE'S ONLY GOING TO GET BETTER.
SCOTT: MORE WALKS THAN
STRIKEOUTS THIS SEASON.
ALBIES, HIS BEST FRIEND, FACING
A 2-2.
MARK: I LOVE DAVEY MARTINEZ'S
DEFENSIVE POSITION RIGHT HERE.
NOT CONCEDING THE EARLY ONE RUN.
HE KNOWS LESTER AND SMYLY ARE
BOTH ON TOP OF THE GAME,
EVENTUALLY GIVING IT OVER TO THE
BULLPEN.
HIS GOT INFIELD PLAYING HALFWAY
RIGHT HERE.
THEY WILL NOT LET ACUNA WALK
HOME.
SCOTT: FULL BOAT.
HE MISSED.
FIRST TWO HITTERS OF THE FRAME
ON BOARD FOR ATLANTA.
RUNNERS ON THE CORNERS.
THAT BRINGS US TO OZUNA.
MR. GRAND SLAM FROM YESTERDAY.
I WANT TO SNEAK THIS IN TOO.
NEXT HALF INNING, WE ARE TALKING
TO MAX SCHERZER FOR A HALF
FRAME.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM OUR YOUTUBE
CREATORS, BRING THEM ON.
MARK:MARK: I'VE GOT A FEW I HAVE
WRITTEN DOWN.
SCOTT: YEAH?
HE HAD A DECK ABOUT A WEEK AGO.
MARK: HE SAID A LOT OF DAYS.
SCOTT: GOES OVER TO WATCH HIS
WIFE GIVE BIRTH TO THEIR THIRD
GET.
OZUNA INTO THE CORNER AND THAT
WILL SCORE THE FIRST RUN OF THE
DAY.
RONALD ACUNA JR. WILL TROT HOME
AND MARCELL OZUNA KNOCKS IN A
RUN FOR ATLANTA.
IT IS 1-0.
MARK: RIGHT HERE, CUTTER INSIDE
BY JON LESTER.
IT IS ACTUALLY A GREAT PITCH.
MARCELL OZUNA ALMOST KNOWS HE
WANTS TO GO TO THAT, TO GET HIM
TO ROLLOVER TO THIRD.
KIND OF CHEATS TO THE SPOT,
KEEPS IT FAIR.
1-0, BRAVOS.
SECOND AND THIRD.
THEY ARE SET UP FOR A BIG
GETTING RIGHT HERE.
SCOTT: THE DOUBLE FOR OZUNA IS
HIS THIRD OF THE SEASON.
ALBIES AT THIRD.
HERE'S A GUY WHO HAS BEEN
SWINGING THE BAT WELL.
AUSTIN RILEY HAS ADVANCED
HIMSELF IN TERMS OF HIS PLATE
DISCIPLINE THIS YEAR.
ALEX ANTHOPOULOS, GM OF THE
SQUAD, MUCH MORE SELECTIVE.
THEY ARE EXCITED ABOUT HIS OWN
RECOGNITION SO MUCH SO, THAT HE
SAID THE CEILING FOR HIM MIGHT
BE HIGHER THAN THEY ANTICIPATED.
MARK: I THINK COMING UP THROUGH
THE BRAVES SYSTEM, THE NAME I
HEARD TIME AND TIME AGAIN WAS
AUSTIN RILEY.
TROY HAD SAYING TROY HAD A GOOD
CAREER, SHORTSTOP COMING UP WITH
UCLA.
I THINK THE THING THAT JUMPED
OUT FOR ME WATCHING, HE BURST ON
THE SCENE IN LEFT FIELD.
THEY REALIZE HE COULD PLAY
THIRD.
TODAY HE'S AT FIRST.
SCOTT: 2-1 TO RILEY.
FOULS THAT BACK.
DO YOU THINK RILEY IS CAPABLE OF
300 PLUS IN HIS CAREER, MAYBE A
45 HOMER YEAR?
MARK: HE IS CERTAINLY TALENTED
ENOUGH.
YOU'VE GOT TO HANG AROUND LONG
TIME TO PULL THOSE KIND OF
NUMBERS.
TOOK ME 16 YEARS TO GET 100.
SCOTT: CHOPPED FOUL.
MARK: IT'S FUNNY, THOUGH, I WAS
BLESSED TO BE DRAFTED BY THE
ATLANTA BRAVES.
ON THE FLIPSIDE, YOU GO OVER TO
THE NATIONALS IN 2012, CAN I
ADDRESS THE TEAM?
I DON'T THINK THEY REALIZED IT
YET.
TWO DIFFERENT SCENARIOS, TWO
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS.
SCOTT: YOU WERE PART OF THE
BEGINNING OR THE RISE FOR THE
NATIONALS.
BRYCE HARPER, ANTHONY RENDON WAS
ON THE FIELD.
MARK: I WALKED AROUND SPRING
TRAINING AND I WAS JUST BLOWN
AWAY BY HOW MUCH TYLAN WAS ON
THE OUTFIELD.
SCOTT: PAYOFF TO RILEY.
MAYBE A LITTLE DOWN.
GOT SECOND AND THIRD.
YOU'RE NOT LOOKING TO WALK IN
THAT SITUATION.
WORK THAT BOTTOM OF THE ZONE.
I THINK NOWADAYS THAT'S THE
NITRO ZONE FOR A LOT OF PLAYERS.
MIKE TROUT LOVES THAT PITCH.
MARK: MIKE TROUT IS AT A WHOLE
OTHER LEVEL.
HOW MUCH OF A RABBIT HOLE DO YOU
WANT ME TO GO DOWN?
SCOTT: RUNNERS IN SCORING
POSITION.
MARK: YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE GUYS TRY TO DRIVE IT OUT
OF THE YARD.
THERE NO KNOCKS ON THE GROUND.
JOSH DONALDSON TOLD YOU THAT
ABOUT EIGHT YEARS AGO.
PEOPLE WEREN'T LISTENING.
YOUR INCENTIVIZING THE 6, 7, 8
GUYS IN THE LINEUP TO TRY TO HIT
HOMERS.
I WANT THEM TO SET THE TONE FOR
3, 4, FIVE.
YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE HIM A REASON
TO CHANGE THE WAY HE CARES GOING
INTO SPRING TRAINING.
SCOTT: SWING AND A MISS FROM
SWANSON.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THAT
PITCH?
>> BORDERLINE.
MEANING NOT BORDERLINE.
MARK: IS HE LISTENING?
SCOTT: SOUNDS LIKE HE IS.
DOES HE HAVE A LITTLE EARPIECE?
MARK: HERE'S THE THING, YOU TAKE
THE BOX OFF THE SCREEN, THAT'S
NOT BORDERLINE.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN HAVE A
BRIGHT, EVEN IF YOU GO BACK AND
WATCH THAT ON VIDEO.
I THINK HE WAS SQUEEZED.
SCOTT: WE NEED ABOUT 10 MORE
SOUNDBITES FROM JOSH HARRISON
TODAY.
TAKE YOUR TIME, BUT WHEN YOU ARE
DONE, YOU ARE HANGING WITH US.
LESTER WENT FIVE INNINGS IN HIS
21 DEBUT, FIVE SCORELESS, 70
PITCHES.
WHAT IS THE NUMBER IF HE GETS
OUT OF THIS ONE, 90-ISH?
MARK: OH, YEAH.
SCOTT: AND HE GETS SWANSON.
BACK-TO-BACK TO BACK PUNCH-OUTS
FOR JON LESTER.
HE'S UP TO FOUR ON THE DAY.
MARK: GETTING THAT NASTY CUTTER
IN.
DANSBY SWANSON, THAT'S A SECOND
A.B. HE'S GOING CUTTER IN,
BACKDOOR CUTTER.
GETS HIM LEANING IN AND JUST
CONSISTENTLY TRYING TO MOVE THE
PLAY.
HAVE YOU EVER BEEN IN HIS
PRESENCE?
HE IS A MOUNTAIN OF A MAN.
BIG DUDE.
I THINK HE CAN STAY IN THERE AS
LONG AS HE WANTS.
SCOTT: SENT TO CENTER AND THAT'S
GOING TO FALL AND SCORE AT LEAST
ONE FOR ATLANTA.
THE SECOND ON ITS WAY.
FIRST SLIDE, HE IS IN THERE.
SCORES TO FOR THE BRAVES TO MAKE
IT 3-0 AS ALBIES AND OZUNA COME
HOME.
I WANT TO SEE THE REPLAY ON THE
SLIDE.
HE LAYS OUT.
AGGRESSIVE BASERUNNING FROM
MARCELL OZUNA COMING HOME.
MARK: JUST BEING FUNDAMENTAL,
IT'S EASY FROM THE BOOTH, BUT
IT'S KIND OF ON YAN GOMES RIGHT
THERE.
VICTOR ROBLES, ONE OF THE BEST
CENTER FIELDERS IN BASEBALL.
THE BALL TRAVELS THEN FAST --
FASTER THAN YOU GOING TO GET THE
BALL AND COMING BACK.
JUST GIVES OZUNA ELAINE.
GREAT SLIDE BY MARCELL.
HE'S PROBABLY GOT 8000 ARM
SLEEVES.
SCOTT: CHRISTIAN CUTS AND
MISSES.
DRIVING INTO WITH A BASE HIT.
THE BRAVES HAVE BEEN BIG ON THAT
EARLY IN THE SEASON.
COMES UP WITH THE HUGE TWO
R.B.I. KNOCK.
ADRIANZA CAN PLAY 15 DIFFERENT
POSITIONS.
PABLO SANDOVAL HAS A KNACK FOR
THE BIG MOMENT.
EVERYBODY LIKES THE PANDA.
MARK: GREAT NICKNAME, FUN DUDE.
FORMER WORLD SERIES M.V.P..
HE IS CHILLING.
JUST LET ME KNOW WHEN YOU NEED
ME.
SCOTT: AND THAT IS IN THERE.
LESTER WITH THREE STRIKEOUTS.
THREE CASE IN THE INNING FOR
RUNS IN THE
FOURTH FOR ATLANTA TO JUMP
AHEAD.
AS WE HEAD TO BREAK, LET'S GET A
CLOSER LOOK AT OZZIE ALBIES.
>> THE DAY HE TURNED NINE YEARS
OLD, HE GOT TO MEET HIS BASEBALL
HERO.
11 YEARS LATER ON THE DAY OF HIS
MAJOR-LEAGUE DEBUT, ARTHUR JOAN
SURPRISED HIM AGAIN.
JONES WAS MLB'S FIRST START FROM
CURACAO.
ONE OF THE REASONS ALBIES AND
HIS FAMILY ARE LIFELONG BRAVES
FANS.
ALBIES FATHER HAD A HEART ATTACK
AND DIED AT 41.
>> IT'S AMAZING HOW WHAT HE TOLD
ME BEFORE HE PASSED AWAY, IF IT
WASN'T BECAUSE OF HIM, I'M NOT
SITTING HERE TODAY.
>> OZZIE ALBIES IS WHO HE IS
BECAUSE OF HIS ROLE MODELS.
ONE AONE A STAR WHO WATCHED HIM.
THE OTHER, HIS FATHER, WHO NEVER
GOT THE CHANCE.
SCOTT: THAT'S OZUNA BEING OZUNA
AND STARTING TO FIND SOMETHING.
OUR NEXT GUEST, MAX SCHERZER
JOINING US.
FIRST OFF, CONGRATULATIONS, THE
FIRST PITCH FROM STARLIN CASTRO
TO DANSBY SWANSON, ONE OUT IN
THE BOTTOM OF THE FOURTH.
HOW ARE YOU TODAY AND HOW IS THE
ADDITION TO THE FAMILY?
MAX: THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
IT'S BEEN A CRAZY COUPLE OF DAYS
BUT A GOOD CRAZY.
EVERYBODY IS GOOD AND HEALTHY,
SO THE FAMILY JUST GOT BIGGER.
MARK: THE OTHER DAY AGAINST THE
MARLINS, OBVIOUSLY DOMINATING,
WHEN DO YOU KNOW YOU ARE ON?
ARE YOU A GUY LIKE THE BULLPEN
MATTERS WHEN YOU'RE COMING OUT,
IS THERE ONE OR TWO PITCHES?
TAKE ME INSIDE THE MINDSET.
MAX: I DON'T KNOW, OUR FOREIGN
OF GAMES WHERE A LIKE I HAVE IT,
ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU GO OUT THERE
AND THINK YOU'VE GOT IT AND THEN
YOU MAKE A COUPLE OF MISTAKES
AND GIVE UP A THREE RUN SHOT.
YOU CAN NEVER REALLY FALL INTO
THE TRAIN OF THOUGHT THAT YOU
ARE LOCKED IN.
THERE'S SOME HE THINGS THAT CAN
HAPPEN IN THE BLINK OF AN EYE.
YOU CAN GIVE UP SOME EARLY RUNS
AND THEN SETTLE IN AND GO DEEP
IN THE GAME AND GO SEVEN INNINGS
AND DO SOMETHING GOOD FOR YOUR
TEAM.
YOU GOT TO GET OUT OF THE
MINDSET OF HOWEVER THE GAME IS
UNFOLDING TO EXECUTE THE NEXT
PITCH.
SCOTT: WE HAVE SOME YOUTUBE
CREATORS WITH SOME EXCELLENT
QUESTIONS.
WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE
ACCOMPLISHMENT OF YOUR CAREER?
I KNOW WINNING THE WORLD SERIES
IS PROBABLY UP THERE, BUT WHAT
ABOUT AFTER THAT?
MAX: OBVIOUSLY WINNING THE CY
YOUNG IS REALLY, REALLY COOL.
DEFINITELY MORE NO-HITTERS.
THAT IS A SHORT LIST.
THAT GAME WAS SPECIAL.
THAT'S ONE OF MY FAVORITE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
MARK: YOU'VE PLAYED A LITTLE
MORE GRIZZLED VETERANS.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON IT, YOU
DON'T SEE MANY GUYS FLIPPING THE
BAT.
I'M NOT TRYING TO GET YOU IN
TROUBLE, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON
IT?
IS IT COOL?
MAX: I'M COOL AS LONG AS AS ITS
-- AS LONG AS IT'S JUST AN
EMOTIONAL PART OF THE GAME.
I GET IT, BUT IF YOU'RE LOSING
AND YOU START BAT FLIPPING,
THAT'S KIND OF WHEN I HAVE AN
ISSUE.
YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO BRING
ATTENTION TO YOURSELF.
PICK A WINNING PLAYER ARE
ANYTHING, STRIKING SOMEONE OUT
OUR DEFENSIVE PLAYER WHATEVER IT
IS, THAT'S FINE, I GET THAT.
IT'S THE OTHER STUFF THAT KIND
OF IRRITATES ME.
SCOTT: YAN GOMES HERE IN THE
FOURTH.
TAKES IT INSIDE.
WERE TALKING TO ACT SURE'S ARE.
BACK TO THE NEW ADDITION TO THE
FAMILY.
WHAT IS THE BIGGER ADRENALINE
RUSH, PITCHING A WORLD SERIES
GAME OR GUNNING IT OVER TO THE
HOSPITAL IN THE CAR?
TELL THE TRUTH.
MAX: YOU ARE ANXIOUS FOR BOTH.
WHEN YOU'RE DRIVING TO THE
HOSPITAL, YOU CAN'T WAIT FOR
JUST HAPPEN.
IT'S KIND OF THE SAME FEELING.
KIND OF A SIMILAR FEELING EVEN
THOUGH IT'S TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS.
SCOTT: YAN GOMES, FLOATER.
MARK: MAX, DID YOU KNOW, OR WILL
YOU SURPRISED?
BOY OR GIRL?
MAX: WE KNEW A BOY WAS COMING.
WE HAD TWO GIRLS FIRST BUT WE
ALWAYS KNEW IT WOULD BE A BOY.
GOOD THINGS HAPPEN.
MARK: I FEEL LIKE WHEN I WATCH
YOU I WANT TO COMPARE YOU TO TOM
BRADY.
RE: WE PITCHING IT TO OUR --
INTO OUR 40'S?
MAX: WHO KNOWS, I NEVER LIKE TO
THINK TOO FAR IN THE FUTURE.
JUST GO OUT THERE AND STAY IN
THE MOMENT.
GO OUT THERE AND DO MY THING AND
THE REST WILL JUST TAKE CARE OF
ITSELF.
SCOTT: ONE ON, TWO OUTS.
IS KYLE SCHWARBER.
WHAT IS ONE THING ABOUT YOUR
GAME THAT WE DON'T SEE OR KNOW
MUCH ABOUT THAT YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SEE MORE DISCUSSED?
MAX: I DON'T KNOW, WHAT DO YOU
GUYS THINK?
MARK: WHY DO YOU THROW YOUR
BULLPENS IN FULL UNIFORM?
MAX: THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
THE L UNIFORMS WHEN THEY WERE
MADE BY MAJESTIC, THEY USED TO
GIVE US THESE TOPS.
ONCE I STOP MAKING THOSE TOPS,
KIND OF LIKE HAVING THE WEIGHT
ON ME LIKE A JERSEY.
NOW THAT NIKE IS MAKING THE
JERSEY HOPEFULLY THEY WILL MAKE
THOSE TOPS.
SCOTT: SCHWARBER RIPS ONE INTO
THE CORNER.
THAT'S A BASE HIT.
HIS BOBBLED IN THE CORNER, THE
NETS BREAK THE ICE.
SCHWARBER INS UP AT THIRD.
IT IS 3-1.
IF THIS INNING GOES FOREVER,
HE'S GOING TO STAY WITH US.
WE DID THIS ONCE A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO.
YOUR TEAM WAS ON A ROLL.
MAX: WE DON'T TALK ABOUT STUFF
LIKE THAT.
YOU MIGHT JINX IT.
MARK: HOW HAS IT BEEN HAVING JON
LESTER FOR SPRING TRAINING?
I KNOW IT'S BEEN KIND OF HIT AND
MISS WITH THE COVID STUFF.
MAX: HE JUST HAPPEN TO BE IN A
COVID TIMEOUT.
I GAVE THEM A NICE BIG HUG AND
SAID WELCOME TO THE STADIUM.
HE ENJOYS BEING BACK IN THE
DUGOUT, BEING ONE OF US.
JUST KIND OF GETTING BACK IN
FOCUS.
I LIKE HAVING THE OLD GUYS IN
THE CLUBHOUSE.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: ON THAT PLAY FOR
SCHWARBER, IT'S A DOUBLE, NO
R.B.I..
MAX SCHERZER IS LIVE HERE ON
YOUTUBE.
SCHWARBER AT THIRD.
VICTOR ROBLES MOVES THE COUNT TO
2-0.
I BELIEVE THIS IS ONE OF YOUR
THINGS.
TALKING TO HITTERS AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
THROUGH THEIR MIND.
DO THOSE CONVERSATIONS HELP YOU
FORMULATE A GAME PLAN?
MAX: I WOULDN'T SAY NECESSARILY
FORM A GAME PLAN, BUT JUST
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON.
YOU'VE BEEN ON THE OTHER SIDE
SEVERAL TIMES.
WHAT YOU SEE, HOW HE SEES THE
GAME, THAT'S WHY LOVE THE NL
HERE BECAUSE YOU'RE IN THE CAGE
WORKING ON THE STUFF.
THE MORE I'M AROUND THE BAD
HITTERS, -- YOU GET A FEEL FOR
WHAT THE HITTERS DO, IT MAKES
YOU A BETTER PITCHER.
SCOTT: RUNNERS ON THE CORNER FOR
WASHINGTON.
SCHWARBER AND ROBLES.
MARK: I WAS TALKING ABOUT THAT
AT THE TOP OF THE SHOW, STARTED
HIS CAREER.
>> I JUST LAID IN A HEATER.
MAX: THANKFULLY WE HAD THE
CENTER FIELD PLAY RIGHT THERE.
I WAS BLOWN AWAY.
IT REALLY STUNK.
LIKE WHAT'S THIS ABOUT?
MARK: HE PLAYS GOLF THE SAME
WAY.
TAKES A LEFT-HAND TURN AROUND
300 YARDS AND IT DISAPPEARS INTO
SOMEONE'S BACKYARD.
MAX: THAT'S GOOD TO KNOW.
SCOTT: 2-0 ON ITS WAY.
AND IT WENT AROUND.
MARK: SO WHAT'S THE MINDSET WITH
THE FANS COMING BACK IN?
I'VE GOT TO BELIEVE 20/20 WAS
JUST A WASH.
THAT HAD TO BE COMPLETELY
STRANGE AND ODD.
MAX: IT STOCK.
IT'S GREAT HAVING FANS BACK IN
THE STANDS.
EVERYBODY FEELS THAT ENERGY.
LAUNCHED THAT ONE.
JUST HAVING THE FANS BACK, IT'S
GREAT TO SEE.
HOPEFULLY AS THE SEASON GOES ON
WILL CONTINUE TO GET MORE AND
MORE.
SCOTT: DOES MAX HAVE A FAVORITE
DEFENDER THAT PLAY BEHIND HIM?
MAX: THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
ANTHONY RENDON WAS REALLY GOOD.
AUSTIN JACKSON WAS REALLY GOOD
AT CENTER.
JOSÉ IGLESIAS AT SHORT.
YOU KNOW WHO ACTUALLY LIKED, HE
WORKED HIS TAIL OFF --
SCOTT: MAX, WE APPRECIATE IT,
AND CONGRATS ON THE NEW
ADDITION.
MAX SCHERZER WITH US LIVE ON
3-1 ATLANTA AFTER FOUR.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE FINE
RIGHT HERE.
THE SMILE SAYS IT ALL.
>> IF HE CAN KEEP THE SMILE ON
HIS FACE LONG ENOUGH I WOULD SAY
THERE IS NO WAY HE DOESN'T TAKE
THEM DEEP.
>> ONE BALL, NO STRIKES.
1-0 PITCH, OUT AND AWAY.
2-0.
>> TWO BALLS, TO STRIKES.
HE STRUCK HIM OUT.
LOOK AT RIZZO, HE CAN'T BELIEVE
IT.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S GREAT.
>> ANTHONY RIZZO STRUCK OUT
FREDDIE FREEMAN.
SOMETHING NO OTHER CUB PITCHER
HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO ALL NIGHT
LONG.
SCOTT: IS JACK LAIRD HE REALLY
THE BEST PLAYER IN THE LEAGUE?
GET TO KNOW MORE ABOUT JACK.
AVAILABLE TOMORROW ON
YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
THE LIVE GAME COMMENTARY IS YOUR
BEST FRIEND HERE ON YOUTUBE.
THANKS FOR HELPING US OUT WITH
QUESTIONS FOR MAX SCHERZER.
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS FOR, THROW
THEM -- IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
FOR DERO, THROW THEM IN THEIR.
MAYBE A FEW IN THE POST GAME AS
WELL.
MARK: THERE'S A MAN THERE, KYLE
SCHWARBER.
JON LESTER STANDING IN THE
SUNSHINE THROWING CUTTERS,
CHANGEUPS.
MR. SMILEY JUST FIGHTING FOR
DEAR LIFE.
SCOTT: YOU SAW THAT WITH LESTER
IN HIS LAST AT-BAT.
4:00 EASTERN START TIME TODAY.
DREW SMYLY HAS A LITTLE JON
LESTER IN HIS PROFILE.
0-28 CAREER.
STILL HAS A WAYS TO GO.
PUSH SOMETHING THE OTHER WAY.
SCOTT: BIG INNING FOR ATLANTA
WITH THE FOURTH, THREE RUNS.
THE TWO R.B.I. SINGLE.
MAYBE THIS IS WHY I'M NOT IN THE
BIGS, AMONG THE MANY OTHER
REASONS.
JUST WORKING THAT PITCH COUNT.
A SWING AND TO STRIKES.
IS THAT THE MOVE?
MARK: TRYING TO PUSH ONE DOWN
THE THIRD-BASE LINE.
THERE'S ROOM TO WORK WITH IT.
SCOTT: THERE'S CASTRO.
HE HASN'T BUDGED.
TWO STRIKES AGAINST DREW SMYLY.
MARK: I KNOW MAX SCHERZER JUST
SAID IN HIS INTERVIEW, THEREIN
LIES THE ARGUMENT FOR THE
UNIVERSAL DH.
HAVING THE PITCHER HIT WORKED
FOR ME, BECAUSE I WAS CONSTANTLY
GETTING INTO GAMES.
MOVING STUFF AROUND.
THE UNIVERSAL DH FOR BENCH
PLAYER IS NOT OPTIMAL, BUT I CAN
UNDERSTAND TO ELIMINATE PITCHER
INJURIES AND TO GET THE BEST
NINE PLAYERS, I DO UNDERSTAND
THE ARGUMENT AGAINST THE
UNIVERSAL DH.
SCOTT: FILLS UP THE COUNT AND
PUTS IT IN PLAY FOR CASTRO.
TWO GONE.
THERE'S JOSH HARRISON.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> THAT COULD HAVE BEEN BAD.
THAT COULD HAVE GET -- COULD
HAVE BEEN BAD.
SCOTT: WE ARE GLAD HE IS OK.
ACUNA JUNIOR TAKES A STRIKE,
BOTTOM OF THE ZONE.
MARK: IT'S QUICK.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT JOSH
HARRISON.
FROZE UP THE LINE, YOU'RE TAUGHT
EVEN IN YOUTH BASEBALL, WHAT'S
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING, HIT
IT.
SCOTT: LESTER WITH TWO QUICK
STRIKES ON ACUNA.
SO IF JOSH HARRISON IS A 10 IN
TERMS OF THE VOLUME OF
REHEARSING HE DOES IN THE FEELS,
WHAT NUMBER WERE YOU?
MARK: I WAS A TALKER, I WAS
DEFINITELY AT LEAST AN EIGHT.
TALKING TO THE UMPIRES COME
TRYING TO GET A FEEL.
IT'S FUNNY, MOST OF THE GUYS
WILL GIVE YOU SOME CONVERSATION,
THERE ARE A FEW GUYS, CHASE
UTLEY, CRAIG COUNSELL, VERY
MINIMAL.
IF YOU GOT A HELLO, YOU WERE
FIRED UP.
CRAIG COUNSELL WASN'T VERY
VERBOSE.
SCOTT: ACUNA IN THE AIR, LONG
RUN FOR HERNAND HEAD RIGHT BACKE
DUGOUT AFTER A 12-3-
>> KERRY WOOD GOING TO THE MOUND
FOR THE CUBS TODAY AND THE
CONCLUSION AGAINST THE DIVISION
LEADING HOUSTON ASTROS.
>> I JUST TRY AND TAKE A DEEP
BREATH AND FORGOT WHAT HE DID IN
THE BULLPEN.
>> GOT HIM WITH THE HEAT.
>> CHANGES SPEEDS.
STRIKES OUT.
HE PUNCHED OUT THE ORDER INTO
FIRST.
>> THE BALL WAS COMING OUT
NICELY THAT DAY.
>> GOT HIM.
SEVEN STRIKEOUTS.
HE STRUCK OUT.
SEE YOU LATER.
13 STRIKEOUTS.
WHAT CAN YOU SAY?
15 STRIKEOUTS!
>> GOING TO THE NINTH INNING, I
FELT LIKE I COULD STRIKE ANYBODY
OUT.
>> GOT HIM, HE TIES THE RECORD.
>> EVERYBODY IN THE STADIUM.
>> HERE COMES THE HOOK.
GOT HIM, 20 STRIKEOUTS.
>> TODAY MARKS FOUR HUNDRED 11
GAMES THAT DAVEY MARTINEZ IS THE
NATIONAL SKIPPER.
TODAY THAT MARKS THE LONGEST
TENURED MANAGER IN THEIR HISTORY
.
WE WERE TALKING TO HIM PREGAME
AND HE SAID HE DID NOT KNOW
UNTIL TREA TURNER HUGGED HIM.
HE SAID, ARE YOU JUST IN A GOOD
MOOD TODAY?
SO TURNER LED THE GUY KNOW,
TODAY YOU ARE THE LONGEST
TENURED MANAGER.
DAVEY LOOKED AT HIM AND SAID, IF
YOU KEEP SLOGGING THE WAY YOU
ARE, I WILL BE MANAGER FOR A LOT
LONGER.
SCOTT: GREAT STORY.
THANK YOU.
LONGEST TENURED MANAGER.
THIS IS THEIR GUY NOW.
MARK: A LITTLE TIDBIT.
I WAS TEAMMATES WITH DAVE
MARTINEZ IN ATLANTA.
KIND OF THE TWILIGHT OF HIS
CAREER WAS THE BEGINNING OF MINE
, JULIO FRANCO AND OZZIE
GUILLEN.
A WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE, GOING ON
TO LEARN UNDER JOE MADDON,
GETTING HIS CHOPS THERE AND
WINNING THE WORLD SERIES WITH
THE CUBBIES.
THE RIGHT MAN AT THE RIGHT TIME.
YOU GO BACK TO 2019.
19-31.
THERE WERE TALKS THAT HE WAS
GOING TO BE REPLACED.
SCOTT: WE WERE TALKING ON MLB
NETWORK SOMETIMES ABOUT
SCHERZER.
ALL THIS GARBAGE.
MARK:MARK: WENT ON TO HAVE ONE
OF THE MOST EPIC WORLD SERIES.
SCOTT: TURNER SWINGS IT.
OUT NUMBER ONE.
DAVE MARTINEZ PLAYED FOR 16
SEASONS, NINE TEAMS OVER 1500
GAMES.
BROKEN TO -- 1500 HITS.
HIRED IN OCTOBER 2017.
HE WAS THE BENCH COACH FOR JOE
MADDON FOR A LONG TIME.
THERE'S THE CAREER LINE FOR A
PLAYER.
THE NATIONALS IN 2019 WINNING
THEIR FIRST EVER WORLD SERIES
TITLE.
DAVE MARTINEZ SAID THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE SINCE WINNING --
HUG'S.
JUST WALKING AROUND TOWN WITH
GETTING HUGGED BY RANDOM PEOPLE
IN D.C.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK: THEY SHOULD.
THAT TEAM WAS SPECIAL.
THE INTERESTING THING WATCHING
MARTINEZ AND TALKING TO HIM --
SCOTT: HERNANDEZ TO DEEP CENTER.
AND PACHE IS THERE, COVERING
GREAT GROUND.
A FEW FEET AWAY FROM THE WALL.
MARK: MICE PLAY.
TALKING ABOUT INTERVIEWING FOR
MANAGERIAL POSITIONS AND NOT
GETTING THEM.
HE SAID, I TRIED TO BE JOE
MADDON'S CLONE.
WHEN I FINALLY WENT INTO THESE
INTERVIEWS AND NOT ONLY'S SPOKE
ABOUT WHAT I BELIEVED JOE MADDON
DID WELL, BUT ALSO HOW I WOULD
BE AN INDIVIDUAL, THAT FELT LIKE
MR. RIZZO AND LERNER WERE
LISTENING A LOT MORE.
AND IN TURN HE ENDS UP GETTING A
CRACK AT MANAGING THE NATIONALS
AND WINNING THE WORLD SERIES.
SCOTT: FIRST PITCH SWINGING.
AND THAT IS GOING TO BE CAUGHT
BY AUSTIN RILEY.
WE ARE GOING TO GET WORD.
JOSH HARRISON.
THERE IT IS.
AUSTIN RILEY CAN FLY.
OVER AT FIRST BASE.
AND AGAIN, DREW SMYLY WITH A
NICE 1-2-3 INNING IN THE FIFTH.
>> THERE'S ALWAYS SO MUCH
EXCITEMENT AND ANTICIPATION
PRIOR TO GAME ONE AND FOR GREAT
REASON.
>> TWO OUT AND NOBODY ON.
HERE'S RYAN ZIMMERMAN.
THE LONGEST TENURED NATIONAL.
SWING, DEEP CENTER FIELD.
WAY BACK GOES SPRING OR.
TO THE WARNING TRACK, LOOKING UP
AND IT IS GONE!
GOODBYE.
>> WE GO TO THE FOURTH INNING.
NATIONALS TRAILING 2-1.
.
JUAN SOTO FACING GERRIT COLE.
FLY BALL WELL HIT TO LEFT FIELD,
IT IS GOING, GOING, LONG GONE
ONTO THE RAILROAD TRACKS.
>> 20 YEARS OLD AND BURSTING
WITH POWER.
THE ASTROS ARE DOWN TO THEIR
FINAL OUT.
INTO LEFT CENTER FIELD, ROBLES
IS THERE.
AND THE WASHINGTON NATIONALS
HAVE STOLEN GAME ONE ON THE
ROAD.
>> THE NATS, IF THEY CAN WIN THE
THREE OF THE NEXT 16, WILL WIN
THE -- SIX GAMES, WILL WIN THE
WORLD SERIES.
>> EVERYBODY GETTING IN ON THE
ACT TONIGHT.
>> THE NATIONALS HAVE CERTAINLY
COME TO HOUSTON TO FLEX THEIR
MUSCLES.
>> AND THAT'S THE BALLGAME.
A BLOW OUT HERE TONIGHT IN GAME
TWO.
SCOTT: DOWNLOAD THE MLB UP TO
GET IN GAME VIDEO HIGHLIGHTS AND
PLAYER STATS AND MORE FOR THE
TEAM AND THE REST OF THE GAME.
BACK TO JON LESTER IN THE SIXTH.
SCOTT BRAUN AND MARK DEROSA ON
YOUTUBE.
OZZIE ALBIES WALKED LAST TIME
AND ENDED UP SCORING.
THAT WAS ALL THE ACTION FOR THE
BRAVES.
THE FOURTH INNING.
BRIAN SNITKER.
ONE ON THE OUTSIDE CORNER,
BREAKING STUFF.
NOT DOING GREAT WORK AGAINST
LEFT-HANDED PITCHING THIS YEAR.
A SMALL SAMPLE SIZE.
HE OWNS JON LESTER.
MARK: I KNOW THAT SMALL SAMPLE
SIZE.
THAT IS OWNERSHIP.
[LAUGHTER]
AND IT CONTINUES.
SCOTT: 7-9.
MARK: THAT'S BIG.
SCOTT: NEW TO THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK, THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF
THE GAME, FANS WATCHING ON
MOBILE DEVICES AND COMPUTERS,
LATER IS YOUR CHANCE TO VOTE.
WHICH PLAYER WILL RECEIVE THE
TROPHY IN THE POSTGAME?
NOT ONLY DO YOU GET TO DECIDE
WHICH PLAYERS ARE GRAVITATING TO
, YOU ALSO GET TO PICK WHO WE
TALK TO IN THE POST GAME.
WHO IS THE EARLY LEADER?
ADRIANZA WITH THE TWO R.B.I.
DOUBLE, PERHAPS.
HERE COMES DAVE MARTINEZ TO TAKE
THE BASEBALL.
ONTO THE NATIONALS BULLPEN.
MARCELL OZUNA COMING UP FOR
ATLANTA IN THE SIXTH.
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> AND THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO.
>> THAT BALL WAS CRUSHED.
♪
>> STRIKE THREE.
THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> I TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS.
THAT WAS INCREDIBLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
SCOTT: AFTER AN ALBIES HIT
THROUGH THE INFIELD, MARCELL
OZUNA.
LOOK WHAT HE BROUGHT TO THE
TABLE FOR THE ATLANTA BRAVES.
A GRAND SLAM AGAINST THE
WASHINGTON NATIONALS YESTERDAY.
IN THE THIRD INNING, THEY
DECIDED TO INTENTIONALLY WALK
BRENDAN FREEMAN.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD
SHOWING US THE LONGEST AVERAGE
DISTANCED HOMER IN BASEBALL
SINCE THE START OF 2020.
IT IS MARCELL OZUNA, AVERAGING
433 FEET OF GLORY WHEN HE
CONNECTS OFF THE BAT OVER THE
WALL.
YOU THINK ABOUT YESTERDAY,
FREDDIE HAS BEEN STRUGGLING.
THEY PUT HIM ON.
MARCEL IS LIKE, REALLY?
LAST YEAR I LEAD IN HOMERS AND
R.B.I.S.
MARK: I WAS YELLING AT THE TV
WHEN RONALD STOLE SECOND BECAUSE
IT ALMOST FORCED HIS HAND.
THEY HAVE CALLED LIGHTNING AND A
BOTTLE.
YOU GO BACK TO 2019, JOSH
DONALDSON IN THE ONE YEAR DEAL,
HE HIT BEHIND FREDDIE AND HE WAS
A MONSTER.
THEN THEY DOUBLE DOWN ON ANOTHER
ONE YEAR DEAL WITH OSUNA.
THEY GOT AWAY WITH IT AGAIN.
HE HAS BEEN AWESOME FOR THIS
TEAM.
NOT JUST IN THE LINEUP, JUST
EVERYTHING HE BRINGS.
SCOTT: FILES BACK THAT PITCH
FROM AUSTIN BOTH -- AUSTIN VOTH.
MOSTLY FOUR-SEAMERS AND
CURVEBALLS.
OFF TO A NICE START.
HE'S DEALING WITH ONE OF THE
N.L. BEST FROM 2020, FOUR YEAR
DEAL AND THE OFF-SEASON WITH $65
MILLION FOR ATLANTA.
MARK: THAT WAS AN INTERESTING
DEAL.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN ATLANTA
THOUGHT THEY WERE HITTING
AGAINST THEMSELVES.
YOU SAW GUYS LIKE NELSON CRUZ
AND MARCELL OZUNA HAVING TO WAIT
OUT THE MARKET.
SCOTT: HE WAS INCREDIBLE LAST
YEAR.
MARK: INCREDIBLE.
SCOTT: SIXTH PLACED N.L. AND
B.P..
YOU GO BY O.P.S.+, IT'S NOT THAT
COMPLICATED.
75% BETTER THAN THE AVERAGE BIG
LEAGUER.
THAT IS SAYING SOMETHING.
1-1 BACK TO AUSTIN VOTH.
HE WILL GO TO SECOND AND THEY
WILL TURN.
THAT'S RIGHT.
A DOUBLE PLAY FOR AUSTIN VOTH TO
ERASE BOTH BASE RUNNERS.
MARK: I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MUCH
IT MEANS FOR THE POSITION PLAYER
FOR THE PITCHER TO WORK ON IT.
YOU WORK ON THIS IN THE BACK
YIELDS AT SPRING TRAINING, AND A
SITUATION LIKE THIS HAS TO GET
DONE AND HE CAN DO IT.
I PLAYED WITH CARLOS ARANO, JOHN
SMOLTZ, ADAM WAINWRIGHT, WHO
REALLY TOOK PRIDE IN THE OTHER
PARTS OF THEIR GAME WHEN IT
MATTERS, HOLDING RUNNERS, BEING
ABLE TO P.F.P., COVER THE BAGS,
GET BUNTS DOWN.
SCOTT: MAX FRIED WON THE GOLD
GLOVE IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE
LAST YEAR.
MARK: DALLAS KEUCHEL WAS
SOMETHING FOR THE WHITE SOX.
SCOTT: MAKES SENSE.
IF YOU ARE A GROUND BALL GUY,
YOU BETTER FIELD YOUR POSITION.
THEY OFF FOR FREEMAN TODAY.
-- THE DAY OFF FOR FREEMAN
TODAY.
VOTH VERSUS RILEY.
DOESN'T BITE.
MARK: IT HAS BEEN NICE TO SEE
AUSTIN RILEY SITUATE HIMSELF
INTO MORE COMFORT AT THE PLATE.
THIS WAS A GUY, YOU COULDN'T
KEEP HIM IN THE MINORS ANY
LONGER.
THEN HE CAME AND PLAYED LEFT
FIELD AND HIT LIKE 12 JACKS IN
30 GAMES AND EVERYONE FELL IN
LOVE.
THEN THERE WAS A HUGE VALLEY.
THEN A HUGE COME -- HOMER LAST
YEAR IN THE NLCS.
HE'S FINDING HIS RHYTHM.
I DON'T THINK WE TRULY KNOW YET.
SCOTT: NINE HOMERS HIS FIRST 18
CAREER GAMES.
MARK: THERE IT WAS.
I REMEMBER HITTING HOMERS WITH
HIS DAD IN THE STANDS.
SCOTT: I WATCHED HIM IN THE
PLAYOFFS LAST YEAR.
A LOT OF CONTACT TO CENTER
FIELD.
THIS TIME ON THE GROUND TO THE
LEFT SIDE.
AND THERE IS THE INNING.
HERE COMES AUSTIN VOTH FOR A
DOUBLE PLAY BALL AND THEN A
GROUND BALL OUT FOR RILEY.
THE BRAVES STILL UP BY TWO, MID
SIX.
>> THIS IS THE 115TH WORLD
SERIES.
FOR JUST THE THIRD TIME IN THE
HISTORY OF THE CLASSIC, THE ROAD
TEAM HAS WON EACH OF THE FIRST
FIVE GAMES.
TONIGHT, THE NATIONALS TRYING TO
FORCE A GAME SEVEN TOMORROW
NIGHT.
>> TO DEEP RIGHT.
DOWN THE LINE.
GOING, GOING, GONE.
GOODBYE.
BANG!
IT'S THE NATIONALS TWO AND THE
ASTROS TWO.
>> NOW JUAN SOTO.
SOTO SWINGS AND HITS ONE HIGH
AND DEEP TO RIGHT.
GOING, GOING.
INTO THE TOP!
A TREMENDOUS HOME RUN FOR JUAN
SOTO.
AND THE WORLD SERIES GAME SIX
WITH A CHARLIE W IS IN THE
BOOKS.
>> LET'S FINISH THE FIGHT
TONIGHT.
>> THAT IS A ROCKET TO LEFT AND
THE LEAD IS CUT IN HALF.
>> HITS A -- HITS IT DOWN THE
RIGHT-FIELD LINE AND IT'S GONE.
HENDRICK HAS DONE IT AGAIN.
>> WHAT A STUNNER HERE IN GAME
SEVEN.
THE NATIONALS A STRIKE AWAY FROM
THAT FRANCHISE.
>> SWING AND A MISS AND A WORLD
SERIES GAME SEVEN, UNBELIEVABLE.
>> IN THE MIDDLE OF THE FOURTH
INNING AT NATIONALS PARK, THE
RACING PRESIDENTS CHASING EACH
OTHER AND CRAZINESS ENSUES.
YOU KNOW BEAT THE FREEZE IS
SOMETHING THAT CANNOT BE MISSED.
WITH THE YOUTUBE POLE, WHICH IS
THE MORE ENTERTAINING BALLPARKS
BAIT -- STABLE?
WE WILL SEE RIGHT HERE.
THIS IS ALWAYS SO GOOD.
WHICH ONE DO YOU GUYS LIKE THAT
ARE?
BEAT THE FREEZE OR THE
PRESIDENTS RACE?
[LAUGHTER]
MARK: BEAT THE FREEZE IS GOOD.
BUT I'M LOYAL TO THE PRESIDENTS
RACE.
I THINK IT'S THE BEST ONE.
AND I HAVE A LITTLE BACKSTORY TO
IT.
2012 POSTSEASON, BY -- RIGHT
BEFORE THE JAYSON WERTH EPIC
HOME RUN TO FORCE GAME FIVE.
I BROUGHT IN A KARAOKE MACHINE.
SCOTT: KARAOKE MACHINE?
MARK: ME AND MIKE MORSE HAD A
KARAOKE MACHINE.
WE SHARED A LOCKER.
WE HAD A KARAOKE MACHINE IN
2012.
WE HAD A LOT OF FUN.
I FELT LIKE THE GUYS NEEDED ME
TO DO THAT IN THEIR ARENA FOR
TEDDY ROOSEVELT -- TO READ "THE
MAN IN THE ARENA" BY TEDDY
ROOSEVELT I RECITED THE
INCREDIBLE SPEECH.
THAT IS STILL ONE OF THE
TOUGHEST LOSSES SINCE I'VE
RETIRED THAT I GO BACK TO.
THAT TEAM COULD HAVE WON THE
WHOLE THING.
WE WERE ROLLING.
THAT TEAM WAS ROLLING.
GIO.
STRASBURG GOT SHUT DOWN.
HAD WE HAD HIM POSTSEASON, IT'S
ANOTHER STORY.
SCOTT: IT EVENTUALLY ALL WORKED
OUT IN 2019.
STARLIN CASTRO, HE'S ON FOR THE
SECOND TIME TODAY.
LET'S SEE IF THE NATS CAN GET
THINGS GOING.
RIGHT NOW, YOUR PLAYER SPOTLIGHT
PRESENTED BY GLOBAL CITIZEN VAX
LIVE.
IN THE FIRST HALF OF 2019, HE
WASN'T JUST AN ALL-STAR, HE WAS
A SUPERSTAR.
SINCE THEN, WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
SAME EVERYTHING FROM JOSH BELL
AT THE PLATE THAT WE WITNESSED
IN THE FIRST HALF.
WE THOUGHT THE NEXT SUPERSTAR
WAS COMING TO THE SHOW.
BIG DUDE, FORMER BIG-TIME PICK
FROM THE PITTSBURGH PIRATES.
A LOT OF PRIMUS -- PROMISE IN
THE MINOR LEAGUES.
GREAT KID.
YOU CAN SEE SO FAR THIS SEASON,
SLOW START, .145, ON THE COVID
I.L. THAT MANY OF THEM DEALT
WITH.
HAS NOT CLICKED LIKE HE DID WITH
THE FIRST HALF OF 2019.
I WANT TO PREFACE WHAT YOU BRING
TO THE TABLE WITH, DID THE
LEAGUE ADJUST TO HIM AND HE'S
NOT ADJUSTING BACK YET?
MARK: IT'S FUNNY, YOU TRY AND
FIND WAYS.
I LOOK AT IT A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY.
IT IS LIKE THE GRASS ISN'T
GREENER ON THE OTHER SIDE, BUT
FOR SOME GUYS, IT MAY BE.
CHRIS GUCCIONE HE RIGHT THERE.
SAYS HE DID NOT GO.
MY THING IS DRIVING TO THE YARD
EVERY DAY, WHAT IS YOUR
MOTIVATION?
PLAYING FOR THE PITTSBURGH
PIRATES, YOU KNOW YOU HAVE NO
SHOT AT WINNING THE N.L.
CENTRAL, SO YOU GET REAL
SELFISH.
IF YOU GET SELFISH IN BASEBALL,
YOU START GOING DOWN DARK PATHS.
IF YOU ARE NOT GETTING RESULTS,
I JUST KIND OF LEADING MORE
TOWARDS THAT.
I WANT TO GIVE HIM MORE OF A
TIME TO GET HIS LEGS UNDER HIM
IN THE D.C. AREA.
EXPECTATIONS ARE GOING TO BE WAY
BIGGER.
PIRATES ARE IN A FULL-BLOWN
REBUILD.
I CAN AGREE WITH WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING AS FAR AS HE MADE IT AN
EFFORT TO GET THE BALL IN THE
AIR, START DRIVING THE BALL OUT
OF THE PARK.
SCOTT: RILEY FOUND THE POPPER.
FIRST OUT IN THE BOTTOM OF THE
SIXTH.
NOW YAN GOMES.
BELL LAST YEAR, .226, .364
SLUGGING, BUT IT WAS 57 GAMES.
MARK: WITH NO FANS.
LAST YEAR FOR THESE GUYS, THEY
SAID ALL THE RIGHT THINGS.
HATS OFF TO BASEBALL AND
EVERYONE ASSOCIATED FOR GRANTING
IT OUT -- GRINDING IT OUT.
NOW WE ARE PAST THAT, THAT 60
GAMES, IT'S WHATEVER.
YOU CAN'T HONOR THE NUMBERS.
IT'S LIKE PLAYING ON THE
BACKFIELD OF SPRING TRAINING
WHEN NO ONE IS WATCHING.
SCOTT: MOST OF THE FRONT OFFICE
EXECUTIVES I TALK TO WHEN THEY
ARE EVALUATING PLAYERS, THEY
OFTEN REFER TO 2019, OR THEY
TAKE A COMBO.
IT'S LIKE ADDING SOME MORE
MONTHS TO THE LEDGER IN THE
RECENT PAST.
I THINK IT'S TIME.
MORE LOVE RIGHT NOW.
I KNOW BRAVES FANS ARE WAITING
FOR IT.
SMILEY THROWING TO JEFF MATHIS
TODAY.
JUST LIKE BRIAN SNITKER SAID.
MIGHT HAVE FOUND HIMSELF A
PERSONAL CATCHER.
5.1, ONE RUN, THREE WALKS BUT
PUNCHED OUT FOUR.
MARK: I LOOK AT IT THE OTHER
WAY, SCOTT.
HE MIGHT HAVE FOUND HIMSELF A
PERSONAL CATCHER, BUT THE
EXPECTATIONS ON A ONE YEAR, $11
MILLION DEAL FOR DREW SMYLY ARE
THIS.
SCOTT: THAT WAS SOME PLAY.
WOW.
[LAUGHTER]
AUSTIN RILEY DOING SOME WORK AT
FIRST.
HERE IT IS AGAIN.
GO THROUGH SECOND, THE LEAP FROM
SWANSON, TOUCHES THE BAG, FIRES
TO FIRST AND THE BRAVES CAN PICK
IT.
PLAY.
AND AGAIN, A SCORELESS INNING
FOR DREW SMYLY.
ATLANTA GOING FOR THE SWEEP.
♪
>> ♪ WANTS IN THE BOX?
WHAT IS IN THE BOX?
WHAT'S INTHE BOX? ♪
>> JELL-O.
>> A PLATE?
>> WHAT IS THIS?
UGH.
IS IT FLAN?
>> DESSERT?
GELATINA?
>> IS IT ELBOW?
-- EDIBLE?
RICE PUDDING?
>> JELL-O?
I GUESS.
>> A TYPE OF CHEESECAKE?
I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT IS IT?
>> CHEESECAKE?
>> STRAWBERRY JELLY?
OR GRAPE JELLY?
>> IS THAT JELL-O?
[LAUGHTER]
♪
>> WE ARE THRILLED TO HAVE YOU
WITH US FOR THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK ON YOUTUBE PRESENTED BY
GLOBAL CITIZEN VAX LIVE.
EXTENDED SHOW ONLY ON YOUTUBE
THIS SATURDAY AT 8:00 EASTERN.
SOME SUPERSTAR, LEGENDARY
PERFORMANCES COMING ON SATURDAY
AT 8:00.
IF YOU LOVE MUSIC, THAT IS THE
SPOT TO BE.
THE FOO FIGHTERS, JENNIFER
LOPEZ.
THIS COPYRIGHTED TELECAST IS
PRESENTED BY AUTHORITY OF THE
OFFICE OF THE COMMISSIONER OF
BASEBALL, AND MAY NOT BE
REPRODUCED OR RETRANSMITTED IN
ANY FORM AND THE ACCOUNTS AND A
SCRIPTION OF THIS GAME MAY NOT
BE DISSEMINATED WITHOUT EXPRESS
WRITTEN CONSENT.
I DO THAT ONCE OR TWICE A WEEK.
I'M PRETTY FAST AT IT.
DANSBY SWANSON TURNS ONE HECK OF
A DOUBLE PLAY WITH AUSTIN RILEY,
BACK IN THE BOTTOM OF THE FIFTH.
MAKE THAT THE BOTTOM OF THE
SIXTH.
NOW HE LEADS OFF THE SEVENTH FOR
ATLANTA.
5, 6, AND SEVEN COMING UP.
MARK: HERE IS WHERE YOU WANT
DANSBY COMING UP RIGHT HERE.
MIDDLE AWAY HEATER, TRYING TO GO
OPPOSITE FIELD.
DOUBLE OFF THE RIGHT CENTER GAP.
SCOTT: THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
AUSTIN VOTH WORKING AT THE
SECOND INNING HERE.
TWO FOR 13, A DOUBLE AND A
HOMER.
SOLID CONTACT TO CENTER.
HANGING IN THE AIR, AND LOOK
WHO'S ALL OVER IT!
VICTOR ROBLES.
BOTH CENTER FIELDERS TODAY
PUTTING ON A SHOW.
LOOK AT ROBLES MOVE.
MADE THAT PLAY LOOK EASY.
MARK: FIRST THE QUICKNESS, HE
HAD THE THROW COMPLETE ON
ADRIANZA.
SCOTT: OUTS ABOVE AVERAGE IS A
GREAT STAT TO MEASURE OVERALL
DEFENSIVE PERFORMANCE.
SINCE THE START OF 2019, KEVIN
KIERMAIER AND VICTOR ROBLES.
ROBLES LEAD IN 20 AS A ROOKIE.
ASK MIKE RIZZO THAT YEAR.
ADRIANZA TAKES -- SAVANNAH, WHAT
DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE DEFENSIVE
PERFORMANCE TODAY IN CENTER
FIELD?
SAVANNAH: YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT
FIRST STEP QUICKNESS AND THAT IS
SOMETHING DAVEY MARTINEZ PICKED
UP ON.
LAST SEASON, VICTOR ROBLES CAME
TO SUMMER CAN'T WITH 20 POUNDS
OF -- CAMP WITH 20 POUNDS OF
MUSCLE.
HE WANTED TO GO A LITTLE BIGGER.
AND DAVEY MARTINEZ SAID MAY BE
LET'S LOSE A LITTLE BIT AND GAIN
FLEXIBILITY.
A PLAY LIKE THAT SHOWS YOU HE
MIGHT HAVE LOST A LITTLE MUSCLE
WEIGHT, BUT THAT GUY CAN MOVE.
SCOTT: AGILITY, FLEXIBILITY.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WORKED ON THIS
PAST SEASON AND WE ARE SEEING
THE 2019 FORM OUT IN CENTER
FIELD.
THEY ALSO HAVE HIM PLAYING A BIT
FARTHER BACK THIS YEAR SO HE CAN
RUN IN ON THE BASEBALLS.
THAT HAS BEEN WORKING OUT FOR
HIM AS WELL.
THEY DID THAT WITH JUAN SOTO
LAST YEAR.
HE CAN FLY, SO DON'T WORRY.
IF HE NEEDS TO COME IN, HE WILL
BE THERE.
MARK: NO ONE'S TELLING US TO
STOP LIFTING.
[LAUGHTER]
WE LOVE IT.
SCOTT: VICTOR ROBLES DOESN'T
NEED TO LIFT WEIGHTS RIGHT NOW.
JUST DO THIS.
IN THIS SERIES, HE ROBBED RONALD
ACUNA JR. TUESDAY.
HE'S ALREADY A STRONG GUY AND
THEY NEED HIM TO DO MORE OF
THIS.
LAST NIGHT COMING IN FOR THE
BASEBALL.
YOU CAN FLY, YOU ARE GOOD.
THIS TIME, SUPERMAN ACTION.
POPPED UP.
GOMES IS LOOKING FOR IT.
AND HE FINDS IT.
MARK: THEREIN LIES GETTING BACK
TO THE SHIFT.
YOU HAVE A GUY LIKE VICTOR
ROBLES WHO WANTS TO COME IN.
NOT OUT OF SHAPE, BUT IN THE
WRONG SHAPE.
WHY?
WANTS TO DRIVE THE BALL OUT OF
THE YARD.
SCOTT: THAT'S WHAT EVERYONE IS
DOING AND GETTING PAID FOR IT.
IT'S TEMPTING.
MARK: ARE THEY ARE GETTING PAID
FOR IT?
BECAUSE IT'S WATERED DOWN.
YOU SEE THE MEGA GUYS GETTING
PAID.
THE MIDDLE GUYS GET SQUEEZED
OUT.
SCOTT: CENTER FIELD, IT'S TOUGH
TO FIND AN -- IT'S TOUGH TO FIND
AN ELITE HITTER.
A GOOD EXAMPLE WOULD BE LORENZO
CAIN, FIVE YEARS, $80 MILLION A
FEW YEARS BACK.
SET YOUR SIGHTS ON A PLAYER LIKE
THAT IF YOU'RE PACHE, OR ROBLES.
THAT'S GOOD.
MARK: YEAH, WE CAN MAKE IT
WORK WITH THAT.
SCOTT: THESE ARE TWO OF THE
FINEST CENTER FIELDERS IN THE
BIZ.
THEY'RE JUST YOUNG.
FANS ARE STILL LEARNING ABOUT
THE TOOLS.
ALSO, IN ADDITION TO THE RANGE
THAT PACHE HAS, HE MIGHT HAVE
THE BEST ARM IN MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST STRONG, IT
IS INCREDIBLY PRECISE.
MARK: LISTEN, ANY PROSPECT
THAT'S GOING TO COME THROUGH AS
AN OUTFIELDER IN THE BRAVES
ORGANIZATION IS GOING TO BE
COMPARED TO ONE GUY AND ONE GUY
ALONE, AND THAT'S ANDRUW JONES,
ONE OF THE BEST TO EVER DO IT.
I KNOW IT'S WILLIE MAYS' 90TH
BIRTHDAY, BUT YOU CAN ARGUE
ANDREW IS AS GOOD AS HIM.
THAT'S TO YOU'RE BEING COMPARED
TO.
HE'S THAT OUTFIELD GROUP, WORKED
WITH -- GURU, WORKED WITH PACHE
OVER THE YEARS -- WHEN I WAS
PLAYING SHORTSTOP, SECOND BASE,
ANDREW WAS BREATHING DOWN MY
NECK.
GREG MADDUX, SMOLTZY, THEY
WANTED THOSE KNOCKS TAKEN AWAY.
OVER YOUR HEAD, IT'S ON ME.
SCOTT: AND HE GOT HIM.
AUSTIN VOTH WITH THE STRIKEOUT.
SO,THEN HE STRIKES OUT THE BRACE
CENTER FIELDER.
PERFECT SEVEN FROM THE NATS
RELIEVER.
♪
>> SWING AND A MISS.
GOT HIM!
ON THE HOOK.
>> THE WIN FOR EDDIE FATTY.
THE NATIONALS OF WON THREE
INTRO.
-- HAVE WON THREE IN A ROW.
♪
>> SCHERZER STEALING AND THERE'S
NO PLAY!
HE JUST GOT A WALKING LEAD AND
KEPT ON GOING.
>> CHECK IT OUT, FOLKS, STANDING
OVATION IN THE BALLPARK, MAX
SCHERZER, FIRST CAREER STOLEN
BASE.
♪
>> AND THERE'S A LOOK AT THE
22-YEAR-OLD MAKING HIS
MAJOR-LEAGUE DEBUT, ANOTHER
LEFT-HANDER, PATRICK CORBIN.
NICE CHANGEUP.
SWING AND A MISS.
BOY, PATRICK CORBIN.
INSIDE CORNER.
HANLEY RAMIREZ IS RUNG UP.
THAT'S HOW THIS GAME ENDS AND
PATRICK ARE MAJOR LEAGUE DEBUT.
-- AND PATRICK CORBIN'S MAJOR
LEAGUE DEBUT.
SCOTT: ALL SEASON LONG, MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL WILL HAVE A
FRONTLINE AND ESSENTIAL WORKERS
WHO TRULY LIFT UP THEIR FELLOW
CITIZENS DURING THE PANDEMIC.
THANK YOU, FRONTLINE HEROES.
STRETCHING WE HAVE THE FULL
RESORT TO BRING YOU, MORE
ENTERTAINING SIGNATURE RACE,
BRAVES FANS SHOWING UP VAGUE,
60%, PRESIDENTS RACE ONLY 32%,
BOTH HIGHLY ENTERTAINING IN
THEIR OWN WAYS, ONE INVOLVING
FOUR VERY UNIQUE MASCOTS.
MAKE A TON OF SENSE.
BEAT THE FREEZE JUST CAME OUT OF
NOWHERE FOUR OR FIVE YEARS AGO
AND WHAT VIRAL, REALLY.
AFTER THAT RACE, ONE OF THE
FIRST FEW, WHEN GUY THOUGHT HE
HAD HIM, STARTING TO MELT IT --
MILK IT, CELEBRATE A LITTLE BIT,
YOU LOOK BACK, FALL, AND A
LEGEND WAS BORN.
MARK: WHILE WE'RE MESSING
AROUND, BOTTOM OF THE SEVENTH,
MR. SMILEY'S STILL -- SMYLY'S
STILL IN THERE.
SCOTT: SEVEN, EIGHT, NINE IN THE
ORDER FOR THE NATIONAL SPIRIT --
NATIONALS.
.
YOU'VE GOT THE FASTBALL UP, THE
BREAKER LOW, AND THE FASTBALL
DOWN.
MARK: YOU HEARD ME TALK ABOUT
THAT, SCOTTY B.
ONE OF MY TAKES, IT ALMOST
BECOME SWING MODE.
YOU ALMOST CAN THINK YOU CAN HIT
EVERYTHING THAT'S THROWN.
IF YOU ARE IN THE ZONE TOO MUCH,
THAT'S WHEN HE WILL GET HURT.
SCOTT: AND TOMMY WILL KNOW.
HE WORKED OF THOSE EDGES AS WELL
AS ANYONE WE'VE EVER SEEN.
MARK: DREW SMYLY HAS NOT
COMPLETED SEVEN INNINGS SINCE
SEPTEMBER 7, 2019.
SCOTT: PITCH COUNT'S AT 93.
SEASON HIGH IS 94.
IN FIRST OUTING OF THE YEAR
AGAINST THE NATIONALS, WHEN HE
WENT SIX.
THE BRAVES ARE HIS FIFTH
ORGANIZATION SINCE 2019.
HE'S HOPPED AROUND.
HASN'T BEEN THE SAME GUY SINCE
COMING BACK FROM TOMMY JOHN
SURGERY.
REALLY, A NUMBER OF INJURIES FOR
HIM THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
DIDN'T PITCH AT ALL IN 2017 OR
2018.
MISSED 324 GAMES.
PAYOFF.
YOU CAN LOOK AT THAT ALSO AS A
GUY WHO HAS A LOT LEFT IN THE
TANK, HASN'T BEEN USED A TON THE
PAST FEW YEARS.
MARK: LISTEN, THERE'S SOME
FUNKINESS TO THEM, LATE LIFE TO
THE FASTBALL, SWING AND MISS.
IF YOU FOR LEFT-HANDED AND YOU
CAN RUN AT UP THERE, YOU KNOW.
THEY'LL KEEP YOU AROUND.
SCOTT: HIS FOUR-SEAMER WAS
GETTING CRUSHED BEFORE TODAY'S
OUTING.
LUKE JACKSON APPARENTLY THE
FUNNIEST GUY ON THE ATLANTA
BRAVES, IAN ANDERSON TOLD US
EARLIER.
RIGHT?
HE GAVE A BIKE TOUR TO SOME OF
THE OTHER PITCHERS.
MARK: THE MONUMENTS ON THEIR OFF
DAY.
SCOTT: GOOD A.B. BY SCHWARBER.
HE'S BATTLING.
MARK: YOU CAN'T WALK IN.
SCHWARBER'S THE KIND OF GUY THAT
WANTS TO HIT ON, AND HE HAS GOOD
PLATE VISION.
THAT HEATER GOING DOWN AND AWAY
IS THE -- IS THE SAME AS JEFF
MATHIS.
SCOTT: MISS.
LEAD OFF BASE RUNNER FOR THE
NATIONALS.
HE KNCKS OU -- KNOCKS OUT THE
STARTER, TOO, DREW SMYLY, BIG
DAY FOR ATLANTA.
ARE THERE ANY RIGHTIES IN THE
BULLPEN?
MARK: LUKE JACKSON, THE ONE HE'S
CALLING.
SCOTT: YOU'RE ACCURATE WITH
THAT GAS.
THIS TIME -- GUESS.
THIS TIME, YES, IT'S A RIGHTY
COMING IN.
♪
>> HEART IS PALPITATING.
>> SWING AND A MISS.
THE BAT GOES ALL THE WAY OUT,
SHALLOW RIGHT FIELD.
THAT IS GOOD DISTANCE.
THE BAT HEAD HIT FAIR.
>> NOT A FAIR BALL, BUT THAT'S A
FAIR BAT.
>> BEHIND HOME PLATE, MURPHY
TRYING TO PICK IT OUT OF THE
DOME, GETS TANGLED UP WITH THE
UMPIRE AND SOMEHOW MAKES THE
CATCH!
THE FIRST BASE UMPIRE SAYS YES,
HIT A RING.
WHAT A JOB BY SEAN MURPHY AND
OVER NOTHING.
>> THE TOWEL IS GONE.
>> PATEL'S -- THE TOWEL'S OFF.
NOW, HE WANTS TO GO HIDE.
DON'T LOOK
>> [LAUGHTER]
>> RIZZO VERSUS RAYMOND.
-- FREEMAN.
>> HE WANTS TO PUNCH HIM OUT SO
BAD.
>> HE GOT HIM!
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: LUKE JACKSON IS IN FOR
ATLANTA THE FACE EIGHTH PLACE
HITTER VICTOR ROBLES, SCOTT
BRAUN, MARK DEROSA, AND OUR
THIRD ANALYST IS ACTUALLY
PLAYING ON THE FIELD.
HIS NAME IS JOSH HARRISON.
JOSH: THIS IS GOING TO BE GOOD.
HE IS GOOD, WHEN HE FIGURES IT
OUT.
OH!
GET UP, BALL!
AH.
DANG.
OFF THE BAT, IT LOOKED LIKE IT
WAS GOING.
TOO HIGH.
SCOTT: THANK YOU, JOSH, FOR ALL
OF Y OUR WO -- YOUR WORDS OF
WISDOM TODAY.
SERIOUS.
FUN TEAMMATE TO HAVE.
ROBLES PULLS BACK ON THE BUNT
FROM LUKE JACKSON.
I WAS JOKING, IT'S PROBABLY A
LEFTY.
NO, IT'S A RIGHTY.
YOU JUST DON'T SEE THIS FROM
BULLPENS THESE DAYS.
THIS IS HIS 12TH APPEARANCE.
THE BRAVES HAVE MORE LEFTIES
THAN RIGHTIES IN THEIR
BULLPEN.
MARK: AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT I
THINK HAS TO BE ADDRESSED AS
THIS SEASON PROGRESSES.
SCOTT: THAT'S HIT AND ROBLES IS
IN BUSINESS.
NATS PUTTING PRESSURE ON JACKSON
IN THE SEVENTH.
HOW DO YOU ADDRESS IT?
MARK: JUST GOING TO HAVE TO GO
OUT AND FIND A WAY -- CHRIS
MARTIN, OBVIOUSLY.
SHOCKED I SAW MARK MELANCON, ONE
YEAR, $2 MILLION FOR THE SAN
DIEGO PADRES.
SHANE GREENE STILL.
SCOTT: NATS FANS ON THEIR FEET
FOR JUAN SOTO, AT BAT OF THE
DAY.
CAN'T PLAY THE FIELD YET.
CROW HOP DRILLS, MOCK THROWS ON
TUESDAY.
HE'LL D.H. THIS WEEKEND,
INTERLEAGUE AFFAIR AGAINST THE
YANKEES IN THE BRONX.
THEY HOPE TO HAVE HIM BACK IN
THE FIELD NEXT WEEK.
TWO ON.
THAT MISS?
MARK: YEAH.
SCOTT: TECHNICALLY.
WHERE WAS THAT?
MARK: I GUESS WE GOT THAT UP.
YOU WATCH LUKE JACKSON THROW,
THIS GUY IS 51% SLIDER, 39%
FOUR-SEAMER.
YOU'RE HUNTING BREAKING BALL
MORE THAN SITTING ON THE HEATER.
SCOTT: ZITO HASN'T BEEN A PINCH
HITTER OFTEN IN HIS CAREER.
USUALLY PLAYING.
1-6 AS A PINCH HITTER WITH A
HOME RUN.
MARK: NOW YOU'RE IN A TOUGH
SITUATION IF YOU'RE LUKE
JACKSON.
YOU REALLY WANT TO GET BACK IN
THIS COUNT?
YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT TREA TURNER
ON-DECK.
THIS IS WHERE YOU PUT BRIAN
SNITKER IN A TOUGH POSITION THE
WAY HIS BULLPEN IS CONSTRUCTED.
SCOTT: 2-0.
SOTO CONNECTS, LEFT FIELD, OZUNA
BACK, AND HE'S ON IT.
AND BOTH RUNNERS RETREAT.
THAT'S A BIG OUT.
NOW, LUKE JACKSON WITH SOME
CONFIDENCE BACK TO THE MOUND.
MARK: HE HAD TO GET BACK IN THAT
COUNT.
HE CHALLENGED HIM, 2-0.
NICE PLAY BY MARCELL OZUNA GOING
INTO THE CORNER HERE.
SCOTT: ONE GONE, TOP OF THE
ORDER, IT'S TREA TURNER.
THAT'S YOUR SOTO AV OF THE DAY.
-- AB OF THE DAY.
TWO ON, DOWN A COUPLE RUNS,
THAT'S WHERE YOU WANTED HIM.
TREA IS HITLESS TODAY.
AND TAKES A STRIKE.
MARK: IT IS FUNNY, YOU THINK
BACK GOING TO BREAK, YOU KNOWS
SOTO IS THE BULLET THAT'S GOING
TO GET SPENT, KIND OF LEADS YOU
TO THINK ALONG WITH THE MANAGER,
YOU HAVE ALL THOSE LEFTIES.
I WAS SHOCKED LUKE JACKSON WAS
YOUR CALL.
SCOTT: THAT COULD BE TWO.
TREA BEATS IT OUT.
THE FORCE AT SECOND,AND
SCHWARBER''S TO THIRD.
THEY'RE ON THE CORNERS FOR
YADIEL HERNANDEZ.
MARK: AND I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
MUCH THAT MEANS TO WATCH NUMBER
SEVEN TREA TURNER GET DOWN THE
LINE.
WE ALL ASSUME HE'S GOING TO BEAT
OUT THE DOUBLE PLAY BUT YOU
STILL KEEP THE INNING ALIVE.
AND THIS IS A NICE MATCHUP FOR
MR. HERNANDEZ AGAINST LUKE
JACKSON.
SCOTT: SPRINT SPEED, BEST IN
BASEBALL, TIED WITH TIM LOCASTRO
OF THE DIAMONDBACKS.
WE REALLY GOTTA GET A
TAILOR-MADE DOUBLE PLAY BALL AND
BE PERFECT IN YOUR EXECUTION.
MARK: THAT'S 9.5 OUT OF 10 BIG
LEAGUERS ARE OUT.
SCOTT: IS HE'S ABOUT -- YOU KNOW
HE'S BOUNCED INTO FIVE DOUBLE
PLAYS THIS YEAR?
MARK: HE'S HITTING EVERYTHING ON
THE SCREWS.
SCOTT: THAT'S TRUE.
IT HAS TO BE A ROCKET TO SHORE
OR SECOND.
-- SHORT OR SECOND.
HERNANDEZ HAD THE SINGLE IN THE
THIRD.
2-0 FROM JACKSON.
MARK: SMOOTH PITCH RIGHT THERE.
OVER 16 E-2, YOU -- 162, YOU'VE
GOT TO GET AWAY WITH SITUATIONS
LIKE THIS.
THERE'S A LEFT-HANDER IN NO
MATTER WHAT IN THE SITUATION.
SCOTT: HERNANDEZ ON THE GROUND,
RIGHT SIDE FOR ALBIES.
MARK: GREAT JOB FOR LUKE
JACKSON.
SCOTT: HE WIGGLES OUT.
FIRST TWO REACH FOR THE
NATIONALS, NOTHING TO SHOW FOR A
LITTLE BIT OF TRAFFIC.
HIS TEAM'S UP TWO AFTER SEVEN.
♪
>> THE FASTBALL.
>> THE FASTBALL?
>> WAS RIGHT DOWN --
>> WAS RIGHT DOWN
>> THE PIPE.
>> PERFECT.
>> PUP --
>> PUMPKIN.
>> POPCORN.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> PUMPKIN?
>> I'M FROM TEXAS.
>> PUMPKIN.
PUMPKIN.
PUMP?
KIN.
>>POPPIN.
HEY, YO, WHAT'S POPPIN'?
>> PUMPKIN SPICE LATTE.
CAN'T READ.
PUMPKIN SPICE LATTE.
NOPE.
♪♪ NEXT ONE.
SCOTT: GO BEHIND THE SCENES.
WATCH EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEWS AND
LEARN MORE ABOUT PLAYERS AT THE
MOLINA BRAVES YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
GO TO YOUTUBE.COM -- ATLANTA
BRAVES YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
GO TO YOUTUBE.COM/BRAVES.
COVID-19 VACCINES ARE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE.
HELP US GET US ALL BACK DOING
WHAT WE LOVE TOGETHER.
VISIT MLB.COM/COVID19 RESOURCES
FOR MORE INFORMATION.
IN THE CHAT SECTION, SOMEONE
SAID IT SEEMS LIKE A DO OR DIE
INNING.
WE JUST SAW THEM WITH TWO ON
COULD NOT CONVERT.
TWO MORE CRACKS AT THE BRAVES
BULLPEN, BUT FIRST IT'S THE
BRAVES TRYING TO ADD SOME
INSURANCE AGAINST THE NEW MAN,
DANIEL HUDSON, 34 YEARS OLD,
KNOWN FOR BIG INNINGS IN 2019
FOR THE NATS, E.R.A. IN THE LOW
2.00'S.
FIRST, IT'S JEFF MATHIS SWINGING
AT 96.
MATHIS PLAYING TODAY, BUT
WILLIAM CONTRERAS IS NOW THE BIG
MAN BEHIND THE PLATE FOR THE
BRAVES.
HE'LL BE THE MAIN CATCHER UNTIL
TRAVIS D'ARNAUD COMES BACK.
CONTRERAS, 4-10 WITH A HOMER,
YOUNGER BROTHER OF WILLSON, WHO
PLACE FOR THE CUBS.
THERE'S THE UNDERHAND TOSS FOR
OUT NUMBER ONE.
MARK: I LIKE WILLIAM CONTRERAS.
AND LISTEN, THE REASON JEFF
MATHIS HAS BEEN ABLE TO STAY IN
THE GAME AS LONG AS HE HAS IS
BECAUSE HE HONORS THE PITCHING
STAFF FIRST, RIGHT ABOUT HIS
OFFENSE SECOND.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE GREAT
CATCHERS HAVE TO DO.
THEY HAVE TO GET THEIR PITCHING
STAFF -- BLOCKING BALLS IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN HITTING A THREE
RUN BOMB.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SEE IN ALL THE
REMARKS FOR THE BRAVES PITCHING
STAFF.
THEY SEEM TO REALLY LOVE
THROWING TO HIM.
SCOTT: THIS GUY HAS SOME
SWAGGER, TOO.
PANDA TIME.
PABLO SANDOVAL.
IN THE MONTH'S WORK WITH THE
BRAVES, HAS MADE A NAME FOR
HIMSELF.
4-14, THREE HOMERS.
YEAH, THERE'S SOME SWING AND
MISS, BUT THERE'S RUN REDUCTION.
MARK: HE'S SUCH A BETTER ATHLETE
THAN PEOPLE HAVE ANY CLUE.
I GET IT, HIS WEIGHT IS
CHRONICLED AND IT'S FLUCTUATED
BACK AND FORTH, UP AND DOWN.
HE'S AN ATHLETE.
THERE'S NOT MUCH PANDA CAN'T DO
ON THE BASEBALL FIELD.
THROWS WITH BOTH HANDS, CAN HIT
FROM BOTH SIDES, CAN PROBABLY GO
BEHIND THE DISH AND CATCH IF HE
WANTED TO.
SCOTT: NOT GOING TO CHEAT HIM
ON HIS HACKS.
GRABS HIS HELMET BACK.
THREE PINCH-HIT HOMERS, MOST BY
A BRACE PLAYER IN ANY CALENDAR
MONTH EVER.
HUDSON BRINGS THE 1-2.
MARK: TALKED ABOUT IT WITH
SNITKER TODAY, ABOUT BULLPEN
RULES.
I KNOW YOU WANT 26 HYBRIDS, GUYS
WHO CAN DO PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING.
BUT GUYS ARE CREATURES OF HABIT,
WOULD LIKE TO ASSIMILATE INTO
SOME TYPE OF ROLE.
SAME COULD BE SAID FOR THE
BENCH.
YOU GET A GUY LIKE ADRIANNE'S A,
GETTING A SPOT START -- THE
PANDA KNOWS EXACTLY IS GOING TO
GET THE TOUGHEST PINCH-HIT AT
BATS YEAR LONG.
SCOTT: CHARLIE CULBERSON HAD
SOME BIG AT-BATS FOR THE BRAVES.
MARK: BRAVES HAVE ALWAYS BEEN AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS STEADFAST
ON THEIR BACKUP INFIELDER BEING
ABLE TO PLAY SHORT AND THAT BE
HIS PRIMARY POSITION.
YOU SAW THAT WITH A DAINTY
TRIVIA, -- ADEINY HECHAVARRIA,
ALL THE WAY BACK TO RAFAEL
BELLIARD.
SCOTT: WISELY, DANIEL HUDSON
LETS PASSED HIS BAREHAND.
SANDOVAL GROUNDS OUT.
MARK: AND THEY HAVE ORLANDO
ARCIA SITTING AT THE ALTERNATE
SITE.
SCOTT: THAT'S TRUE.
THERE'S TURNER.
YEAH, ARCIA CUT LOOSE BY THE
BREWERS AND DEALT OVER TO
ATLANTA.
HE'S A FINE DEFENDER.
TWO GONE IN THE EIGHTH, BACK TO
ACUNA.
REMEMBER WE WERE HANGING OUT
WITH ACUNA AND ALBIES IN SPRING
TRAINING THREE OR FOUR YEARS
AGO, AND THEY WERE TRYING TO
MAKE THE BEAST A THING FOR HIS
NICKNAME?
I LIKE IT.
BUT I HAVEN'T HEARD IT.
MARK: NO, IT HAD NO LEGS.
SCOTT: WHY?
MARK: BECAUSE HE DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE A BEAST.
SCOTT: BUT HE PLAYS LIKE A
BEAST.
MARK: HE'S A SWAG HE BEAST.
-- SWAGGY BEAST.
SCOTT: YEAH.
THE GOAL BEAST.
MARK: HE JUST WAS PUT ON THIS
EARTH TO PLAY BASEBALL, TO MAKE
IT LOOK PRETTY.
SCOTT: I KNOW YOU TALKED ABOUT
THIS, TOO, HITTING COACH KEVIN
SEITZER SAYING THE BIGGEST
ADJUSTMENT IS HERE, HE WOULD
LOSE THE BARREL IN THE PAST,
LEADING TO SOME WHIFFS, DROPPING
DOWN, THE BALL NOT STAYING ON AN
EVEN PLANE.
RIGHT CENTER.
AND IT'S HERNANDEZ MAKING THE
CALL.
NICE AND EASY FOR DANIEL HUDSON
IN THE EIGHTH.
BACK TO THE, IN THE
BOTTOM OF THE FRAME, DOWN BY TWO
RUSN NICE DATE -- RUNS, NICE
DAY FOR THE MEN ON THE
MOUND, BRAVES GOING FOR THE
SWEEP.
>> BOOKCLUB IS SOMETHING I
STARTED LAST YEAR, A COUPLE
TITLES AM EXCITED FOR.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET AS MANY
PEOPLE INVOLVED AS POSSIBLE.
THE GIRLS IN MY LIFE, THEY ARE
ALWAYS READING.
THEY FINALLY GOT ME TO SIT DOWN
AND READ A LITTLE BIT, STARTING
TO AWESOME AS A HOBBY OF MINE
THE LAST FEW YEARS.
FOR THE TITLES OF THE BOOK CLUB,
THEY ARE MORE BASED AROUND BOOKS
I WISH I READ EARLIER, BOOKS I
READ, MAN, I COULD'VE USED THIS
FOR FIVE YEARS AGO.
I THINK EVERYBODY IS GOING TO
GET SOMETHING OUT OF IT.
FOR ME, THIS YEAR, I THINK
DIVING INSIDE US AS PEOPLE,
EVERYBODY HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GROW.
EVERYBODY SHOULD GO 1-0
EVERYDAY.
HOPEFULLY THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO DO THAT.
I WANT THIS TO BE AS INCLUSIVE
AS POSSIBLE.
ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO LOG ONTO
THE WEBINAR, ASK SOME QUESTIONS,
THIS IS WHAT THE BOOK CLUB IS
FOR.
I'M GOING TO BE READING, AS
WELL.
LET'S DO IT.
>> EVERY FAN WANTS TO LEAVE THE
BALLPARK WITH A BIT OF A
SOUVENIR AND JOSH HARRISON MADE
IT HAPPEN FOR A YOUNG FAN.
PLEASE THROW ME A BALL!
JOSH HARRISON WAS TRYING BUT
THEY COULDN'T CONNECT.
JOSH HARRISON MAJOR THERE WAS A
BALL FOR THAT YOUNG FAN.
JOSH HARRISON ONE OUT AND
SIGNED.
HE DEFINITELY HAS A SOUVENIR,
AND I GUESS A JOSH HARRISON FAN
FOR LIFE.
SCOTT: THANKS FOR THE PHOTO,
TOO.
THAT'S A GREAT HANDOFF.
HE'S DOING IT ALL THIS WEEK.
THAT WAS RELEVANT FOR HIS
NICKNAME IN PITTSBURGH.
THEY CALLED HIM MICROWAVE.
MARK: THAT'S A GOOD NICKNAME.
SCOTT: ALSO UNDERRATED.
MARK: DETROIT PISTONS.
SCOTT: SANTANA, 29 YEARS OLD.
MARK: WHY NOTICE ABOUT JOSH
HARRISON, HIS TOP HAND AND
BOTTOM HAND ARE ACTUALLY
DISCONNECTED WHEN HE'S HOLDING
THE BAT.
THERE'S A LITTLE HALF-INCH
SPACE, ALMOST FORCING HIMSELF,
THROW THAT TOP AND TO THE
BASEBALL.
-- TOP HAND TO THE BASEBALL.
SCOTT: THAT MITT WOULD BOTHER ME
ON THE LEFT-HAND, NO?
DID YOU HAVE BATTING GLOVES LIKE
THAT?
MARK: HE'S OBSOLETE BEEN DRILLED
ON THE HAND A TON.
-- OBVIOUSLY BEEN DRILLED ON THE
HAND A TON.
SCOTT: PACHE WILL WATCH IT OFF
THE WALL.
AND HARRISON WILL SLIDE INTO
SECOND WITH A LEADOFF DOUBLE.
IF IT WENT JUST A SHADE LEFT, IT
WAS GONE.
BUT HIGH PART OF THE WALL FOR
HARRISON AND HE'S GOT TWO BAGS.
I'M SURE HE'S GOING, REALLY?
MARK: THE LITTLE TWO-SEAM
FASTBALL COMING BACK OVER THE
HEART OF THE PLATE, DRIVES IT UP
THE MIDDLE THE OTHER WAY.
LIKE YOU SAID, A FOOT LEFT AND
IT'S A HOME RUN.
SCOTT: ANOTHER FOOT VERTICALLY
AND IT'S A HOMER, TOO.
STARLIN CASTRO, DOUBLE NUMBER
FOUR ON THE YEAR.
HARRISON SWINGING THE BAT WELL,
TWO HITS TODAY.
CASTRO HAS REACHED BASE TWO OUT
OF THREE TIMES THIS AFTERNOON.
FOUR TIME ALL-STAR AT THE PLATE.
EDGAR SANTANA JUST MADE HIS
BRAVES DEBUT ON FRIDAY,
RELIEVING DREW SMYLY.
AND SMYLY WATCHING HIM VERY
CAREFULLY AGAIN TODAY.
MARK: GOT TO GET BACK IN THE
COUNT RIGHT HERE.
IS GOING TO TAKE ONE OR TWO TO
FORCE THIS YOUNG RIGHT-HANDER TO
GET BACK IN THE COUNT, MAYBE
PUTTING MORE PRESSURE ON HIM.
SCOTT: MINTER AND MATZEK HAVE
PITCHED EACH OF THE LAST TWO
GAMES, STILL EARLY IN THE
SEASON, COMING OFF AN
ABBREVIATED CAMPAIGN IN 2020.
I'M SURE AS A BRAVES FAN,, WEARS
MATZEK?
-- WHERE'S MATZEK?
MARK: WHERE ARE WE GOING?
THIS IS THE RIGHT MATCH UP.
STARLIN CASTRO NORTH OF 1600
HITS, LED THE N.L. IN 2011 WITH
207 HITS.
SCOTT: BALL FOUR, FOUR MISSES
FROM SANTANA.
SO, HARRISON WITH A NEAR DOUBLE
-- NEAR HOMER.
INSTEAD, IT'S A DOUBLE.
ALMOST HAD IT, MAN.
>> WRONG PART OF THE PARK.
I AIN'T GOT NO POP.
THAT'S GONE PROBABLY LIKE 17
OTHER PARKS.
I'LL TELL YOU WHERE IT'S NOT
GONE, DETROIT.
SCOTT: THERE IS A STAT YOU CAN
LOOK UP TO SEE HOW MANY PARKS IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN GONE.
I'LL GET YOU THAT.
FOUR.
NO, WAIT, IT'S GONE IN FOUR?
MARK: ONLY A HOME RUN IN FOUR?
SCOTT: HANGING UP FOR A WHILE.
OZUNA PUTS IT AWAY.
TAG UP, AND HE'S THERE,
HARRISON TO THIRD.
HE'S NO HOME RUN HITTER, BUT
HE'S GOT SPEED, JUST ONE OUT.
MARK: THERE IS A SITUATION.
YOU DON'T WANT TO TAKE THE BAT
OUT OF JOSH BELL'S HANDS.
HE JUST WATCHED HIM WALK STARLIN
CASTRO ON FOUR PITCHES.
YOU'RE SCUFFLING.
HE'S SCUFFLING TO FIND THE ZONE.
TAKE A PITCH?
I DON'T KNOW IF I WOULD
NECESSARILY TAKE A PITCH.
YOUR HELMET FALLING OFF IF YOU
SWING AT THE FIRST ONE.
SCOTT: YAN GOMES 0-3.
IN ON THE HANDS AND THAT'S FOUL.
WATCH EXCLUSIVE CONTENT ON THE
WASHINGTON NATIONALS YOUTUBE
CHANNEL.
HEAD TO YOUTUBE.COM/NATIONALS
AND FOLLOW THE NATS TODAY.
HARRISON DOUBLE, CASTRO WALK.
BELL FLEW OUT TO LEFT.
SINKER.
MARK: THAT'S NASTY.
YOU CAN'T LET THE BRAVES GET OFF
THE HOOK WITH LUKE JACKSON, MR.
SANTANA, BACK-TO-BACK INNINGS.
HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO SCRATCH
ACROSS SOME
I KNOW HE'S DOWN 0-2.
SCOTT: SANTANA WITH THE SCORE
THE SIXTH INNING LAST NIGHT.
ONE WALK, 15 PITCHES.
GOMES OUT TO RIGHT CENTER AND
HE'S IN BUSINESS.
AND THE NATS CUT THIS TO A ONE
RUN GAME.
HARRISON TROTS HOME.
IT'S 3-2.
THAT'S GOING TO DO IT FOR
SANTANA.
YAN GOMES CONNECTS.
MARK: 0-2, GREAT SLIDER.
JUST A NICE PIECE OF HITTING BY
YAN GOMES.
BAT HEAD TO THE BASEBALL RIGHT
THERE, PUSHING IT THE OTHER WAY.
SCOTT: GETTING THE JOB DONE,
CASTROE OUT OF THE
GAME AND LEAD US TO GRANT DAYTON
COMING OUT OF THE BULLPEN.
THERE YOUR LEFTY FOR ATLANTA,
NEXT.
>> OH, HANG ONTO THE ROOF!
>> THIS ONE IS --
>> OUTTA HERE!
>> NOW, LET'S SEE THE BIG FELLA
RUN.
HIGH FLY BALL, CENTER FIELD.
THAT BALL IS WAY OUT OF HERE!
>> THAT BALL IS ABSOLUTELY
HAMMERED.
YOU CALLED IT.
♪
>> APRIL 17, 481 FEET FOR ACUNA.
>> LEVEL WAS HAMMERED.
-- THAT ALL WAS HAMMERED.
♪
SCOTT: GOOGLE CLOUD IS HELPING
TO POWER STATCAST WITH MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF DATA POINTS TO REVEAL
NEW INSIGHTS TAKING YOU DEEPER
INTO THE GAME THAN EVER BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
STATCAST, POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
WITH TWO HOME RUNS THIS IS AN
FROM KYLE SCHWARBER, AND A
COMMON THEME -- BOTH BOMBS, 450
PLUS, BOTH WALKOFF SHOTS FOR THE
NATS.
IT'S QUALITY OVER QUANTITY RIGHT
NOW, DERO.
HE CAN REALLY SMASH THE BASEBALL
A LONG WAY.
SCENE THAT FOR YEARS, DOWN 2020.
2019 WAS A CAREER YEAR, 32
HOMERS.
HE WAS GOING FOR THERE.
.
BREAKING PITCH FROM GRANT
DAYTON.
MARK: HE'S ONE OF THE GUYS AT
LOOK AT, KIND OF THE ENIGMA IN
THE BOX BECAUSE HE DOES SO MANY
THINGS FUNDAMENTALLY RIGHT.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE'S GOT LONG
ARMS.
HE'S SHORT AND QUICK TO THE
BASEBALL.
WHAT HE DID IN 2016 TO COME BACK
FROM THE BLOWN OUT KNEE AND BE
RELEVANT, HAVE RELEVANT A.B.'S
IN THE WORLD SERIES WAS
LEGENDARY.
DON'T SEE MUCH SLUMP IN HIS
GAME.
SCOTT: HIT .412 IN THE WORLD
SERIES IN 2016, THREE HITS IN
GAME SEVEN.
MARK: HE WAS HAVING A.B.'S
AGAINST ANDREW MILLER AT THE
HEIGHT OF ANDREW MILLER, LEFT ON
LEFT.
SCOTT: CUBS WIPING AWAY A 108 YE
AR CHAMPIONSHIP DROUGHT, AND
SCHWARBER WAS A BIG PART OF IT.
DAYTON'S AHEAD 0-2, AND HE PUTS
HIM AWAY.
THEY PITCH FROM GRANT DAYTON.
MARK: THREE GREAT CURVEBALLS,
BACK TO BACK TO BACK.
JUST PRESENT THEMSELVES RIGHT
OVER THE HEART OF THE PLATE,
ENTICE.
LOOK AT THAT.
LOOK AT THE DEPTH ON THAT THING.
HE RECOGNIZES IT, JUST GOT TOO
MUCH SPIN.
SCOTT: BIG SECOND OUT.
NUMBER EIGHT HITTER, VICTOR
ROBLES.
MARK: WANT TO BE PLAYER OF THE
GAME, VICTOR?
SCOTT: NOW'S YOUR CHANCE.
HAD A SHOT YESTERDAY.
KEEP THIS THING GOING FOR RYAN
ZIMMERMAN, WHO LOVES LEFT HANDED
PITCHING.
DAYTON'S FACING ZIMMERMAN IF
ROBLES CAN KEEP IT GOING.
A WALK, A SINGLE, AND A FLY OUT
FOR ROBLES THIS AFTERNOON.
CASTRO AND GOMES, ONE RUN IN FOR
THE ASTROS IN THE EIGHTH.
DAYTON THIS TIME GOING FOR THE
HEATER.
DROP THE 12-6?
MARK: LET'S BRUSH HIM UPSTAIRS
FIRST.
SCOTT: OK.
JEFF MATHIS SETS UP HIGH.
GOOD CALL.
MARK: I DIDN'T LIKE THAT.
GO BACK UP THERE AGAIN.
THAT WAS TOO NONCOMPETITIVE,
GRANT.
GET RIGHT BACK UP THERE AGAIN.
YOU'LL GET A FISH.
IF NOT, THEN YOU GO TO THE
BREAKING BALL.
SCOTT: BRAVES WITH A THREE RUN
FOURTH.
JOSH HARRISON, THE LEADOFF
DOUBLE.
NOW VICTOR ROBLES DOES NOT GO
AFTER THAT ONE.
MARK: YOU SAW, TO.
YOU SEE THE TAKE?
KIND OF A JUAN SOTO TAKE.
HE DID THE SHIMMY ON THAT ONE.
SCOTT: HE'S TRYING TO BE MORE
LIKE JUAN SOTO.
ROBLES MORE PATIENT THIS SEASON.
A 2-2.
MARK: GOOD TAKE.
SCOTT: HE HAS WIDENED HIS STANCE
WITH TWO STRIKES THIS SEASON,
JUST AS JUAN SOTO DOES.
TAKE ONE FOR ZIMMERMAN OR IS IT
IN THE ZONE?
IT'S IN THERE AND HE FOULED OFF.
MARK: HUGE HACK RIGHT THERE.
DAYTON'S NOT FOOLING ANYBODY,
GOING HIGH HEATER OR BREAKING
BALL.
GOT TO THROW THE HEATER FOR A
STRIKE, ZIMMERMAN ON DECK.
SCOTT: I'M THROWING IT -- MARK:
I'M THROWING IT BELOW THE ZONE,
SEE IF HE BITES.
?!
WHAT?!
SCOTT: HE SAYS IT'S IN THERE AND
VICTOR ROBLES IS DOWN ON
STRIKES.
I MEAN, THAT IS A PRO TAKE RIGHT
THERE.
MARK: YOU HAVE TO GET EJECTED
RIGHT THERE.
THAT'S WHAT HAS TO HAPPEN.
SCOTT: MIGHT GET KICKED OUT.
MARK: THAT'S PART OF IT.
SCOTT: THAT'S THE PITCH WE'LL
LOOK BACK ON.
MARK: HE KNOWS HE MISSED IT.
HE KNOWS.
SCOTT: THAT WOULD'VE LOADED UP
THE BASES FOR MR. NATIONAL, RYAN
ZIMMERMAN.
WOW.
GRANT DAYTON TRIED TO GET VICTOR
ROBLES TO CHASE.
MARK: OH, NO. THAT PITCH, A BIT
DOWNSTAIRS.
ONE RUN FOR THE NATS IN THE
EIGHTH, ONE RUN GAME.
>> OH, MY LORD!
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF.
>> THIS ONE IS --
>> OUTTA HERE!
♪
>> THERE IT GOES!
GAME-WINNER!
SEE YOU LATER!
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
112 MILES PER HOUR, 463 FEET.
KYLE SCHWARBER FINALLY GOT ONE.
>> SCHWARBER, OUT TO RIGHT
CENTER, THAT BALL IS TO THE
MOMENT!
TWO HOME RUNS ON THE SEASON, AND
BOTH OF THEM HAVE BEEN WALKOFFS.
>> THAT'S WHY HE DOESN'T BUNT.
>> NOT WITH THIS GUY.
>> 1-2, TWO OUT, NOBODY ON, TOP
OF THE NIGHT.
SCHERZER'S INTO THE WIND UP.
THE KICK AND THE 1-2 PITCH.
HE STRUCK HIM OUT!
THE NINTH STRIKEOUT OF THE
AFTERNOON, COMPLETE GAME
VICTORY, 12TH OF HIS CAREER, AND
THE NATIONALS OUT OF THE DUGOUT
TO CONGRATULATE MAX SCHERZER.
SCOTT: WE'VE REACHED THE NINTH
AND WE'RE STILL THINKING ABOUT
THAT PITCH THAT ENDED THE
EIGHTH, VICTOR ROBLES.
THEY SCORED ONE IN THE EIGHTH.
BRAD HAND IN THE NINTH RIGHT NOW
FOR THE NATS.
I MEAN, CREDIT TO THE
ADVANCEMENT OF VICTOR ROBLES AS
A HITTER WITH HIS PITCH
RECOGNITION, BUT YOU DON'T GET
REWARDED ON THAT.
A WALK WOULD HAVE LOADED UP THE
BASES FOR RYAN ZIMMERMAN.
THAT ONE IS SKIED BY ALBIES,
JOSH BELL AND FOULED GROUNDS.
THERE'S ONE.
MARK: LISTEN, THE UMPIRES BEHIND
HOME PLATE ARE DOING THE BEST
THEY CAN.
THEREIN LIES THE FRUSTRATION.
GRINDING SO HARD AT THE PLATE,
HUGE SPOT IN THE GAME, A CHANCE
TO BE THE HERO, WHATEVER.
SEEING THE BALL, TAKE GRANT
DAYTON FULL, HAVE THE AT-BAT
RIPPED FROM YOU, THAT STUFF.
HE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE THAT
BOTHERED.
SCOTT: MANI AFTER THE GAME,
PEDI?
HERE IT IS.
THE BOX IS GOING TO CATCH THAT
PITCH NOT WHERE IT LANDS, BUT
WHERE IT COMES ACROSS.
MARK: THAT BALL'S DOWN.
IT'S NOT EVEN CLOSE, ACTUALLY.
SCOTT: WHERE YOU GOING TO DO?
-- WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
GOT A NAIL HANGING.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
GREAT PRESENTATION BEHIND THE
PLATE.
MARK: YOU SAW HIM GET SCHWARBER
EARLIER IN THE INNING ON THREE
STRAIGHT CURVEBALLS THAT WERE
OUT OF THE ZONE, VERY SIMILAR
PITCHES, SO OBVIOUSLY IT'S
SHOWING ITSELF TO BE A STRIKE
FOR 59.5 FEET.
SCOTT: OZUNA DOUBLED AND SCORED
IN THE FOURTH.
SWING HE WANTS BACK.
OVER TO FIRST TO COMPLETE THE K.
SWINGING THROUGH THE WATER
THERE.
SINCE THE FOURTH, THEY SCORED
THREE.
MARK: GREAT SLIDE INTO HOME.
SCOTT: BRAD HAND.
GOING BACK TO LAST YEAR, 16-16
IN SAVES FOR 2020, 2.05 E.R.A.
THAT SLIDER'S WHAT HE'S KNOWN
FOR.
MARK: FUNKY, HIS HEAD FLIES OUT,
KIND OF DECEPTIVE, SHORT LEG
KICK, KIND OF SHOULDERS,
EVERYTHING COMING AT YOU AT
ONCE, ABILITY TO SPIN THE BALL
DIFFERENT WAYS.
HE SWINGING THE BAT GOOD.
I KNOW HE'S BEEN STRUGGLING.
HE JUST SWUNG AT ONE THAT
BOUNCED KIND OF UNDER HIS BACK
FOOT.
SCOTT: HAND HAD AN OPTION LAST
YEAR THAT WAS DECLINED BY
CLEVELAND.
IT TOOK A WHILE FOR HIM TO FIND
A HOME.
SIGNED FOR 10 BY $5 MILLION WITH
WASHINGTON.
THEY HAVE THEIR -- $10.5 MILLION
WITH WASHINGTON.
THEY HAVE THEIR NINTH INNING
MAN.
MARK: THEY HAVE GOOD OPTIONS
WITH DANIEL HUDSON.
YOU'VE GOT HIM, BRAD HAND,
TANNER RAINEY COMING IN.
YOU'VE GOT WEAPONS -- WILL
SMITH, I GET IT.
HE IS YOUR CLOSER.
I THINK IF WE'RE IN THE TRUST
TREAT, HE WOULD LIKE TO BE 8 --
TRUST TREE, HE WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO USE HIM HIGH LEVERAGE.
SCOTT: RILEY, CHOPPER FOR
HARRISON.
PLATED WELL ON THAT HOP.
-- PLAYED IT WELL ON THAT HOP.
LAST >> FOR THE NATIONALS.
-- LAST LICKS FOR THE NATIONALS.
THEY NEED A RUN TO KEEP THIS
GOING.
>> HE WANTS TO KNOW HOW YOU WILL
GET INVOLVED IN THE NETS
COMMUNITY.
>> I DO HAVE MY OWN CHARITY.
WE SERVE POLICE, FIRE, AND
MILITARY.
IT GOT ME REALLY EXCITED TO GO
INTO THE COMMUNITY.
THAT WAS DEFINITELY ONE OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF MY CAREER SO FAR
IS --
>> THAT STILL MAY BE THE BEST
HOME RUN DERBY THEY'VE EVER HAD.
>> IT WAS DEFINITELY A FUN SHOW
TO BE AT.
>> THE CROWD IS REALLY GETTING
INTO IT.
THESE NETS FANS LOVE KYLE
SCHWARBER RIGHT NOW.
>> THEY WANT TO KNOW HOW YOU'RE
DUGOUT DANCE IS.
>> WHEN I WAS IN CHICAGO, THEY
BLOW IT UP A LITTLE.
I WAS IN SHOW CHOIR.
ANY KIND OF DANCING IS GOOD FOR
ME, SO I'M READY FOR IT.
SCOTT: GOOD ONE TODAY IN D.C.,
ONE RUN AFFAIR, BOTTOM NINE,
NETS WITH NINE, ONE, AND TWO DUE
UP IN THEIR ORDER.
WILL SMITH TIME, SIXTH SAVE OF
THE SEASON LAST NIGHT FOR
ATLANTA, GRAB THE FIRST TWO
GAMES OF THE SERIES.
THEY'VE TAKEN FOUR OF FIVE FROM
THE NATS, ALL IN D.C., SO FAR
THIS YEAR.
A LEFTY, JUST THE WAY RYAN
ZIMMERMAN LIKES IT.
HAVING A REALLY GOOD YEAR SO
FAR, SWINGING THE BAT WELL AND
SPRING TRAINING, CARRIES IT OVER
IN 2021.
MARK: HE'S BEEN CRAFTY AT THE
DISH, NO DOUBT.
RYAN HAS A LOT OF MOVING PARTS,
BIG LEG KICK.
WITH HIS TIMING -- WHEN HIS
TIMING IS RIGHT, ONE OF THE
BETTER HITTERS.
WATCHED AND THE OTHER DAY
AGAINST THE MARLINS FACING
TREVOR ROGERS, BIG-TIME PROBLEMS
TO THE LEFT SIDE.
GOT HIM DOWN 0-2 AND TRIED TO
SNEAK A HEATER IN.
RYAN TOOK A THREE RUN BOMB TO
DEAD CENTER, THE BIGGEST BLOW IN
THE GAME.
HE WANTS THAT ONE BACK.
SCOTT: YEAH.
MARK: JUST SETTING, FOR IT
LATER.
-- SETTING HIM UP FOR IT LATER.
SCOTT: SOME DO.
NOT MANY.
MARK: JIM EDMONDS IS THE ONLY
ONE THAT WOULD TELL ME ON-DECK
AM GOING TO SWING AT A CURVEBALL
IN THE DIRT, LOOK LIKE I'M FULL,
I'LL GET IT AGAIN AND TAKEN
DEEP.
SCOTT: THAT'S AWESOME.
ZIMMERMAN RIPS ONE TO LEFT FIELD
AND HE'S GOT EXTRA BASES.
RYAN ZIMMERMAN WITH A PINCH-HIT
DOUBLE TO START OFF THE LAST OF
THE NINTH.
MARK: PERFECT DAY.
NOW YOU PINCH RUN.
HE HITS THE SHOWERS.
SCOTT: THAT SLIDER CATCHES A LOT
OF THE PLATE AND ZIMMERMAN IS
ALL OVER IT.
HE HITS THE BALL HARD.
THERE IT IS.
HAVE A GOOD ONE, RYAN.
ANDREW STEVENSON'S GOT A FEW
MORE FEET ON YOU WITH THE SPRINT
SPEED.
MARK: COMING INTO THE DUGOUT,
THAT'S HOW IT'S DONE, BOYS.
SCOTT: COULD HAVE BEEN HIM IN
THE EIGHTH AFTER ROBLES WAS
CALLED ON STRIKES.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN ZIMMERMAN
WITH THE BAGS FULL OF GNATS.
ZIMMERMAN OUT, STEPHENSON INCOME
A TURNER UP, TAKING A STRIKE.
NATS ARE TWO GAMES UNDER .500.
BRAVES ARE TWO GAMES BELOW .500.
N.L. EAST HAS TALENT BUT NO TEAM
HAS SEPARATED ITSELF YET.
MARK: AND I KNOW THIS PEOPLE AT
HOME RIGHT NOW, SCREAMING AT THE
TV, SAYING TREA TURNER HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT SOMETHING
DOWN THE FIRST-BASE LINE.
YOU HAVE TO TRUST IN THE FACT
THAT HE'S ABLE TO DO IT SWINGING
THE BAT, MOVE THE RUNNER, MAYBE
GAP ONE AND TIE IT UP.
SCOTT: AND HE GOES TO RIGHT.
MARK: NICE PIECE OF HITTING.
SCOTT: ACUNA IS THERE AND
STEPHENSON IS GOING TO TAG.
THAT'S WHAT YOU NEED TO DO.
MARK: ABSOLUTELY.
SCOTT: NOW A FLY DEEP ENOUGH
FROM HERNANDEZ WOULD BRING UP A
RUN THAT WOULD TIE THIS GAME UP.
I VOUCH FOR TREA TURNER IN THE
DUGOUT.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST AT-BATS OF
HIS LIFE RIGHT NOW, YADIEL
HERNANDEZ.
33 YEARS OLD.
BIG-TIME NUMBERS.
SMITH FULL'S HIM FOR STRIKE ONE.
HARRISON IS ON DECK.
TWO HITS TODAY FOR JOSH.
MARK: THAT'S THE BEAUTY OF WILL
SMITH, YOU KNOW HE'S GOING TO
BURY THE SLIDER RIGHT NOW, JEFF
MATHIS NEW ADDITION TO THE
BRAVES.
WILLING TO BURY IT, KNOWING NO
BALLS GETTING BACK.
SCOTT: WILL SMITH OUT OF
GEORGIA, ATLANTA AREA.
GREW UP WATCHING THE BRAVES.
31-YEAR-OLD LEFTY, MISSED IN.
THIS IS THE SAC FLY LINE, WHERE
YOU NEED TO GO.
PAST THE GREENLINE SHOULD SCORE
THE RUN.
OZUNA, SINCE THE SHOULDER
INJURY, HE'S NOT THE SAME.
THE BRAVES WILL TELL YOU.
MARK: IT'S NOT EVEN CLOSE.
IT'S LIKE THEY WENT TO ST.
LOUIS, NEVER GOT RIGHT.
SCOTT: HE HANDED THE BALL OFF TO
AN OUTFIELDER TO MAKE THE THROW,
SOMEONE CLOSE BY.
MARK: HERE COMES YOUR POWER
SLIDER RIGHT HERE.
SCOTT: 42% SLIDERS FROM SMITH.
SEE IF HE GOES.
AND HE GOT HIM.
BIG PITCH FROM WILL SMITH TO
RETIRE YADIEL HERNANDEZ.
MARK: IT'S CRAZY.
THIS ISN'T EVEN ONE OF HIS GOOD
ONES RIGHT HERE.
YOU CAN ALMOST TELL MR.
HERNANDEZ, WHO WAS THROWING THAT
PITCH RIGHT THERE.
BATTERS ARE 0-18 WITH 13
PUNCH-OUTS VERSUS THE SLIDER
THIS SEASON.
SCOTT: THAT'S WHY HE SIGNED UP
FOR THE BIG BOX, THREE YEARS,
$40 MILLION.
SIGNED NOVEMBER OF 2019.
JOSH HARRISON WITH A CHANCE HERE
AGAIN SMITH.
GOT TO GIVE SOME CREDIT TO JEFF
MATHIS, MAKING SOME BIG STOPS.
MARK: TAKE FOUR DAYS OFF TO GET
BACK IN THERE NEXT TIME.
DREW'S BACK ON THE MOUND.
SCOTT: EVERY BALL IS DRIBBLING
AWAY.
A LOT OF MOVEMENT FROM WILL
SMITH.
THERE'S THE LINE FOR HARRISON,
1-6 AGAINST THE BRAVES LEFTY.
STEVENSON AT THIRD, NATS DOWN A
RUN.
AND HARRISON CONNECTS TO RIGHT.
AND ACUNA IS THERE, GAME OVER.
THE BRAVES SWEEP THE
NATIONALS AND UP THEIR RECORD.
AND IT'S THE FIRST TIME THEY WIN
A GAME WITH DREW SMYLY ON THE
MOUND, AND HE WAS SENSATIONAL.
OZUNA WITH A BIG SLIDE THAT
ENDED UP BEING THE DIFFERENCE.
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME,
OZUNA, SMYLY, ADRIANZA, OR LUKE
JACKSON.
HELP US OUT.
MARK: I'M LEANING DREW SMYLY
RIGHT NOW.
SCOTT: AND WE'LL FIND OUT AS WE
HAVE HIT POSTGAME TIME RIGHT
HERE ON YOUTUBE.
♪
SCOTT: IT IS THE POSTGAME SHOW,
PRESENTED BY GLOBAL CITIZEN OF
VAX.
SCOTT BRAUN, MARK DEROSA, AND
SAVANNAH MCCANN.
A GOOD ONE BETWEEN THE NATIONALS
AND THE BRAVES.
BRAVES WIN BY A RUN.
ADRIANZA KNOCKED IN TWO.
ATLANTA SWEEPS THE WASHINGTON
NATIONALS.
THEY'VE WRAPPED FIVE OF SIX
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
RESULTS COMING SOON RIGHT HERE.
SO, IF YOU'RE ATLANTA, YOU'VE
BEEN THROUGH UPS AND DOWNS, THEY
HAD A TOUGH SEASON IN DUNEDIN
AGAINST THE TORONTO BLUE JAYS,
INCLUDING A LOSS FOR SMYLY.
MARK: THEY HAVE TO FEEL GOOD,
THE TWO LEFT-HANDERS, MAX FRIED
SHOWING OUT YESTERDAY, AND DREW
SMYLY, WHO HOPEFULLY WE'RE GOING
TO GET A CHANCE TO TALK TO.
SIX INNINGS OF WORK, FOUR
PUNCH-OUTS -- FREDDY GOT A DAY
OFF HIS FEET.
THEY WON A BALLGAME.
EVERYBODY TAKE A DEEP BREATH AND
ATLANTA.
SCOTT: FIRST WIN FOR DREW SMYLY
SINCE SEPTEMBER OF 2019.
WE'RE WITH YOU.
AND WE DID NOT PLAN THE ATTIRE
LIKE THIS.
WE HAVE THE SAME DESIGNS HERE.
WARDROBE, THEY HOOK US UP HERE.
WE'RE LIVE WITH YOU FOR THE NEXT
30, SCOTT BRAUN, MARK DEROSA.
IT WAS GOOD, EXCELLENT DEFENSIVE
PLAYS IN CENTERVILLE, REALLY
TIGHT -- CENTER FIELD, REALLY
TIGHT PITCHES.
THE WAY THAT THE BALL SPINS AND
THE VELOCITY COMING AT YOU, NATS
FANS ARE GOING TO THINK ABOUT
THE PITCH THAT WAS CALLED FOR
STRIKE THREE TO VICTOR ROBLES.
MARK: THEY SHOULD THINK ABOUT IT
AND I'M GETTING A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN MY MENTIONS TELLING THE
AUSTIN RILEY'S STRIKE THREE WAS
THE SAME EXACT PITCH.
I COMPLETELY DISAGREE WITH THAT.
TOUGH SPOT.
IT WAS A BREAKING BALL AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE ZONE THAT GRANT
DAYTON STRUCK OUT AND DOUBLED
DOWN AGAINST ROBLES, EXECUTED A
PITCH.
NICE, CLEAN, TIE BALLGAME.
BOTH LEFTIES THREW THE BALL
GREAT.
I THOUGHT LESTER WAS GREAT FOR
THE NATS.
DREW SMYLY, HIM AND MAX FRIED,
THAT HAS TO COME DOWN THE
ROTATION A LITTLE BIT.
SCOTT: DREW SMYLY WAS THE BIG
SIGNING IN THE OFF-SEASON, ALONG
WITH CHARLIE MARTIN.
THE BRAVES ALWAYS DO THIS.
I DON'T HAVE A PLAN B.
THEY ARE REGRESSIVE AFTER THE
FREE AGENTS THAT THEY WANT TO
SIGN AND THEN THEY COME THROUGH
-- PROGRESSIVE -- AGGRESSIVE
AFTER THE FREE AGENTS THAT THEY
WANT TO SIGN AND THEN THEY COME
THROUGH.
MARK: I THINK IT'S INTERESTING
TO WATCH THEM.
THEY TRUST A LOT OF THEIR
HOMEGROWN TALENT, RIGHTFULLY SO.
AND THEN THEY KIND OF NICKEL AND
DIME WITH THE ONE YEAR DEALS,
LIKE YOU SAID, DONALDSON, OZUNA,
HAMELS, DREW SMYLY.
THE FOUR FOR $63 MILLION THAT
WAS WHEN I GOT, THAT WAS
STEPPING OUT FOR THEM.
WHO WITH A BIDDING AGAINST?
IT SCREAMS MORE TO THE FACT OF
WHAT OZUNA MEANT TO THEIR TEAM
IN 2020, NOT ONLY HITTING BEHIND
FREDDIE WITH THE 18 HOMERS, BUT
HOW LOVED HE IS IN THE
CLUBHOUSE.
ALBIES, ACUNA, THAT LATIN
AMERICAN PERSUASION IN THAT
CLUBHOUSE IS SO HUGE.
THEY HAVE THE FREDDIE FREEMAN
AND THE OZUNA, PERFECT
COMBINATION OF LEADERSHIP.
SCOTT: HE BROUGHT SO MUCH FUN TO
THE TEAM LAST YEAR.
FOR NOW, PITCHERS HIT, AND THERE
IS NOT MUCH HITTING GOING ON FOR
A WHILE FOR THE NATIONALS
BECAUSE DREW SMYLY HAD IT GOING,
AND THE DEFENSE BEHIND HIM WAS
SOLID, AS WELL.
MARK: LOOK AT SWANSON.
SCOTT: COME DOWN TO TURN THE
DOUBLE PLAY.
DREW SMYLY PICKS UP THE W FOR
THE ATLANTA BRAVES.
JOINS US LIVE FOR A GLOBAL
AUDIENCE ON YOUTUBE RIGHT NOW.
THANKS FOR THE TIME.
HOW ARE YOU TODAY?
CONGRATS ON THE WIN.
DREW: GOOD, MAN.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
ANYTIME YOU CAN WIN A MAJOR
LEAGUE GAME FEELS PRETTY GOOD.
IT'S BEEN A ROUGH START TO THE
SEASON FOR ME, PERSONALLY, BUT
STILL A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE,
A LOT OF SEASON TO BE PLAYED.
SCOTT: THE POLL RESULTS JUST
CAME IN.
YOU ARE THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF
THE GAME, CUSTOM TROPHY, IT'S
GOING TO HAVE YOUR NAME ON IT.
WE DO THIS EVERY WEEK.
CAN YOU HOLD IT UP FOR US?
WHERE ARE YOU PUTTING THAT?
DREW: PRETTY COOL.
I'LL PUT IT RIGHT THERE THIS
MIGHT BE MY FIRST TROPHY, SO I'M
GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE A TROPHY
CASE.
SCOTT: IT'S NICE.
WE'LL HAVE IT DELIVERED WITH THE
ENGRAVING.
MARK: DID YOU TELL EVERYBODY,
CALM DOWN, RELAX?
WHAT WAS WORKING FOR YOU TODAY?
DREW: YOU KNOW, HONESTLY, IT WAS
A LITTLE BIT OF A GRIND TODAY.
I HAD GOODLIFE ON MY FASTBALL.
THAT WAS MY BEST PITCH.
THE PARABLE, ONE OF THE GAMES --
CURVEBALL, I HAD THAT GOING
EARLY.
I WAS YANKING IT DOWN FOR BALLS,
WASN'T REALLY BEING AGGRESSIVE
WITH IT.
AND THEN IN THE FINAL THIRD TIME
THROUGH THE LINEUP, FIFTH AND
SIXTH, IT REALLY STARTED
DROPPING IN FOR A STRIKE AND
BURYING IT WHEN I NEEDED TO.
THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN THE KEY FOR
ME IS DROP THE CURVEBALL EARLY
AND MAKE THEM CHASE AND HAVE
FASTBALL COMMAND.
THAT'S WHEN I MET MY BEST.
THIS SEASON, A FEW THINGS GOING
AGAINST MY GAME.
YOU KNOW HOW BASEBALL IS.
IT CAN SPIRAL ON YOU PRETTY
QUICK.
IT'S A REALLY LONG SEASON.
I KNOW I'M CAPABLE OF GETTING
THESE GUYS OUT EVERY FIVE DAYS.
ANYTIME YOU GET A WIN AND YOU
CAN HELP THE TEAM OUT AND
CELEBRATE WITH YOUR GUYS, IT'S A
GOOD FEELING.
MARK: YOU HAVE TO BE FIRED UP.
I WAS TELLING SCOTTY BRONK, I'VE
BEEN IN THE -- SCOTTY BRAUN,
I'VE BEEN IN THE BOX AGAINST
YOU.
YOU'RE HEATER, ARE YOU AWARE
OF THE LATE LIFE ON YOUR
FASTBALL?
DREW: ABSOLUTELY.
MY MINDSET EVERY GAME IS ATTACK,
MAKE THE HITTERS BE IN DEFENSE
MODE AND GO RIGHT AT THEM.
I DON'T WANT TO NIBBLE.
I'M PRONE TO GIVE UP A FEW FLY
BALLS HERE AND THERE WHEN THE
HITTERS RUN INTO IT, BUT THAT'S
OK.
THAT'S THE WAY THE LEAGUE IS
RIGHT NOW.
THE KEY IS TO NOT DO IT WHEN
GUYS ARE ON BASE AND GET AHEAD,
STAY AHEAD.
THAT'S MY MANTRA EVERY GAME,
KEEP THESE GUYS ON THEIR TOES
AND MIX IN THE CURVEBALL'S AND
CUTTERS FROM THERE.
SCOTT: WHAT WAS IT LIKE TO WORK
WITH JEFF MATHIS TODAY?
WAS THIS YOUR FIRST TIME IN A
REGULAR-SEASON GAME?
DREW: NO, ACTUALLY I WAS IN
TEXAS WITH HIM IN 2019.
I CALL HIM CAPTAIN.
HE'S BEEN AROUND FOR 14, 15
YEARS IN THE LEAGUE NOW.
HE KNOWS HOW TO CATCH.
HE KNOWS HOW TO WORK WITH WHAT
THE PITCHER HAS THAT DAY, THE
SCOUTING REPORTS OF THE HITTERS.
HE KNOWS HOW TO NAVIGATE THROUGH
THE LINEUP.
WHEN HE'S BACK THERE, YOU FEEL
COMFORTABLE.
MARK: WHAT IS IT LIKE WORKING
WITH THIS FRONT OFFICE, ATLANTA?
EARLY ON IN ALL SEASONS, THEY
HAVE A FEW PLAYERS THAT THEY
PICK AND THEY TARGET.
AND THEY OFTEN COME THROUGH WITH
JOSH DONALDSON AND MARCELL OZUNA
ON THE HITTING SIDE THIS YEAR.
IT WAS YOU AND CHARLIE MORTON.
WHAT DID THAT MEAN TO YOU, AND
THEY HAVE SOMETHING FOR YOU WHEN
YOU CAME TO THE TABLE?
DREW: I MEAN, IT JUST BRINGS
CONFIDENCE TO YOU.
WHEN THEY SEEK YOU OUT RIGHT
WHEN THE OFF-SEASON STARTS AND
SAY YOU'RE THEIR GUY, IT JUST
MAKES YOU FEEL GOOD.
A LOT OF THESE TEAMS SLOW PLAY
IT AND WAIT AROUND.
BRAVES SAID NO, YOU WHEN
CHARLIE, THOSE ARE THE GUYS WE
WANT.
CHARLIE, HIS CAREER'S BEEN
AMAZING.
HE GOT OFF TO A SEMI-SLOW START.
HE'S BEEN ONE OF THE BEST
PITCHERS IN THE LEAGUE.
THAT'S WHAT ALEX TOLD ME WHEN HE
SIGNED ME.
I BATTLED SOME INJURIES, BOUNCED
AROUND A FEW TIMES.
WHEN I'M AT BEST, I KNOW I CAN
GET THESE GUYS OUT.
FOR ME, IT'S THE CONSISTENCY,
CONTINUING TO WORK EVERY FIVE
DAYS, WORK ON THE CRAFT, THROW
STRIKES AND MIX SPEEDS.
IT SOUNDS EASY, BUT WHEN YOU GET
OUT THERE ON THE MOUND, YOU GUYS
KNOW IT'S HARDER THAN IT LOOKS.
MARK: YOU GUYS HAVE TO FEEL
RELAXED NOW.
YOU WATCHED MAX FRIED GO TO WORK
AND THEN YOU ON THE BACKEND.
IS THERE ANYTHING THE TWO OF YOU
CAN BOUNCE IDEAS OFF EACH OTHER,
SOMETHING YOU CAN GIVE HIM,
SOMETHING YOU TAKE FROM HIM?
DREW: FOR SURE.
FRIED'S A BULLDOG.
HE IS LASER FOCUSED.
WE'RE A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
PERSONALITIES.
I'M KIND OF LOOSE, JUST TRYING
TO HAVE A GOOD TIME.
FRIED'S EASY.
HE'S LOCKED IN, READY TO GO TO
WAR EVERY DAY.
EVEN IN THE BATTER'S BOX, HE'S
NOT TAKING A PITCH OFF.
I NEED A LITTLE OF THAT.
ALL OF US, WE'VE GOT A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP.
CHARLIE'S BEEN AROUND,.
DOING ITHE -- AROUND, DOING IT.
HE'S SEEN IT ALL
IAN ANDERSON, HE'S WAY BEYOND
HIS YEARS.
THE WHOLE STAFF, REALLY, YNOA,
WHAT CAN YOU SAY ABOUT THAT GUY?
HE'S A BEAST.
IT'S FUN.
EVERY DAY, YOU'RE WATCHING THESE
GUYS PLAY.
IT'S NICE TO GET IN THE WINNING
CIRCLE WITH THESE GUYS.
SCOTT: CONGRATULATIONS ON THE W
TODAY.
GOOD LUCK THE REST OF THE WAY.
WE'LL TALK TO YOU SOON.
DREW: THANKS, GUYS.
I APPRECIATE IT.
SCOTT: THERE IT IS.
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME, DREW
SMYLY JOINING US ON YOUTUBE.
44%.
HE EDGES MARCELL OZUNA FOR THAT
TROPHY.
CUSTOM-DESIGNED.
YOU WOULD HAVE LIKED THAT.
MARK: ABSOLUTELY.
SCOTT: IT'S UNIQUE.
YOU WOULD BRING THAT HOME, KIDS
WOULD BE ALL OVER IT. SMYLY SHOE
TROPHY AND A BIG SMILE, A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE IN THE INTERVIEW.
WE'LL GET INTO IT ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF IT.
BRAVES WIN, 4-2.
♪
>> WHAT DID THE BABY CORN ASK
HIS MOM CORN?
WHERE'S MY POPCORN?
>> HOW DID THE HIPSTER BURN HIS
MOUTH?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> HE ATE THE PIZZA BEFORE IT
WAS COOL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I CAN'T LOOK AT YOUR FACE.
>> AND NOT LAUGH?
IS THAT A GOOD THING OR A BAD
THING?
>> FOR THIS GAME, IT'S A GOOD
THING, OR BAD THING FOR ME.
WHAT DID THE BIG FLOWER SAY TO
THE TINY FLOWER?
HEY THERE, BUD.
>> [LAUGHTER]
>> THERE'S NO WAY HE SHOULD GET
POINTS FOR ME LAUGHING AT HIS
LEFT.
>> -- HIS LAUGH.
>> WHAT DO YOU CALL IT WHEN
BATMAN SKIPS CHURCH?
>> ROBIN?
>> CHRISTIAN BALE.
>> I'M NOT LAUGHING AT THE JOKE.
I'M LAUGHING AT WHAT YOU DID.
♪
SCOTT: BRAVES SWEEP IN D.C.,
POSTGAME SHOW.
TO SHOW YOU HOW IT HAPPENED, WE
SHOW YOU THIS.
START OF THE FOURTH INNING FOR
ATLANTA.
SENT ONE TO LEFT AND WE'LL GET
TO WATCH HIM RUN THE BASES.
RONALD ACUNA JR. STARTS OFF THE
FOURTH WITH A BASE HIT, 111 OF
THE BAT FOR THAT SINGLE.
THERE HE GOES.
THE THROW SKIPS AWAY INTO
CENTER.
AND ACUNA'S OFF TO THIRD.
AND JUST LIKE THAT, ONE OF THE
FLASHIEST PLAYERS IN THE GAME,
90 FEET AWAY FROM THE FIRST RUN.
MARK: HE DOES NOT LIKE TO THROW
TO FIRST BASE.
RONALD ACUNA CAN STEAL FOR DAYS.
EVEN IF HE DOES THROW DOWN TO
JOSH BELL, I STILL THINK HE
BEATS THE TRANSFER TO SECOND.
HE'S PLAYING YOUTH BALL.
SCOTT: HE MISSED.
FIRST TWO HITTERS OF THE FRAME
ON BOARD FOR ATLANTA.
RUNNERS ON THE CORNERS, THAT
BRINGS US TO OZUNA.
OZUNA INTO THE CORNER, AND
THAT'S GOING TO SCORE THE FIRST
RUN OF THE DAY.
RONALD ACUNA JR. WILL TROT HOME
AND MARCELL OZUNA KNOCKS IN A
RUN FOR ATLANTA AT 1-0.
MARK: ACTUALLY A GREAT PITCH.
MARCELL OZUNA ALMOST KNOWS HE
WANTS TO GO TO THAT WELL TO ROLL
OVER TO THIRD FOR A DOUBLE PLAY,
KIND OF CHEATS TO THE SPOT,
KEEPS IT FAIR, 1-0 BRAVOS.
THEY ARE SET UP FOR A BEGINNING.
SCOTT: THAT'S SENT TO CENTER AND
THAT'S GOING TO FALL AND SCORE
AT LEAST ONE FOR ATLANTA.
SECOND ON ITS WAY.
SLIDE, OZUNA'S IN THERE.
ADRIANZA SCORES TWO FOR THE
BRAVES.
MAKE IT 3-0 AS ALBIES AND OZUNA
COME HOME.
IT'S KYLE SCHWARBER.
RIPS ONE INTO THE CORNER.
THERE'S A BASE HIT.
AND BELL HEADING TO THIRD, NOW
GOING TO COME HOME.
BOBBLED.
JOSH BELL IS GOING TO SCORE.
SHORT OR ENDS UP AT THIRD AND
IT'S 3-1.
-- WARBURG ENDS UP AT THIRD AND
LOOK WHO'S ALL OVER IT.
VICTOR ROBLES, BOTH CENTER
FIELDERS TODAY PUTTING ON A
SHOW.
LOOK AT ROBLES MOVE.
MARK: MADE THAT PLAY WITH EASE.
SCOTT: DRAMA IN THE LATE STAGES.
LET'S START WITH KYLE SCHWARBER
LEADING OFF A NINE PITCH WALK.
THAT WILL BE UP FOR DREW SMYLY,
BRILLIANT, WENT TO THE FASTBALL
EARLY AND OFTEN.
LUKE JACKSON IN, BUT VICTOR
ROBLES GREETS HIM WITH A BASE
HIT.
AND THEN DAVE MARTINEZ TURNS TO
JUAN SOTO.
MARK: AND 2-0 COUNT, CAP
LEVERAGE, KNEW -- COUNT
LEVERAGE, KNEW HE HAD TO THROW A
HITTER.
HE WAS ABLE TO WIGGLE OUT OF IT,
TOUGH DAY FOR TREA TURNER, AN
0-5, AND THEN MAKES A BIG
PITCH.
SCOTT: KEEPS THIS A TWO RUN
GAME.
NOW LET'S FAST-FORWARD TO THE
BOTTOM OF THE EIGHTH, WHERE JOSH
HARRISON LEADS OFF WITH AN
EXTRA-BASE HIT THAT WAS ALMOST
GONE.
CAN YOU GET MUCH CLOSER?
AND YOU HAD TO GO FOR THE TALL
PART AND RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
YAN GOMES SAYS COME ON DOWN.
KYLE SCHWARBER DOWN ON STRIKES.
AND THE VICTOR ROBLES -- THEN
VICTOR ROBLES.
PATIENT.
THAT'S A GOOD TAKE.
MARK: CANNOT BE A STRIKE AT THE
BIG-LEAGUE LEVEL.
CANNOT BE.
SCOTT: IT WOULD'VE BEEN RYAN
ZIMMERMAN WITH THE BASES LOADED.
ZIM IS HOT RIGHT NOW AT THE
PLATE, LOVES LEFT-HANDED
PITCHING.
THEY SAID, GONNA USE THAT.
INSTEAD, THE PINCH-HIT DOUBLE
LEADS TO STEPHENSON AS THE PINCH
RUNNER.
TREA TURNER WOULD FLY OUT TO
RIGHT FIELD.
STEVENSON MOVES UP.
HE'LL TAKE THIS.
THIS IS THE AT-BAT RIGHT HERE.
MARK: WILL SMITH IS TOUGH RIGHT
HERE, LEFT ON LEFT, TOUGH
MATCHUP.
SCOTT: GETS HIM WITH THE SLIDER.
MARK: JOSH HARRISON, JOSH IS ON
EVERYTHING RIGHT NOW.
SCOTT: THAT'S HOW THE BRAVES WIN
TODAY BY A RUN AND SWEEP THE
SERIES AGAINST THE WASHINGTON
NATIONALS, NOT JUST ONE GAME
UNDER THE .500 MARK, WHILE THE
NATS ARE THREE GAMES UNDER .500.
NO ONE OFF TO A SIZZLING START,
SO IT'S UP FOR ANYONE.
SAVANNA MCCANN AT THE BALLPARK,
WHAT DID YOU SEE TODAY?
SAVANNAH: THE BRACE SKIPPER HAS
SAID THE WAY -- BRAVES SKIPPER
SAID THE WAY THEY WERE PITCHING,
A SLOW START TO THE SEASON, BY
HOT SPRING.
ONCE DREW SMYLY GOT GOING, HE
KNEW THIS TEAM WOULD HAVE A
STARTING ROTATION AGAIN.
DREW SMYLY DID NOT DISAPPOINT.
HE TOSSED THE MOST FASTBALLS HE
HAD SINCE 2016, AND THAT'S WHAT
GOT THE BRAVES THEIR FIRST SWEEP
SINCE 2014.
THE BRAVES A RUN A THREE GAME
WINNING STREAK AND THEY HAD OVER
TO THE PHILLIES AT HOME, WHERE
THE NATS WILL TAKE ON THE
YANKEES IN THE BRONX.
SCOTT: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'RE HANGING HERE.
FIRST FOUR STARTS FOR DREW SMYLY
NOT PRETTY, 21 RUNS IN 19
INNINGS, NINE HOMERS ALLOWED,
HIGHEST HOME RUN RATE IN
BASEBALL.
HE SHOWS UP TODAY AND LOOKS LIKE
THE GUY --
MARK: HE WENT TO THAT FOUR-SEAM
WELL TIME IN AND TIMEOUT.
I'M ALWAYS ENAMORED.
THAT'S WHY I ASKED MAX SCHERZER
THAT, ALWAYS ENAMORED WHY THEY
CAN USE IT IN MIDDLE PORTIONS OF
THE INNINGS AND RECAPTURE IT
AGAIN.
BUT HE'S ALWAYS HAD THAT HEATER
THAT PLAYS UP.
GOING TO GIVE UP THE OCCASIONAL
HOME RUN BALL.
BUT THE WAY THE SHADOWS WERE AT
4:00 TODAY, MR. LESTER JUST WENT
TO WORK AT THE BOTTOM HALF OF
THE ZONE WITH THAT HEATER.
SCOTT: SLICING AND DICING,
GETTING SOME FAVORABLE CALLS
HERE AND THERE.
MARK: THAT'S TRUE, NO DOUBT.
SCOTT: IT'S FRUSTRATING.
MARK: THE NATS HAD THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES, SOME MATCHUPS I
DON'T THINK THEY NECESSARILY --
LET'S SAY IN A POSTSEASON GAME
OR DOWN THE STRETCH IN
SEPTEMBER, YOU'VE GOT A
SITUATION WHERE YOU HAVE JUAN
SOTO TO THE PLATE IN A 2-0 COUNT
, LUKE JACKSON, DOESN'T GET ANY
MORE FAVORABLE.
SCOTT: AND SOTO'S GOING TO BE
BACK EVERY DAY FOR THE NATIONAL
SOON.
HE'LL BE HITTING BECAUSE THEY
D.H.
NATS JUST FISHING FOR W'S.
THEY DIDN'T FIND ONE TODAY.
MUCH MORE ON THE POSTGAME SHOW.
THAT'S NEXT.
>> IF COWS DON'T HAVE INTERNET,
HOW DO THEY ORDER THINGS?
FROM A CATALOG.
>> [LAUGHTER]
THAT'S GOOD.
WHICH STATE HAS REALLY SMALL
SOFT DRINKS?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> MINNESOTA.
>> [LAUGHTER]
>> GOT A CHANCE TO CLINCH THEIR
THIRD STRAIGHT N.L. EAST
TONIGHT.
GET THE JOB DONE.
>> OZUNA HITS A SOLO HOMER!
BOMBS AWAY IN ATLANTA, GA.
THREE MORE HOME RUNS TONIGHT.
>> IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
FIREPOWER, YOU'VE COME TO THE
RIGHT PLACE.
THE BRAVES ARE PILING THEM ON,
11-1.
>> THEY'RE THE CHAMPIONS OF THE
EAST IN 2020.
SCOTT: BRAVES THREE, NATIONALS
TWO, POSTGAME SHOW PRESENTED BY
GLOBAL CITIZEN VAX LIFE.
AND THAT SHOW IS ON SATURDAY
NIGHT, 8:00 EASTERN.
WE HAD A SHOW, PERSONALLY FOR
US, IT WAS CALLED THE JOSH
HARRISON MIKED UP SHOW ALL DAY
LONG.
JOSH: TWO HANDS.
I DROPPED A COUPLE POP-UPS.
WHAT'S UP, BABY?
RODRIGUEZ SAYS YOU ARE THE MOST
ATHLETIC CATCHER YOU EVER PLAYED
WITH.
I MIKED UP.
IF YOU'RE TO SAY HIGH TO
YOUTUBE, SAY HI.
REVIEW MIC'D UP, TOO?
I'M RIGHT WITH YOU.
I THOUGHT I GOT HIM.
THE BALL WAS KIND OF LIKE A
CHANGEUP.
ANYTIME THEY THROW UP THE LINE
-- IT WAS OF THE LINE JUST A
LITTLE BIT.
THAT BALL CAME OUT LIKE A
CHANGEUP, HUH?
YEAH, NAH.
PERFECT THROW, THOUGH, TAG
RIGHT THERE.
THAT BAD BOY WENT WAY FARTHER.
I THOUGHT IT WAS RIGHT THERE.
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN BAD RIGHT
THERE.
I MEAN, GOING TO PICK IT, I GOT
CAUGHT IN THE SHIN.
A.C.L., I.L.
I AIN'T GOT NO POP.
THAT'S GONE IN PROBABLY 27 OTHER
PARKS.
I'LL TELL YOU WHERE IT AIN'T
GONE, HERE IN DETROIT.
SCOTT: TWO HITS, HITTING
EVERYTHING ON THIS CRUISE, AND
EVEN THAT IN-DEPTH -- ON THE
SCREWS, AND EVEN THAT IN-DEPTH.
JOSH HARRISON, WHAT DID YOU
THINK?
JOSH: NO, NO!
COME ON!
WOW!
SCOTT: SO, YOU DISAGREE?
TAHT'S PASSION.
HE'S BEEN PLAYING FOR A WHILE.
THIS IS EARLY MAY BASEBALL, NATS
IN A FIGHT FOR THE DIVISION.
HE'S BEEN GREAT, .329, ON-BASE
PERCENTAGE OVER .400, YOU'RE A
STAR.
ALMOST AS MANY WALKS AS
STRIKEOUTS.
ADDING TO THE TOOLS HE BRINGS TO
THE TABLE, HE CAN TALK, FUN TO
LISTEN TO COME ENTERTAINING.
-- LISTEN TO, ENTERTAINING.
THAT CALL IN THE EIGHTH INNING,
MAYBE THE PLAY OF THE GAME, THE
PITCH OF THE GAME, TO GET THAT
REACTION, THAT'S THE GOOD STUFF.
MARK: BATTLING EVERY DAY.
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE BIG LEAGUER
-- YOU TELL YOURSELF TO THINGS
AS A POSITION PLAYER COMING INTO
THE SEASON.
I WANT TO STAY HEALTHY AND I
DON'T WANT TO GIVE AWAY AN
AT-BAT.
I DON'T WANT TO GIVE AWAY ONE.
TO HAVE IT TAKEN FOR YOU AND A
BIG SPOT AGAINST A DIVISIONAL
FOE, YOU ARE SEEING THE REACTION
.
SCOTT: HOW WOULD YOU HAVE
REACTED TO THAT?
THE PG VERSION.
MARK: I PROBABLY WOULD HAVE TO
GET EJECTED FROM THAT GAME.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT PITCH WAS
SIMILAR TO THE AUSTIN RILEY
PITCH.
IT IS NOT EVEN CLOSE.
CURVEBALL SPINNING DOWN, I DON'T
CARE WHERE IT CROSSES.
THAT BALL IS BELOW THE ZONE.
SCOTT: GOT SOMETHING SPECIAL
WE'RE BRINGING TO THE POSTGAME
SHOW.
STARTING TODAY, IT'S CALLED
CURIOUS CREATORS.
MARK WAS 5-19, TWO DOUBLES AND A
HOMER.
LESTER K'S HIM FOUR TIMES.
MARK: I SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH
JOHN.
HE LIVES IN THE ATLANTA AREA.
PLAYED A LOT OF ROUNDS OF GOLF,
BEEN ON VACATIONS.
PHENOMENAL HUMAN BEING ON AND
OFF THE FIELD.
SCOTT: YOU SAW HIM DECENTLY, DID
SOME THINGS.
MARK: HE'S COMING TO GET YOU.
CUTTER IN, CHANGEUP AWAY, NOT
TOO DIFFERENT FROM WHAT HE
FEATURED TODAY, JUST MAYBE THREE
OR FOUR MILES PER HOUR FASTER.
SCOTT: STILL, SEEING IT, 37
YEARS OLD, PICKING HIS SPOTS.
COMMAND IS THERE, LOOKING LIKE
HE CAN BE A SERVICEABLE NUMBER
FOUR STARTER.
MARK: RUN IT OUT TO THE MOUND,
LESTER.
SCOTT: THE INNINGS, TOO.
STRASBURG'S HURT RIGHT NOW.
WHAT ELSE IS GOING ON AROUND
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL?
HEY, NOBODY WATCHES THE GAME
LIKE MARK DEROSA, EVERY SINGLE
NIGHT YOU ARE LOCKED IN.
MARK: MR. MEANS, MEANS OT AN
END.
FASTBALL-CHANGEUP COMBO, HE WAS
AWESOME.
SCOTT: HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
ALBERT PUJOLS CUT I THE ANGELS.
MARK: I NEED TO DIVE INTO THIS.
SCOTT: GIVE ME YOUR QUICK TAKE.
MARK: HOW DO YOU RELEASE ONE OF
YOUR GREAT PLAYERS -- REGARDLESS
-- I DON'T SAY HE MAYBE DOESN'T
DESERVE TO BE ON THE ROSTER
ANYMORE, IT'S THE WAY THEY'RE
DOING IT.
THERE'S MORE TO THIS.
SCOTT: I'M ALBERT.
I COME TO YOU.
YOU'RE THE G.M.
I ONE OUT TO SEE IF I CAN PLAY
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
MARK: I UNDERSTAND THAT.
I'LL HONOR THAT AND I DO BELIEVE
JARED WALSH AND OHTANI ARE GOING
TO STEAL MOST OF YOUR AT-BATS
THIS YEAR.
I'VE ALSO GIVEN YOU 10 YEARS,
$240 MILLION, SO LET'S DO THIS
THE RIGHT WAY.
LET COOLER HEADS PREVAIL.
WE'LL TAKE YOU OUT OF TONIGHT'S
LINEUP AND LET'S SIT DOWN.
LET'S NOT BE BRASH AND SAY WE'RE
GOING TO DESIGNATE YOU FOR
ASSIGNMENT AND THE WHOLE WORLD
IS WONDERING -- COME ON.
LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS.
YOU DON'T GET TO JUST DESIGNATE
THIS.
SCOTT: ANGELS HAVE NO PLAYOFF
W'S WITH PUJOLS.
MIKE TROUT, THAT'S ON THEIR MIND
EVERY SINGLE DAY, ANGELS FANS
THINKING ABOUT IT.
AND JARED WALSH IS A GOOD
LOOKING PLAYER, SHOULD BE IN
THERE EVERY DAY AT FIRST BASE.
MARK: NOBODY IS DENYING THE FACT
THAT ALBERT'S LOST A STEP.
NOBODY IS DENYING THERE ARE SOME
DIFFERENT OPTIONS ON THE ANGELS
THAT CAN PROVIDE HIM A CHANCE ON
THE OFFENSIVE SIDE.
BUT WHAT ALBERT'S MEANT TO THE
GAME OF BASEBALL, THIS WAS
BIZARRE TO ME.
AGAIN, I'M GOING TO GET INTO IT.
SCOTT: HE'S ON MLB NETWORK EVERY
DAY.
CAN'T WAIT TO WATCH IT.
LAST THING BEFORE WE GET OFF
HERE, DOES HE PLAY AGAIN FOR
ANOTHER TEAM?
MARK: I THINK HE DOES.
IF HE'S RAISING CAIN ABOUT
WANTING TO BE IN THE LINEUP, I
CAN THINK OF -- I JUST THINK
GUYS LIKE THAT SHOULD BE ABLE TO
GO OUT ON THEIR OWN TERMS,
WHETHER THAT'S TONY LA RUSSA IN
CHICAGO, BACK TO ST. LOUIS FOR A
FAREWELL TOUR, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
IT IS.
BUT I KNOW ALBERT'S MEANT TO THE
GAME.
MIGGY, ALBERT, MANNY -- I'M
GOING TO LEAVE A FEW UP, MY
GENERATION COMING UP.
HE WAS THE GUY.
SCOTT: DID YOU HAVE FUN?
WE LOVED HAVING YOU.
COME BACK SOMEDAY?
MARK: WOULD LOVE TO.
SCOTT: MARK DEROSA, SUPERSTAR
UTILITYMAN.
WE'LL DO THIS AGAIN.
JOSH HARRISON WAS AWESOME.
GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE NEXT WEEK,
THURSDAY, MAY 13, CARDINALS AND
BREWERS.
COVERAGE BEGINS WITH THE PREGAME
SHOW AT 12:30 EASTERN.
SEE YOU THEN.
MARK DEROSA BRINGING IT TODAY.
OUR ENTIRE SUPERSTAR CREW, I'M
SCOTT BRAUN LINING OUT FOR NOW.
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]